few moments the the senate television
studio is sending us a picture right now
the senate floor will see that as we
finish things up with with steve marcy
let me conclude by asking we've talked
about the relationships going going on
between various groups describe for us
the relationship between the republicans
from the house and the senate and how
republican senators are reacting to what
their colleagues from the house are
telling them
well they apparently are
thinking that they're making a good and
effective case but for the most part
they aren't really telling us what they
themselves think of the strength of the
case everybody republicans and democrats
alike have been saying have been uh a
bit loathe to go ahead at this
particular point so early in the process
to make up their minds remember we have
still three days of testimony left
tuesday wednesday and thursday from the
uh how from the white house uh legal
team and everybody's waiting to see what
they're going to say and i really don't
think anybody is anywhere close to
making up their minds yet how easy or
difficult is this a story to cover well
it's been a fairly difficult story to
cover sometimes because because of the
security uh with the chief justice
presiding
it's they've cut down some of the access
that we normally have and it's made it a
little bit more difficult and trickier
to get to and talk to some of the
senators to find out what they're really
thinking steve marcy of bridge news one
of the reporters covering the story on
capitol hill as always steve thanks very
much for taking a few minutes for us
thank you
we are going to in a few moments be
bringing you live gavel to gavel
coverage of today's session of the u.s
senate it's the third day of the
impeachment trial of the president i'd
like to remind you this will be live on
c-span 2 and tonight at 8 p.m today's
session will re-air in its entirety on
our companion network on c-span that
will also happen next week when the
president's defense council begin their
arguments live on c-span 2 during the
day when the senate's in session and
re-airing each night on c-span at 8pm
eastern time up next live coverage of
the u.s senate
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
gracious god you have given us
magnificent promises to claim today
you have told us that if we wait on you
we will renew our strength
you have assured us that you will use
our minds to think clearly in response
to your inspiration
courage is offered
patience provided
and wisdom engendered
in this quiet moment
grant the senators your power to
persevere
your peace for equipoise
your judgment for the evaluation of the
facts presented
and your will to guide their decisions
as you have blessed us with this day
we praise you that you will show the way
through our lord and savior
amen amen
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
the majority leader is recognized mr
chief justice it is my understanding
that the house managers intend to extend
their presentation until approximately 3
pm
with a lunch break at approximately 12
40 or 12 45.
i remind all senators to remain standing
at the desk each time the chief justice
enters and departs the chamber we want
to maintain
the very best decorum
one other point uh we had been scheduled
to go from 1005 straight through to 12
40 but we will probably take a very
short 10 minute break after the
presentation by manager graham it would
be very important members
attend the business and return promptly
to the chamber so that we can complete
activity as early as possible this
afternoon i yield the four mr chief
justice
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date personal to the provisions of
senate resolution 16 the managers for
the house of representatives have 15
hours and 37 minutes remaining to make
the presentation of their case the case
will now hear you rather the senate will
now hear you the presiding officer
recognizes mr manager boyer
i thank you miss chief mr chief justice
thank the senators the council to the
president
i am steve boyer a house manager from
the fifth district of indiana i want to
thank all of you
for your attention
the past several days it has not been
it has not been easy for the house
managers to argue from a dry record
i ask for your patience
the house managers are prepared to call
witnesses and offer developed evidence
as the trial proceeds
this morning the managers on the part of
the house are going to present why the
offenses you have been hearing over the
course of the last several days
require the president's removal from
office
i will discuss why the offenses attack
the judicial system which is a core
function of the government and how
perjury and obstruction of justice are
not private acts these are public crimes
and therefore quintessential impeachable
offenses
for the president's premeditated assault
on the administration of justice
must be interpreted as a threat to our
system of government
i will be followed by mr manager graham
of south carolina who will discuss the
precedence and impeachment cases and
then he will be followed by mr manager
kennedy
will discuss how the felonies constitute
high crimes and misdemeanors as
envisioned by the founding fathers and
why they warrant his removal from office
while this is day three of our
presentation it is important for the
senate to be fully informed as to the
facts the law and the consequences
please indulge me for a quick
reiteration of the facts
on may 27 1997 nine justices of the
supreme court of the united states
unanimously ruled that mrs jones could
pursue her federal civil rights actions
against william jefferson clinton on
december 11 1997 united states district
court judge susan weber wright ordered
president clinton to provide mrs jones
with answers to certain routine
questions relevant to the lawsuit
acting under the authority of these
court orders mrs jones exercised her
rights rights every litigant has under
our system of justice
she sought answers from president
clinton to help prove her case against
him just as president clinton sought and
received answers from her
president clinton used numerous means
then to prevent her from getting
truthful answers
on december 17 1997 president clinton
encouraged a witness to file a false
affidavit in the case and to testify
falsely if she were called to testify in
this case why
because her truthful testimony would
have helped mrs jones
and hurt his case
on december 23 1997 he provided under
oath
false written answers to mrs jones
questions on december 18 1997 president
clinton began an effort to get the
witnesses to conceal evidence that would
have helped mrs jones
throughout this period he intensified
efforts to provide the witness with help
in getting a job to ensure that she
carried out his designs
on january 17 1998
president clinton provided under oath
numerous false answers to mrs jones
questions during that deposition in the
civil case in the days immediately
following the deposition president
clinton provided a false and misleading
account to another witness
his secretary betty curry in hopes that
she would substantiate the false
testimony he gave in the deposition
all of these unlawful actions denied mrs
jones her rights as a litigant
subverted the fundamental truth-seeking
function of the united states district
court for the eastern district of
arkansas and violated president
clinton's constitutional oath to
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states
and further it violated his
constitutional duty
to take care that the laws be faithfully
executed
beginning shortly after his deposition
president clinton became aware that the
federal grand jury empaneled by the
united states district court for the
district of columbia was investigating
his unlawful actions before and during
his civil deposition was the scope of
inquiry
president clinton made numerous false
statements to potential grand jury
witnesses in hopes that they would
repeat these statements to the grand
jury
on august 17 1998 president clinton
appeared before the grand jury by video
under oath
and he provided numerous false answers
to questions asked
these actions impeded the grand jury's
investigation it subverted the
fundamental truth-seeking function of
the united states district court for the
district of columbia and they also
violated president clinton's
constitutional oath
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states and
his constitutional duty as the chief
executive officer to take care that the
laws be faithfully executed
now you will hear
next week
perhaps from the president's lawyers
that the offenses charged by the house
are not impeachable
in other words that even if the
allegations that set forth in the
articles of impeachment are true
so what
you see
the house managers have began to refer
this to as the so what defense
i'm not offended by the so what defense
because if that's all you have
then try it
you see there are only a few basic ways
that you can actually defend a case
you can defend the case on the facts
you can defend the case on the law
you can defend a case on the facts and
the law
now here we hear we hear in this case we
hear very often that the facts are
indefensible
and you also hear that
if you're not going to call witnesses
on the facts
then i guess you better argue on the law
so then what is the argument on the law
what you do then in defending of a case
is you argue procedure
you attack the prosecutor
you attempt to confuse those who sit in
judgment on the laws so you don't follow
your precedent
you go out and obtain from your
political allies and friends in the
academic world to sign a letter saying
that the offenses as alleged in the
articles of impeachment do not rise to
the level of an impeachable offense
you see this rise to the level has
somehow become the legal cliche
of this case
you've all also often heard it
and you've even some have even spoken it
you see the house managers chose not to
go out
into the academic world and obtain
signatures on our own letter
that would have said why the offenses
are impeachable
and then we would have had this war of
dueling academics they have a letter of
400 signatures we get a letter of 400
signatures they add 500 to it now they
have 900 we go out and get a thousand we
chose not to do that
you know why
because the house managers have the
precedence of the senate
on our side
we have the precedence of the senate
mr manager graham will discuss those
precedents
now if i'm prosecuting a defendant of
perjury
at obstruction of justice
in white county superior court before
judge bob murslack in monticello indiana
and i have this perjury and obstruction
of justice case
on a thursday
and i know that the judge has three
other cases he's got a case on monday
he's got a case on tuesday he's got a
case on wednesday
so i'm watching
what the judge is going to do because
i'm curious with regard to the precedent
so on monday of that week judge murslack
tries a case of a public official for
perjury
and i watch what he does
he convicts him for perjury
on tuesday he tries a public official
for obstruction of justice
and he convicts him
on wednesday
judge murslack tries a public official
for grand jury perjury
and he convicts him
my case now comes up on third thursday
for a public official for obstruction of
justice
and grand jury perjury and perjury on
top of perjury
i would say that based on the precedence
that it's not looking good for the
defendant that i'm about to prosecute
now the white house lawyers are hoping
that those of you who have voted
those of you in this chamber that have
voted
to remove federal judges for similar
offenses in the past
that you have a feigned memory
and if you don't have a feigned memory
then we'll try to confuse you
they will attempt to confuse you on the
law
so when i hear the so what
well
it is the position of the house that
what the president did does matter
that by his actions the president did
commit high crimes and misdemeanors
the house is prepared to establish that
the president william jefferson clinton
willfully and repeatedly violated the
rule of law and abused the trust placed
upon him by the american people
now let me address how the offenses
charged in the articles of impeachment
attacked the judicial system
the offenses as charged in the articles
of impeachment again against our system
of government are the core of the
concept of high crimes and misdemeanors
you see perjury and obstruction of
justice are therefore quintessential
impeachable offenses
indeed it is precisely their public
nature that makes them offenses
acts
that are not crimes when committed
outside the judicial realm become crimes
when they enter the judicial realm
lying to one's spouse about an
extramarital affair is not a crime it is
a public matter
excuse me it strike that it is a private
matter
but telling that same lie under oath
before a federal judge as a defendant in
a civil rights sexual harassment lawsuit
is a crime
against the state and is therefore a
public matter
hiding gifts
given to conceal the affair is not a
crime
it is a private matter
but when those gifts are the subject of
a court-ordered subpoena in a sexual
harassment lawsuit the act of hiding the
gifts becomes a crime against the state
called obstruction of justice
and is therefore
a public matter
our law has consistently recognized that
perjury subverts the judicial process
it strikes at our nation's most
fundamental value
the rule of law
in commentaries on laws of england sir
william blackstone differentiated
between crimes that quote
more directly infringe the rights of the
public or commonwealth taken in its
collective capacity
and
those which in a more peculiar manner
injure individuals or private subjects
this book was widely recognized by the
founding fathers such as james madison
he described blackstone's work at the
time as quote
a book which is in every man's
hand blackstone's private category
contained crimes such as murder burglary
and arson
the public category however he catalyzed
catalog crimes that could be understood
as an assault upon the state
within a sub-category denominated quote
offenses against public justice end
quote
blackstone included the crimes of
perjury and bribery in fact in his
catalog of public justice
offenses
blackstone placed perjury and bribery
side by side
now in the constitution
article 2 section 4
when you read the impeachment clause
the president
vice president and all civil officers of
the united states
shall be removed from office
on impeachment for and conviction of
treason
bribery
comma
or other high crimes and misdemeanors
so what did they mean when they thought
other high crimes
i would submit to you
that perjury
obstruction of justice
fits in this category of other high
crimes
perjury and bribery are side by side
you know hypothetically
hypothetically
if when
william jefferson clinton
sat at the table in the civil deposition
in the jones versus clinton case
and as alleged in the
record
that he perjured himself
speaking hypothetically
if he had then
offered judge susan weber wright
a cash bribe
there would be no question
in this body
what we must what you must do
but what i'm saying
unto all of you
is that
there is no difference here
and that's the pain of this case
there is no difference between a cash
bribe
or
sitting before a federal judge
and one and perjuring oneself
whether it be in the underlying civil
deposition or in fact the grand jury
perjury
perjury and bribery are side by side
mr kent mr manager kennedy will develop
that further
the constitution also recognizes
that truth-telling under oath is central
to the maintenance of our republic
we're all familiar with the constitution
this is in its handwritten glory
you know the the founders they took such
pride in the oath
that it's mentioned here in the
constitution on five separate occasions
not the least of which is the
president's own oath to defend the
constitution
article 1 section 3 sets forth the
requirement
that the senate be under oath when
trying the cases of impeachment
and i witnessed
as that occurred
article two section one specifically
prescribes the oath which must be taken
before our president enter the execution
of his office
the right against self-incrimination
under the constitution derives in some
measure from the republic's interest in
preserving the truth-telling oath
you see forced testimony is forbidden
because it might lead to many
to violate their most solemn obligations
and over time weaken the essential civic
norm
of the fidelity
to that oath
fidelity
the framers took significance of the
oath very very seriously
the crime of perjury was among the few
offenses that the first congress
outlawed by statute as they met
and that affirms the framers view of the
seriousness
in 1790 in a statute entitled
quote an act for the punishment of
certain crimes against the united states
end quote
congress made the crime of perjury
punishable by imprisonment of up to
three years
a fine of up to eight hundred dollars
disqualification from giving future
testimony
and standing in the pillory
for one hour
now
today we don't force individuals
convicted of perjury to stand in the
pillary
for up to one hour
today perjury is punishable by up to
five years imprisonment in a federal
penitentiary if you perjure yourself in
the federal jurisdiction
likewise the supreme court has
repeatedly noted the extent to which
perjury subverts the judicial process
and thus the rule of law
for example
in 1976
in the case of the united states versus
mandujana
the supreme court emphasized quote
that perjured testimony is an obvious
and flagrant affront to the basic
concepts of judicial proceedings
effective restraints against this type
of egregious offense are therefore
imperative
hence congress has made the giving of
false answers a criminal act punishable
by severe penalties
in no other way can criminal conduct
be flushed into the open where law can
deal with it
end quote
moreover it is obvious that any
testimony given to a grand jury must be
truthful for the grand jury process is
in fact the truth-seeking process of our
criminal justice system
as the supreme court stated in 1911 in
the case of glickstein versus the united
states
quote
it cannot be conceived that there is
power to compel the giving of testimony
where no right exists to require that
the testimony shall be given under such
circumstances and safeguards as to
compel it to be truthful
end quote
indeed giving false material testimony
to a grand jury
perjuring oneself
totally destroys the value of one's
testimony and interferes with the
ability of a grand jury to accomplish
its mission
which again is to find the truth
perjury before a grand jury is a crime
against our system of government and the
american people
and in the case before us
this is a case of perjury
upon perjury
before the grand jury president clinton
testified that the testimony that he
gave
in the underlying
civil case of jones versus clinton in a
civil deposition that it was truthful
we submit that that is a lie
so what we have is perjury on perjury
you may hear that the president's
lawyers remarked that the view of the
founders is quaint
not really applicable to these settings
today
let's look at a few very recent examples
to see if the view of the seriousness of
telling the truth under oath as
envisioned by the founding fathers has
changed any here today
in the case of the united states versus
landy in the eastern district of
virginia in 1997
the defendant was convicted on two
counts of perjury
one for lying in a declaration she made
during a civil forfeiture case and the
other for lying to the grand jury in a
related criminal investigation
here's what the judge said in this case
the defendant committed perjury on two
separate occasions there can be no
question of it being done by mistake
the perjury is perhaps one of the most
serious offenses that can be committed
against the court itself
and the court does not believe that it's
appropriate to consider probation
in the case of somebody who's convicted
of perjury
in the second case
the united states versus vincent bono
in the district of new hampshire
in 1998
the defendant was found guilty of lying
before a grand jury
in trying to cover his stepson
involvement
in a robbery that the grand jury was
investigating
here's what the judge had to say about
lying before a grand jury
as a matter of policy they meaning
congress
they don't want people lying to grand
juries
they particularly don't want people
lying to grand juries about criminal
offenses
they particularly don't want people
lying to grand juries about criminal
offenses that are being investigated
they don't like that
and congress has said
we as a people are going to tell you if
you do that you are going to jail
and you are going to jail for a long
time
and if you don't get the message we'll
send you to jail again
maybe others will
but we
we are not going to have people coming
to grand juries and telling lies because
of their children
their mothers or their fathers or
themselves
it is just not acceptable the system
can't work that way
end quote
in another case in the united states
versus ronald blackley in the district
of columbia here in 1998
the defendant
was the former chief of staff to the
secretary of the united states
department of agriculture
the defendant was found guilty at trial
on three counts of making false
statements to the grand jury in
connection with his official duties
here's what the judge had to say in this
case
in my view providing a false statement
under oath
is a serious offense
the fact that the proceeding is civil or
administrative does not make the crime
less serious
we cannot fairly administer any kind of
system of justice in this country
if we do not penalize those who lie
under oath
the defendant stands before me as a
high-ranking government official
convicted of making false statements
under oath
this is such a serious crime but it
demands an even longer term of
imprisonment in this court's view
this court has a duty to send a message
to other high-level government officials
that there is a severe penalty to be
paid for providing false information
under oath
there is strong reason to there is a
strong reason to deter such conduct and
dispel all of the nonsense that is being
publicly discussed and debated about the
seriousness of lying under oath by
government officials
a democracy like ours depends on people
having trust in our government and its
officials end quote
you see there are many other cases and
you can go to your lexus and westlaw and
you can research them
these three cases make a very make it
very clear
that lying under oath is as serious
today in the 106th congress as it was in
1790 in the first congress when it
enacted the perjury statute
the first congress recognized the
seriousness of perjury and its attack on
the judicial system
now i'd like to discuss article two
which is the obstruction of justice
and how it is an attack on our judicial
system
in either a criminal or a civil case
obstruction undermines the judicial
system's ability to vindicate legal
rights
if it is allowed to go unchecked
then the system will become a farce and
ultimately a test
of which side is better at using
underhanded methods
accordingly
federal courts have called the federal
obstruction justice statute quote one of
the most important laws ever adopted in
that it prevents the miscarriage of
justice
this is black's law dictionary
black's law dictionary defines
obstruction of justice
as impeding or obstructing those who
will seek justice in a court or those
who have duties or powers of
administering justice therein
it's very clear
not only is obstruction of justice in
its own
a crime in the federal code
but in addition
the federal sentencing guidelines
the federal sentencing guidelines
increase the sentence of a convicted
defendant who is willfully obstructed
was willfully obstructed or impeded or
attempted to obstruct or impede the
administration
of justice during the investigation
prosecution or sentencing of his offense
the commentary on the guidelines
specifically list is examples of
obstructions actions the house alleges
that president clinton has inc has
committed
including
committing suborning or attempting to
suborn perjury destroying or concealing
or directing procuring another person to
destroy or conceal evidence that is
material to an official investigation or
judicial proceeding
and yesterday you learned from mr
manager mccullum of florida
when he discussed that perjury and
obstruction of justice
is punished more severely in the federal
sentencing guidelines than bribery
and again as i stated earlier blackstone
put bribery and perjury side by side
at a hearing on the background of the
history of impeachment as part of the
house impeachment inquiry
we were privileged to have the testimony
of judge griffin bell
an individual who has highly
distinguished himself in public service
judge bell was appointed to the federal
bench by president john kennedy
and he served as the united states
attorney general under president carter
judge bell said that quote
i have thought about this a great deal
this is a serious matter
trifling with the federal courts is
serious
and i guess i am biased because i used
to be a federal judge
but i cannot imagine
that it wouldn't be a serious crime to
lie in a federal grand jury
or to lie before a federal judge
and that is where i come down
judge bell went on to say
quote
and all the civil rights cases
that i was in in the south
depended on the integrity of the federal
court
and the federal court orders and people
telling
truth
and fairness
truth and fairness are the two essential
elements in a justice system
and of all the statutes i mentioned
perjury temporary tampering
with a witness
obstruction of justice all deal in the
interests of truth
if we don't have truth in the judicial
process
and in the court system in our country
we don't have anything
we don't have a system
as you can see according to judge bell
truth
and fairness
are two cornerstones of our judicial
system
president clinton violated both
of these bedrock principles
finally judge bell
spoke to the issue if a president ever
was convicted of a felony
judge bell stated quote
if the president were indicted
and convicted
of a felony such as perjury or
obstruction of justice or witness
tampering before impeachment proceedings
began
would anyone argue that he should
continue to be president
i don't think so
if the president were subsequently
indicted and convicted of a felony
which judge bell believes the
constitution clearly allows
he went on to say would anyone argue
that he should continue to be president
i don't think so
he stated this
he said a president cannot
faithfully execute the laws
if he himself
is breaking them
judge bell hit it right on the head
judge bell said a president cannot
faithfully execute the laws if he
himself is breaking them
if
strike the word if
the statutes against perjury
obstruction of justice and witness
tampering
rest on vouchsafing the element of truth
in judicial proceedings
judge bell stated
he went on to say that civil and
criminal cases in particular
and also the grand jury
allegations of this kind are grave
indeed end quote
to borrow the words of constitutional
scholar charles j cooper the crimes of
perjury and obstruction of justice like
the crimes of treason and bribery are
quintessentially offenses against our
system of government
visiting injury immediately on society
itself
whether or not committed in connection
with the exercise of official government
powers
i believe all of you should have these
charts
at your table
in a society governed by the rule of law
perjury and obstruction of justice
simply cannot be tolerated because these
crimes subvert the very judicial process
on which the rule of law so vitally
depends
you can take
this it is no exaggeration to say that
our constitution and the american people
entrust to the president singular
responsibility for the enforcing of the
rule of law
perjury and obstruction of justice
strike at the heart of the rule of law
a president who has committed these
crimes has plainly and directly violated
the most important executive duty
the core of the president's
constitutional responsibilities is his
duty to take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
and because perjury and obstruction of
justice strike at the rule of law itself
it is difficult to imagine crimes that
more clearly or directly violate this
core presidential constitutional duty
when president clinton had the
opportunity to personally uphold the
rule of law
to uphold the truth seeking function of
the courts
to uphold the fairness
in a judicial proceeding
he failed
far from taking care that the laws be
faithfully executed
if a president
is guilty of perjury and obstruction of
justice
he himself
faithlessly subverted the very law
that the rest of us are called upon
to obey
you may hear arguments that perjury and
obstruction
don't really have much consequence in
this case
because it was a private matter
and therefore
not really a serious offense
i would like to arm you
with the facts
the courts do not trivialize
perjury and obstruction of justice
according to the united states
sentencing commission in 1997 182
americans were sentenced in federal
court for committing perjury
also in 1997 144 americans were
sentenced to federal court for
obstruction and witness tampering
states in state jurisdictions all across
this country they take the matter very
seriously
i've chosen one state the state of
california
they brought 4 318 perjury prosecutions
in 1997
there are now at least 115 persons
serving sentences for perjury in federal
prisons
where is the fairness to these americans
if they stay in jail and the president
stays in the oval office
if the allegations in the independent
council's referral were made
against a sitting federal judge
would not the senate convict
if william jefferson clinton were a
sitting judge
instead of the president
would not the senate convict
while my colleague mr manager graham
will look into this further let's look
briefly at precedent for the moment
when we bring up the issues regarding
the impeachment of former federal judges
mr claiborne and mr nixon
one standard was used
high crimes and misdemeanors
the senate said
one standard that applies to the
president and vice president will also
apply
to these federal judges and other civil
officers
you see in the defense
of judges claiborne and nixon the
defense lawyers at the time in the trial
here in the senate argued that federal
judges should be treated differently
from the president
that they could not be impeached for
private misbehavior because it was
extrajudicial
the senate rejected that proposition as
incompatible with common sense and the
orderly conduct of government you
rejected that argument
the very same argument that we will
about to hear perhaps from the white
house
defense team
and i believe
this senate
will uphold your precedent
the precedent that federal judges and
the president should be treated by the
same standard
impeachment for high crimes
and misdemeanors
also
do not be tempted
to believe the argument that lying under
oath about sex
doesn't matter
that it's private
i covered that earlier
but i want to bring you our attention as
some of the house managers did yesterday
about american law
it makes rape a crime
domestic violence a crime
sexual harassment
a civil rights violation
libel a compensable offense
without the protections of perjury and
obstruction
none of the rights of the victims of
such cases
could be vindicated
that's why the courts take these matters
so seriously
if the president's lawyers try to tell
you that this case is simply about an
illicit affair
i believe that it demeans our civil
rights laws
if indeed the president is successful in
trying to make everyone believe that
this case is only about an illicit
affair
what will the message be in this
hollowed body to those who've in the
past been passionate advocates of our
civil rights laws
whether it be by race
gender
religion disability
if the evidence gathering process is
unimportant in federal civil rights
sexual harassment lawsuits
remember that
was the underlying basis of this case
what message does that send to women in
america
there are some important questions we
need to ask
our sexual harassment lawsuits
which were designed to vindicate
legitimate and serious civil rights
grievances of women across america now
somewhat less
important
than other civil rights
which of our civil rights laws will fall
next
will we soon decide that the
evidence-gathering process is
unimportant with respect to vindicating
the rights of the disabled under the
americans with disabilities act
will the evidence-gathering process
become unimportant with respect to
vindicating the voting rights of those
discriminated against based on race or
national origin
who will tell
the hundreds of federal judges across
the nation that the evidence gathering
process in these cases is now
unimportant
consider postal worker diane parker who
is convicted of perjury and
sentenced to 13 months in prison for
making a false material declaration
during the discovery deposition in a
sexual harassment lawsuit
judge lacey collier said
one of the most troubling things in our
society today
is people who raise their hands
take the oath to tell the truth and then
fail to do that
this is i hope
is the finished punishment for you the
judge stated the judge went on to say
but more importantly i hope that it is a
deterrence to others so your story can
be taken far and wide to demonstrate
to others the seriousness of the
responsibility of telling the truth in
court proceedings
the senate must now determine whether it
is acceptable or whether it is
appropriate to set a precedent to have
an individual serve as president of the
united states
when that individual has committed has
alleged to have committed
serious offenses
against our system of government while
holding
that office
while we've been discussing how perjury
and obstruction of justice are attacks
on our judicial system
we must recognize how the judicial
system is a core function
of the government
when mr manager henry hyde speaks of the
rule of law protecting us from the knock
on the door at three am
what exactly
was he referring to
well in totalitarian societies
rulers may drag the rule
off to prison at any time for any reason
our system differs because we require
our leaders to go through a judicial
procedure before they put someone in
prison or otherwise violate their
individual rights
the president's offenses
assault the administration of this
judicial procedure
as such they constitute an assault on
the core function of the government and
repudiate our most basic social contract
a core function of the government
derives its role from the social
contract that our civilized society has
under the fundamental exchange of rights
that takes place between those of us as
individuals and unto the government
we give up our individual rights
to exercise
brute force
to settle our personal disputes
that's a situation where chaos reigns
and the strongest most often prevails
instead
we submit to the power delegated to the
state under which the individual then
submits
to the governmental processes as part of
the social contract
indeed
when conflict arises in our society we
as individuals are compelled via the
social contract to take disputes to our
third branch of government the courts
the judicial branch then peacefully
decides which party is entitled to
judgment in their favor after a full
presentation
of the truthful
evidence
now implicit in the social contract that
we enter as a civilized society is the
principle that the weak
are equally entitled as the strong to
equal justice under the law
despite the tumbling tides of politics
ours is a government of laws not of men
it was the inspired vision of our
founding fathers that the judicial
legislative and executive branch of
government would work together to
preserve the rule of law
the united states constitution requires
the judicial branch to apply the law
equally and fairly to both the weak and
the strong
once we as a society and particularly
our leaders
no longer submit to the social contract
and no longer pay deference to the third
branch of government
which
is equally as important as the
legislative and executive branches of
government
we then begin to erode the rule of law
and begin to erode the social contract
of the great american experiment
that
i believe is why judge bell had stated
that a president cannot faithfully
execute the laws if he himself is
breaking them
the administration of justice is a core
function of the government precisely
because of the importance we place on
the fair resolution of disputes
and on whom and for how long a person
will be denied liberty for violating our
criminal laws
any assault on the administration of
justice
must be interpreted as a threat to our
system of government
our president
who is the chief executive and chief law
enforcement officer and who alone has
delegated the task of our constitution
to take care that the laws be faithfully
executed
cannot and must not be permitted to
engage in such an assault on the
administration of justice
the articles of impeachment adopted by
the house of representatives
established an abuse of public trust and
a betrayal of the social contract that
the president
is alleged to have repeatedly placed his
personal interests above the public
interest and violated his constitutional
duties
for if he is allowed to escape
conviction by the senate
you would allow the president
to set the example for
lawlessness we would
allow our president to serve as an
example of the erosion of the concept of
the social contract
embraced and embodied in our
constitution
i don't believe the senate will allow
that to happen
as you undertake your examination
of the facts the law and your precedence
the senate must wait carefully its
judgment for the consequences are deeply
profound
not for the moment
but for the ages
should the senate choose to acquit
it must be prepared to accept the lower
standard
a bad precedent and a double standard
however
should the senate choose to convict
it will be reinforcing the high
standards for high office
maintain your existing precedence
and uphold the principle of equal
justice under the law
i think it is important here to pause
and
reflect at the upon the constitutional
duties of the president of the united
states
i would agree
with a defense argument
that
this has not been alleged as a
dereliction of a president's
exercise of executive powers
so let me talk about
his executive duties
the president is reposed with a special
trust
by the american people
the president is a physical embodiment
of america and the hope and freedom for
which she stands
when the president goes abroad
he is honored as a head of a sovereign
nation
our nation is acknowledged not just the
individual who occupies the office of
the presidency
when he walks into a room and he
receives a standing ovation the ovation
is not that of the individual
it is for the nation for whom he
represents
the president has a constitutional role
as commander-in-chief
the president plays a unique and
indispensable role in the chain of
command
in federalist 74 alexander hamilton
stated that quote
of all the cares or concerns of
government the direction of war most
peculiarly demands those qualities which
distinguish the exercise of power by a
single hand
it is universally agreed that the
president in his role as
commander-in-chief
is not an actual member of the military
however as the single hand that guides
the actions of the armed services it is
incumbent that the president exhibit
sound responsible leadership and set a
proper example when acting as the
commander-in-chief
that leadership
is also at the core of the issue
before us
in order to be an effective leader
an effective military leader
the president must exhibit the traits
that inspire those who must risk their
lives at his command
these traits include honor and integrity
and
accountability admiral thomas moore the
former chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff submitted testimony to the house
impeachment inquiry
and admiral moore stated it this way
quote
military leaders also serve as role
models for honorable and virtuous
conduct end quote
you see veracity and truthfulness are
important components of a leader's
character
in order to have the trust of their
subordinates
military leaders must have honor and be
truthful in all things
that trust
that bond between the leaders and the
lead is an essential element of any
successful military organization
the president's own self-inflicted
wounds have called his credibility into
question
while a president's decisions are always
critiqued
a president receives the benefit of the
doubt in the decision-making process
that he always places the interest of
the nation
above his own
but william jefferson clinton's
present diminished veracity
he has now forfeited the benefit
and has invited doubt into the
decision-making process
the lack of trust in the president's
motives
his his his veracity his judgment is
inherently corrosive
and can only be detrimental on the
effect of our military and credibility
overseas
this corrosion is difficult to measure
for it cannot be quantified easily in
some readiness report or training
exercise
but in the squad bays and ward rooms
around the world and at bases here in
the united states
there can be heard the whispers and
conversations of those who know that had
they merely been accused of the same
offense their careers would have ended
long ago
this is an intangible effect that the
president's actions have had on the
military
we could not ignore the fact that the
commander-in-chief's conduct sets a poor
example to the men and women of the
military
worse
we cannot ignore the idea that to acquit
the president would create a double
standard
the constitution directs
this body
to provide advice and consent to the
president's nominations for military
officers
it is your singular responsibility
to set high standards of conduct for
these officers and you have done that
the senate has in the past
and you will likely again do so in the
future
reject those whose moral and legal
misconduct
make them unsuitable to be officers in
the military
now let me indulge in a hypothetical
an officer is nominated by the president
from promotion to the rank of major
after the list is submitted but before
the senate's confirmation
an investigation of the individual's
background results in a report that
mirrors the allegations of the office of
of independent council's referral
after a very careful review
of the code of military justice
this captain
if having been committed
similar offenses in the office of
council referral
could be charged with article 105 false
swearing
face up to three years
be charged in article 107 false official
statement be charged up to five years
be charged with article 131 perjury
probably
several times face up to five years
charged with article 133 conduct on
becoming of an officer
charged with article 134 prevent seizure
of property up to one year imprisonment
article 134 soliciting another to commit
an offense face a penalty for up to five
years imprisonment
charged with article 134 subordination
of perjury
face confinement for up to five years
article 134 again obstructing justice
faced five years and i could probably
come up with about four others but i
won't get into the salacious details
you see needless to say
the senate would insist on this
hypothetical officer's removal from the
promotion list
you would do that
and the services would certainly relieve
him of his duties
in every warship every squad bay and
every headquarters building throughout
the united states those of you who have
traveled to military bases you have seen
the picture of the commander-in-chief
hang in the apex of the pyramid that is
the military chain of command
you should also know that all over the
world military personnel look at the
current picture and know that if accused
of the same offenses as their
commander-in-chief
they would no longer be
deserving of the privilege
of serving in the military
some would say that
what i've just talked about doesn't
matter
that in the military they live under
different standards they live under
these high standards
they say words like duty honor country
they're instilled with core values and
core virtues
that that really doesn't matter in this
case
that the president really doesn't have
to follow those types of high standards
that if he violates some form of high
standards
and stands accused of high crimes
they're really not high crimes
it was about a private matter they don't
rise to the level
needed to remove the president from
office
like to remind you
of general douglas macarthur
in his farewell address at west point
general douglas macarthur stated
when he referenced
the words i spoke of duty and honor and
country and the high principles
he said quote the unbelievers will say
that they are but words
but a slogan but a flamboyant phrase and
every pendant every demagogue every
cynic every hypocrite every troublemaker
and i'm sorry to say some others of an
entirely different character will try to
downgrade them to the extent of mockery
and ridicule end quote
the ideal object must be held high
even though we recognize that as humans
we are not perfect
no matter how great we aspire
we're human
and we will occasionally fail
but there must be the pursuit of such
high ideals
we cannot degrade our standards as a
people
by a conviction in the senate
of the president of the united states
you will be upholding a high and lofty
standard
not only for america
but in particular for those military
leaders
rather than set a low standard for the
president and a high lofty standard for
military leaders
let me turn to the president's
responsibility
to see that the laws
be faithfully executed
according to scholar philip v kirk
kirlin
it was probably george washington
rather than the constitution that is
responsible for our hierarchy of cabinet
offices
it's been taken for granted over the
years and we refer to the president as
the chief law enforcement officer of the
land and
he can't find it in the constitution
so we have to give credit to george
washington and how he put together the
cabinet and we've accepted it over time
so it's been accepted by custom
practice and legislation
that the executive branch is an entity
for which the president is responsible
both to congress
and to the public
mr kerlin stated quote
the whole of the executive branch acts
subordinately to the command of the
president in the administration of
federal laws
so long as they act within the terms of
those laws
their offices confer no right to violate
the laws
whether they take the form of
constitution
statute or treaty end quote
the president's departments of treasury
and justice
seek to bring to account those who
disturb our domestic tranquility
and those who seek to disturb our
domestic tranquility
whether they be drug pushers
or unabombers
gangsters mobsters church arsonists
violators of individual rights
dedicated men and women
of the fbi
dea
customs secret service batf inf the
united states marshal's office they all
pursue them
methodically
thoughtfully
firmly
doggedly
applying the law
while risking their lives to uphold the
rule of law for our peace and security
they seek to ensure equal justice under
the law
for everyone
in the book the imperial presidency
professor arthur schlesinger jr
he states quote
the continuation of a law breaker
as the chief magistrate
would be a strange way to exemplify law
and order at home
or to demonstrate american probity
before the world
end quote
by a conviction
the senate will be upholding the high
calling of law enforcement in protecting
the rule of law and equal justice under
the law
equal justice
under the law
that principle so embodies the american
constitutional order
that we have carved it in stone on the
front of the supreme court building
right across the street
the carving across the street
shines like a beacon from the highest
sanctum
across to us here in the capital
the home of the legislative branch
and it shines right down pennsylvania
avenue to the white house
the home of the executive branch
it illuminates
our national life and reminds
those other branches that despite the
tumbling tides of politics
ours is a government of laws not of men
it was inspi it was the inspired vision
of our founders and
framers again that the judicial
legislative and executive branches would
work together to preserve the rule of
law of law
but equal justice under law accounts to
much more than a stone carving
although we can't see it
or hear it
this living breathing force
has very real consequences in the lives
of every
citizen
every day
in america
it allows americans to claim the
assistance of the government when
someone has wronged us
even if the person is stronger or
wealthier or more popular
than we are
in america unlike other countries
when an average citizen sues the chief
executive of our nation
they stand equal before the bar of
justice
the constitution requires the judicial
branch of our government to apply the
law equally to both
that is the living consequence of equal
justice under the law that shines
brightly across our country
the president of the united states
must work with the judicial and the
legislative branch to sustain that force
he is the temporary trustee of that
office
but unfortunately
and sadly
william jefferson clinton
worked
to defeat it
and to bring darkness upon that grand
illumination
when he stood before the bar of justice
he acted without authority to award
himself
even if he believed in his heart
that the case against him was
politically motivated
he singularly assumed to unto himself
that he had by virtue of his power
special privileges
that he could be clever
create
own definitions of words in his own mind
create what c.s lewis called the
verbicide and he murdered
he murdered the plain spoken english
language
so he could come up with these
definitions in his own mind state them
and then say well i never committed
perjury
because this is what i meant by this
word even though it fails the
reasonableness test
and is absurd
that no one would believe
his own definitions
you see he assumed these special
privileges
and then
lied and obstructed
justice to gain advantage
in a federal civil rights action in the
united states district court for the
eastern district of arkansas
and he did so then again
when a federal grand jury began to
investigate
that lawlessness
and he did it in the for the grand jury
in the united states district court for
the district of columbia
his resistance brings us to this almost
unfortunate juncture for which you sit
in judgment
so equal justice under law
lies at the heart of this matter
it rests on three essential pillars
an impartial judiciary
an ethical bar
and a sacred oath
if litigants profane the sanctity of the
oath equal justice under law
loses its protective force
the house
as does the senate
has the responsibility to uphold the
constitution
we have all taken our oaths to defend
the constitution
the founding fathers created a system of
checks and balances
a system of accountability between the
functions of government
you see i believe as i'm sure you do
that the founding fathers knew the
nature of the human heart
that as sometimes as
much as we try
at times we fail
and that the human heart does in fact
struggle at times between good and evil
we recognize that no person has perfect
virtue
and that we each have our human failings
and the founders could foresee a time
when corruption could invade the
institutions of government
and they provided the means to address
it
and the impeachment proceeding
is one such means
we are to seeking to defend the rule of
law
america again is the government of laws
not of men
what protects us from that knock on the
door in the middle of the night
is the law
what ensures the rights of the weak and
the powerless against the powerful
is the law
what provides the rights to the poor
against the rich
is the law
what upholds the rightness of the
minority view against the popular but
wrong
is the law
as former president andrew jackson wrote
the great can protect themselves but the
poor and the humble require the arm and
shield of the
law when our nation began its journey in
history over 200 years ago
the united states was nearly unique in
depending on the rule of law
as opposed to at that time the rule of
kings and czars and chieftains and
monarchs
now that our unique
grand american experiment
has proved unto the rest of the world
the success
others now seek to follow us
they seek to follow
and we have seen
in the crumbling of the soviet union and
now the infant
former soviet republics these former
soviet nations now infant republics they
look and they turn to us
they turn to us a government ruled
by
law
for the sake of ourselves and the sake
of generations yet unborn
we
and in particular you
who sit in judgment here in the senate
must preserve the rule of law
i will leave you with the words of the
first president
of the senate
and the second president of our nation
john adams
he said facts are stubborn things and
whatever may be our wishes
our inclinations
or the dictates of our passions
they cannot alter the state
of facts and evidence
i believe john adams was right
facts and evidence
facts are stubborn things
you can color the facts
you can shade the facts you can
misrepresent the facts you can hide the
facts
but the truthful facts are stubborn
they won't go away
like the telltale heart they keep
pounding then they keep coming and they
won't go away
and what's also stubborn
are the precedents of the senate
i will now yield the floor
to mr manager
graham of south carolina to discuss the
precedence of the senate
the chair recognizes mr manager graham
mr chief justice
the chair recognizes them i sense the
need for a 10-minute break
but
my colleagues please
uh
tend to your business and return
promptly so that we can get started with
the property forum without objection
it's so ordered
[Music]
now new york is undecided good morning
yes uh good morning um
i'm undecided and i'm trying to listen
to this evidence that comes in
what surprises me uh tremendous chair
recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice uh
i believe we are ready to begin with uh
manager
graham
i've been asked about any changes in the
schedule it would depend on how things
uh move forward that i would ask for
consent to change it depending on how
things develop from this point um it's
chief justice i'll leave the floor
the chair recognizes mr manager graham
thank you miss chief justice i think i
broke the code there uh when i hear
stomachs growling i know it will be
time to wrap this up
uh this is an unbelievable occasion for
all of us i'm lindsey graham from south
carolina
and we'll talk a lot about civil rights
i'm a child of the south and i will
give you my views on civil rights and
how we've progressed in this country
uh but i'm going to talk to you a bit
about some decisions this body has has
made
regarding the crime of perjuring
obstruction justice
and the impeachment clause in the
constitution as it applies to federal
judges i'm not so presumptuous to tell
you i know more about what you did than
you did
i'm going to try to highlight some of
the things that you did i think have
served this country well in this area
but before we get get there
a couple observations as i was walking
over
through the rotunda today
there were a group of japanese tourists
there
and i stopped and talked
and my dad
who's now deceased was a world war ii
veteran
and it struck me
50 years plus how resilient this world
is
my dad's generation
i don't think would have ever envisioned
50 years ago
that his son one would be a congressman
which is a great thing about this
country
would be stopping and talking to
japanese tourists in the capital the
united states
so when we talk about the consequences
of this case
no matter what you decide in my opinion
this country will survive
if you acquit the president we will
survive if you convict him
it will be traumatic
and if you remove him it will be
traumatic
but we will survive
and this has been billed as a
constitutional drama
by some of the pundits that's called a
snoozer
and i can understand that a little bit
i'm the 12th lawyer you've had to listen
to and i think my colleagues have done a
very good job but it's a very long
tedious process in many ways
and it's hard to sit here and listen to
12 lawyers
talk to you but you've done a wonderful
job i think i'm very proud of the united
states senate
uh you've paid great attention but the
fact that people call this boring is not
a bad thing to me
i think it shows the confidence we've
achieved in 200 years
as a republic that people can go on
about their business and they're upset i
know my phone rings a lot your phone's
ringing a lot about what to do but
there's a calmness in this country
in the midst of something so important
like this
that tells me
we've done it right for a long time
how many countries would love
the chance to be bored when their
government is in action
how many countries fear
that the government won't work for them
that they get it right you got to pick
up a gun
that happens every day throughout this
world and the fact that we can come
together and talk about something so
important
and the country can go on
and people not be so anxious about their
personal lives and their freedoms and
their properties and their jobs
is a compliment to every generation
who's ever
served this republic
and tom brokaw's got a book out called
the greatest generation
and i recommend it to you to read
because we'll be talking about values in
a moment
but let's talk about some of this
country's imperfections
mister boyer talked about very
eloquently the rule of law and how it
makes us so different and how is
something that people literally do die
for and have died for
but let me tell you as a lawyer
it is not a perfect legal system
if you're a poor person and you're
charged with a crime
you're likely to get a public defender
right out of law school
and hopefully that public defender will
do the best he can
or she can
but it's not a perfect system
don't ever think it is
civil rights have been advanced a lot in
my lifetime
but we got a long way to go in south
carolina
i think we got a long way to go in this
nation
in my lifetime i started school with no
black person in my class
by the sixth grade
i think it was the sixth grade
integration hit
in my area and i can remember my mom and
dad being scared to death
about what it would do and what it would
mean
but we made it and we're better off as a
country
so
we're here to judge our president
we're here to say whether or not he's
guilty to begin with
of some serious offenses
that are colored by sex
and there's absolutely no way to get
around that
and i know it's uncomfortable to listen
to
my father and mother owned a restaurant
a beer joint i guess is what we'd say in
south carolina
i can remember
that if you were black you came and you
had to buy the beer and you had to go
because you couldn't drink it there
that's just the way it was is what my
dad said i always never quite understood
that but my dad and mom were good people
but that's just the way it was
well that's not the way it is now and
we're better off for that in sexual
harassment cases
is always uncomfortable to listen to
that's just the way it is
it used to be in this country
not long ago
there was really no recourse if you were
sexually harassed
we've changed things
for the better
the reason we're here today is not
because somebody wanted to look into the
personal life of the president for no
good reason
we're here today
because somebody accused him when he was
governor
of picking them out of a crowd
asking her
to come to a hotel room
and if you believe her
did something very crude and rude that
you wouldn't want to happen to anybody
in your family
now only god knows what happened there
that case has been settled
the parties know and god knows we'll
never know
but let me just say this i'm proud of my
country
where you
as a low-level employee
can sue the governor of your state
and if the president that governor
becomes president
you can still sue
the supreme court said
nine to nothing
a shutout legally
mr president
you will stand subject to this suit
and we're going to talk about is this
private
or public conduct does this go to the
heart of being president or is this just
some private matter he could be
prosecuted after he gets out office is
this really big a big deal about being
president
i would contend to you ladies and
gentlemen the senate it became a big
deal about being president when he
raised the defense
you can't sue me now
because i'm the president
i'm a busy man i got a lot going on
he used his office or tried to
to avoid the day in court
but the supreme court said no sir
you will stand subject to suit under
some reasonable accommodations
and we're here today
if i had been on the supreme court i
don't know if i would have ruled that
way
there's not much chance of that
happening anytime soon if you're worried
about that i don't think that's going to
be my future but
i'm i may not have ruled that way and we
in congress if we don't like the way all
this has come out we can change that law
we can change that ruling
by law but it's the law of the land
because the chief justice and his
colleagues said so
what did our president do
he tried to say you can't sue me because
i'm president
well he participated in that lawsuit
because he was told to
and i would argue ladies and gentlemen
that we all assumed he would play fair
now isn't there a lot of doubt about
that
ladies and gentlemen the senate what if
he had not shown up
what if he had
refused to answer any court order what
if he said i'm not going to play that's
it
i'm not going to listen to you judicial
branch
you know the remedy we have to resolve
problems like that when presidential
conduct gets out of bounds you know
where that remedy lies
it lies with us
the united states congress
when a president gets out of bounds and
doesn't do
as he or she should do constitutionally
and i would argue that every president
and every citizen has a constitutional
duty not to cheat another citizen
especially the president
and they get out of bounds
it's up to us to put them back in bounds
or declare it illegal
and how do we do that
how do we regulate presidential
misconduct
when it's done in a presidential fashion
through the laws and powers of
impeachment
that is why we're here today
it's going to take teamwork on our part
to get this right
because i will argue to you in a moment
that the president the united states
through his conduct
flouted judicial
authority and decision making
over him
when he chose to lie
when he chose to manipulate the evidence
the witnesses against him and get his
friends to go live for him he in fact i
think vetoed that decision
it's worse than if he hadn't shown up at
all
is that out of bounds
that's what we're going to be talking
about today
and we got some guidance as to what
really is in or out of bounds for high
government officials what's a high crime
how about if an important person
hurts somebody of low means
it's not very scholarly
but i think it's the truth
i think that's what they meant by high
crimes
doesn't even have to be a crime
it's just when you start using your
office and you're acting in a way
that hurts people
you've committed a higher crime
when you decide that a course of conduct
meets the high crime standard
under our constitution
for the president what are we doing to
the presidency
i think we're putting a burden on the
presidency and you should consider it
that way
that if you determine that the conduct
and the crimes in this case are high
crimes you need to do so knowing that
you're placing a burden on every future
occupant or that office
and the office itself
so do so cautiously
because one branch of the government
should never put a burden on another
branch of the government that's not fair
and they can't bear
ladies and gentlemen the senate
if you decided
from the conduct of this president that
henceforth
any office holder who occupies the
office of president
will have this burden to bear
let me tell you what it is
don't lie under oath to a federal grand
jury
when meeting the country are begging you
not to can the occupant bear that burden
i voted against article 2 in the house
which was the deposition
perjury allegations against the
president standing alone
i think many of us may have thought
that he didn't know about the tapes
that he and miss lewinsky thought i had
a story that was going to work
and he got caught off guard and he
started telling a bunch of lies that
maybe i would have lied about
maybe you would lie about because it is
personal
to have to talk about intimate things
and our human nature is to protect
ourselves our family that's just human
nature
but ladies and gentlemen what he stands
charged up in the senate
happened eight months later
after some members of this body
said mr president square yourself with
the law
mr president
if you go into that federal grand jury
and you lie again
you're risking your presidency
people in this body said that
legal commentators said that
professor dershowitz and i probably
don't agree on a lot i think he would
probably agree with that statement
that'd be one thing would agree on
he said and he's a very smart passionate
man and i like passionate people i don't
agree with him
even he said
that if you go to a grand jury and you
lie as president that ought to be a high
crime
so the context in which you're going to
decide this case
has to understand human failings
because if you don't do that you're not
being fair
and i know you want to be fair
human failings exist in all of us
only when it gets to be so premeditated
so calculated
so much my interest over anybody else or
the public be damned
should you really really start getting
serious about what to do
that happened in august in my opinion
ladies and gentlemen
after being begged not to lie to their
grand jury
and in this matter he chose to lie
that's the burden you'd be placing on
the next president
don't do that
don't lie under oath when you're
defending a lawsuit against an average
citizen have the courage to apply the
law in a fair manner to yourself
mr booyer talked about values and
courage
let me say something about president
clinton that i believe
i believe he does embrace civil rights
for our citizens
i believe he's been articulate spokesman
for civil rights for our citizens
i believe that may be one of the
hallmarks of his presidency
and i'm not here to tell you that he
doesn't
i'm here to tell you that when it was
his case
when those rights had to be applied to
him
he failed miserably miserably
it's always easy to talk about what
other people ought to do the test of
character
is the way you judge people you disagree
with
don't cheat in a lawsuit by manipulating
the testimony of others
don't send public officials and friends
to tell your lies before a federal grand
jury to avoid your legal
responsibilities
don't put your legal and political
interest ahead of the rule of law and
common decency
if you find that these are high crimes
that is the burden you're placing on the
next office holder
if they can't meet that burden this
country has a serious problem
i don't want my country to be the
country
of great equivocators and
compartmentalizers for the next century
and that's what this case is about
equivocation and compartmentalizing
what i have described today to you
as the conduct of the president being in
a high crime i think is just his job
description
we're asking no more of him than to be
the chief
law enforcement officer of the land
follow your job description
a determination that this conduct is a
high crime
is no burden
that can't be beared in a reasonable
fashion by future occupants
now what did i talk about constitutional
teamwork
i am a child of the south
the civil rights litigation and matters
that came about in the sixties
were threefold
there was legislation passed in congress
there were judicial decisions that were
rendered
and the executive branch came in to help
out
remember when governor wallace was
standing in the doors
of the university of alabama
remember how he was told to get aside
what went on
it was a constitutional dance of
magnificent
proportions
you had litigation
that was resolved for the individual
citizen so they could go in
and acquire the rights full benefits of
a citizen of that state you had
legislation coming out of this body
and you had defiance
against the federal government from the
state level
and you had the president of the
executive branch
federalizing the national guard
and
governor wallace
stepped aside
when it was nine to nothing that bill
clinton
had to be a participant in a lawsuit
and he chose to cheat in every manner
you can cheat in a lawsuit
his conduct needs to be regulated
and it needs to be brought to bear under
the constitution and if you put him in
jail after his office that would not
solve the constitutional problem he
created
the constitutional conduct exhibited by
the executive when he was told by the
judicial branch you've got to
participate in a lawsuit was so far
afield of what's fair what's decent that
it became a high crime
and it had happened to be
against a little person
the senate
has spoken before
about perjury and obstruction of justice
and how it applies to high government
officials and those government officials
were judges
before we start this analysis it's
important to know
and some of you know this better than
i'll ever hope to know
the history of the senate the history of
this body and how it works and why it
works
that when a judge is impeached in the
united states of america
the same legal standard
treason bribery or other high crimes or
misdemeanors
is applied to that judge's conduct
as it is to any high official just like
the president so we're comparing apples
to apples
now in judge claiborne's trial
they seized upon the language judges
shall hold their office during good
behavior
and the defense was trying to say
unlike the president and other
government officials high government
officials
the impeachment standard for judges is
good behavior
that's the term it's a different
impeachment standard
you know these cases better than i know
these cases
and you said wrong
the good behavior standard doesn't apply
to why you will be removed
is just a reference to how long you will
have your job
our president is two terms a judge is
for life conditioned on good behavior
what gets you out of office
is whether or not you violate the
constitutional standard for impeachment
which is treason bribery or other high
crimes or misdemeanors so as i talked to
you about these cases and what you as a
body did
understand we're using the same legal
standard
not because i said so but because you
said so
[Applause]
judge claiborne
convicted and removed from office by the
senate 90-7
for what
filing a false income tax return under
penalties of perjury
one thing they said in that case was
well i'm a judge
and
filing false income tax returns has
nothing to do with me being a judge
and i'll not lose my job unless you can
show me or prove that i did something
wrong as a judge
they were saying
cheating on your taxes has nothing to do
with being a judge
you know what the senate said
it has everything to do with being a
judge
and the reason you said that
is because you didn't buy into this idea
that the only way you can lose your job
as a high government official under the
constitution
is to engage in some type public conduct
directly related to what you do every
day
you took a little broader view
next short please
you took a little broader view and i'm
certainly glad you did
because this is not a country of high
officials who are technicians
this is a country based on character
this is a country based on having to set
a standard that others will follow
willingly
this is manager
fish
judge claiborne's actions raise
fundamental questions about public
confidence in and the public's
perception of the federal court system
they serve to undermine the confidence
of the american people in our judicial
system judge claiborne is more than a
mere embarrassment he is a disgrace and
a front to the judicial office and to
the judicial branch he was appointed to
serve that's very strong language
apparently you agreed with that concept
because 90 of you voted to throw him out
and what did he do cheated on his taxes
by making false statements under oath
and we'll talk more about public versus
private
senator
matthias about this idea of public birth
versus private it is my opinion that the
impeachment power is not as narrow
as judge claiborne suggests
there is neither historical nor logical
reason to believe that the framers of
the constitution sought to prohibit the
house from impeaching an officer of the
united states who had committed treason
or bribe or any other high crime or
misdemeanor which is a serious offense
against the governor of the united
states and which indicates that the
official is unfit to exercise public
responsibility but which is an offense
which is technically
unrelated to the officer's particular
job responsibilities
this hits it head on
impeachable conducts does not have to
occur in the course of the performance
of an officer's official duties evidence
of misconduct misbehavior high crimes
and misdemeanors can be justified upon
one's private
dealings
as well as one's exercise of public
office that of course is the situation
in this case
it would be absurd to conclude that a
judge who committed murder mayhem rape
or perhaps espionage in his private life
could not be removed from office by the
u.s senate
the point you made so well
was that we're not buying this
if you're a federal judge
and you cheat on your taxes and you lie
under oath
it's true that it had nothing to do with
your courtroom
in a technical sense
but you're going to be judging others
and they're going to come before you
with their fate in your hands
and we don't want somebody like you
running our courtroom
because people won't trust the results
let's go to judge nixon
try to get you out so when i'll have
some lunch here judge nixon
judge walter nixon
convicted and removed from office for
what
perjury before a grand jury
what was that about
he tried to fix
a case for a business partner's son
in state court
he went to the prosecutor who was in the
state court
and tried to fix the case
when they investigated the matter he
lied about meeting with the prosecutor
he lied about doing anything related to
trying to manipulate the results
he was convicted
and he was thrown out office by the
united states senate
i guess you could say what's that got to
do with being a federal judge it wasn't
even his
it's got everything to do with being a
high public official
because if he stays in office
what signal are you sending anybody else
that you send to his courtroom or
anybody else's courtroom
the question becomes
if a federal judge
can be thrown in our office for lying
and trying to fix
a friend's son's case
can the president of the united states
be removed for office for trying to fix
his case
that's not a scholarly word but that's
what happened
he tried to fix his case
he turned the judicial system upside
down
every way but loose he sent his friends
to life for him he lied for himself as
any time any relevant question come up
instead of taking the honorable out he
just lied and he dug a hole and we're
all here today because of that and i'm
not going to go over the facts again
because you have been bombarded with the
facts but if you believe you committed
perjury and you believe you obstructed
justice the reason he did it was to fix
his case
and you got some record
obstructed justice the reason he did it
was to fix his case
and you got some records to which you
can rely upon to see what you ought to
do with somebody like that
judge hastings
this federal judge
was convicted and removed from office by
the united states senate
but you know what's interesting about
this case to me he was acquitted before
he got here
he was accused of conspiring with
another person
to take money to fix results in his own
court
he gave testimony his own behalf
the conspirator was convicted but he was
acquitted
and you know what the united states
senate and the house said
we believe your conduct is out of bounds
and we're not bound for that acquittal
we want to get to the truth
and we don't want federal judges that we
have a strong suspicion or a reasonable
belief about that are trying to fix
cases in their court
so the point i'm trying to make is you
don't even have to be convicted of a
crime
to lose your job
in this constitutional republic if this
body
determines that your conduct as a public
official is clearly out of bounds in
your role
thank god you did that
because impeachment
is not about punishment
impeachment is about cleansing the
office
impeachment is about restoring honor and
integrity to the office
the remedy of prosecuting william
jefferson clinton has no effect on the
problem you are facing here today in my
opinion
now
every case
was tried before it got here with
different results
two of them were convicted one of them
was acquitted
you had a factual record to go upon
i urge you ladies and gentlemen of the
united states senate
that that cannot happen in this case
unless we have a trial in its true sense
of the word
the evidence is compelling and
overwhelming
but it's only been half told
the learned counsel for the president
will have their chance
and they are excellent lawyers
if this is a football game we're almost
to halftime
please
please wait because i have set where
they have set
dying to say something
i know there are things they want to
tell you about what we've said that may
put this in a different light and that's
coming and it ought to come
but there's another thing that you'll
have to decide
has the factual record been developed
enough that i can equip with good
conscience that i can convict and remove
with good conscience
in these judge cases there's a
full-blown trial before it ever got here
because we can't prosecute the president
criminally because we can't do the
things that happen in the judge's cases
we don't have that record
so i would just commit that to you for
your wisdom
none of this matters unless you believe
you committed the offense and i'm not
going to go over that again
you know the facts pretty well and if
there's any doubt call witnesses
and let's develop them fully and let's
leave no doubt on the table and let's
make sure that history would judge us
well and everybody the house and the
president had a fair shot at proving
their case that these things occurred
their high crimes and the hard question
now
because i don't believe ladies and
gentlemen that when you look at the
totality of what the president did
the prior presence of the senate the
fact that he was told by the supreme
court to go into this litigation matter
and he cheated so badly that you would
consider these not to be high crimes
because you're not placing a burden on
this office that the office can't bear i
think that will be resolved i hope and
pray in a bipartisan fashion
if we can do nothing else for this
country let us say clearly this conduct
is unacceptable by any president these
are in fact high crimes they go to the
core of why
why we're all here as a nation the rule
of law and he is told to abide by the
rules of litigation and he cheated and
you got to put him back in bounds
removal
determining that it's a high crime
puts it back in bounds
this is a hard question
i am not going to tell you it is not i
do not want to be where you're sitting
i think
the evidence will be persuasive that
he's guilty
the logic of your past rulings and just
fundamental fairness and decency and
helping the supreme court enforce their
rulings if nothing else
will lead you to a higher crime
determination
but we're asking you to remove a popular
president
i don't know why
all this occurred
and
we have a popular
president i know this
that the american people are
fundamentally fair
and they have an impression about this
case
from just tons and tons and tons and
tons of talk
tons and tons and tons of spin
and that one in five they tell me are
paying close attention to this
the question you must ask
every american were required to do what
i have done
as sit silently
listen to the evidence
would it be different
you are their representatives
they will trust you
this is a cynical age but i'm an
optimist
that no matter what you do
this country will get up and go to work
the next day
and they will feel
good no matter what it is
to set aside an election
is a very scary thought in the democracy
i do not agree with this president
on most major policy initiatives i did
not vote for this president
but he won
he won twice
to undo that election
is tough
let me give you some of my thoughts
how many times
have you had to go
to
a child a grandchild
somebody works for you
and give them a lecture
that goes along the lines
don't do as i do do as i say
in that a miserable experience
the problem
with keeping this president in office in
my opinion
is that these crimes
can't be ignored by anybody who looks at
the evidence
they can be explained away and they can
be excused
but they have far-reaching consequences
far-reaching consequences for the law
and in his role of chief law enforcement
officer of the land
how can we say to our fellow citizens
that
this will not be
20 months
of do as i do
don't do as i do do as i say
what effect will that have
i think it will be devastating this case
is the butt of a thousand jokes
this case is requiring
parents and teachers to sit down and
explain what lion's all about
this case has created confusion
this craig this case has hit america far
harder than america knows it's been hit
and it is tempting
to let the clock tick
but i would suggest to you ladies and
gentlemen of the senate that if you
believe he's a perjurer
and the obstructed justice in a civil
rights lawsuit
the question is not
should he stay
what if he stays
if you believe this president committed
perjure before a grand jury when he was
begged not to
and people in this body telling him
don't do it because your political
career is at stake
if you believe he obstructed justice in
a civil rights lawsuit
don't move the bar any more
we have moved the bar for this case a
thousand times
remember how you felt
when you knew you had a perjurer as a
judge
when you knew you had somebody who had
fundamentally
ran over the law that he was
forced to uphold or
responsible for upholding remember how
you felt when you knew that judge had
gotten so out of bounds that you
couldn't put him back in court even
though it was unrelated to his court
because she'd be doing a disservice to
the citizens that would come before him
a judge has a duty
to take care of the individuals fairly
that come before their court
the president ladies and gentlemen the
senate
has a duty to see that the law applies
to everyone fairly
a higher duty
a higher duty in the constitution
you couldn't live with yourself
knowing that you were going to leave a
perjuring judge on the bench
ladies and gentlemen
as hard as it may be
for the same reasons
cleanse this office
the vice president will be waiting
outside the doors
this chamber our constitutional system
is simple
and it's genius all at the same time
if that vice president is asked to come
in and assume the mantle of chief
executive officer of the land chief law
enforcement officer of the land
it will be tough
it will be painful
but we will survive
and we will be better for it thank
you
the chair recognizes mr manager kennedy
[Music]
mr chief justice
distinguished counsel
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
i'm representative charles kennedy of
the 12th district of florida
and i rise now to conclude the argument
that my two fellow managers have begun
and to address the fundamental question
now before the senate
do the offenses charged against the
president
rise to the level of high crimes and
misdemeanors
under our constitution
are these crimes
perjury before a federal grand jury
and obstruction of justice
offenses for which the president has
properly been impeached by the house
and for which he may now properly be
convicted by the senate
or are these serious felonies offenses
for which a chief executive may not
constitutionally be called to account by
either the house or the senate
to properly answer these questions must
be understood
as my fellow manager mr boyer has argued
that perjury and obstruction of justice
are
serious offenses against the system of
justice
to properly answer these questions it
must also be understood
as my fellow manager mr graham has just
discussed
that the senate has already determined
that as a serious offense against the
system of justice
perjury is proper grounds for removal
from office
there are several additional points that
i now ask you to consider as you
deliberate on the momentous issue
you are called on to decide
first i will argue that restricting the
impeachment process to crimes involving
the abuse of presidential power is
contrary to common sense
this is a key point in this case
the president's defense hinges to a
large extent on his claim that the
offenses charged against him do not
involve official misconduct
i will then review the history and
purpose of the impeachment process to
show that its fundamental object
is to maintain the supremacy of law
against the misconduct of public
officials
after reviewing the background of the
impeachment process i will briefly
discuss the prevailing views on the
seriousness of perjury
at the time the constitution was adopted
and show that perjury and obstruction of
justice are akin to bribery
both in their purpose
and in their effect
to conclude i will discuss the proper
role of the senate in exercising the
removal power emphasizing three
essential points
first that the removal power is designed
to preserve
protect and strengthen our constitution
by setting a standard of conduct for
public officers
second that the senate should not
establish a lower standard of integrity
for the president of the united states
than the standard it has already
established for federal judges
third
that the senate should not allow a
president who has violated his
constitutional duty and oath of office
and made himself a notorious example of
lawlessness to remain in office
the president's lawyers have argued that
the constitution requires proof of
official misconduct for impeachment and
conviction
and that removal from office is not
proper for crimes that do not involve
an abuse of the power of office
this view
has also been endorsed by various
academics who have signed a letter in
support of the president
now the senate must decide if this
interpretation is a proper
interpretation of the constitution
in deciding this question you should be
guided by common sense and good judgment
it is by no means an abstruse and
mysterious matter of constitutional law
nor is it a new question before the
senate it has been decided in the recent
judicial impeachments which mr graham
has discussed
and it is a it is a question which arose
200 years ago in the course of the first
impeachment trial conducted by the
senate
at that trial in january of 1799
as the senate met in philadelphia an
argument was made by council for the
respondent senator blount of tennessee
that the impeachment power was properly
exercised only with respect to official
offenses
although senator blount escaped
conviction on other grounds
the response to his claim that only
official misconduct could justify
impeachment and removal remains
noteworthy today
robert goodloe harper of south carolina
one of the house managers and who
incidentally subsequently served as a
member of the senate representing the
state of maryland
refuted that claim by asking a simple
question
he said
suppose a judge of the united states to
commit a theft or perjury
would the learned council say that he
should not be impeached for it
if so
he must remain in office
with all his infamy
200 years to the month after robert
goodloe harper posed that question to
the senate
a very similar question is before the
senate today
shall a president
if found guilty of perjury and
obstruction of justice be removed
or must
he remain in office with all his infamy
although a judge who commits crimes may
be subjected to criminal penalties and
prevented from discharging judicial
functions
he can be divested of his office
only by impeachment and removal
the tenure of a president will
necessarily expire with the passage of
time
but most scholars of constitutional law
agree that while he remains in office he
is immune from the processes of the
criminal law so long as he is president
the only mechanism available to hold him
accountable for his crimes
is the power of impeachment
and removal unless that power is
exercised no matter what crimes he has
committed he must remain in office with
all his infamy
the argument of the president's lawyers
that no criminal act by the president
subjects him to removal from office
unless the crime involves abuse of his
power
is an argument entailing consequences
which upon a moment's reflection
this body should be unwilling to accept
would a president guilty of murder be
immune from the constitutional process
of impeachment and removal so long as
this crime involved no misuse of
official power
would a president guilty of sexual
assault or child molesting remain secure
in office because his crime did not
involve an abuse of office
in support of their position the
president's lawyers
have vigorously argued that a president
who committed tax fraud a felony offense
not involving official misconduct would
not be subject to impeachment and
removal
they erroneously cite the decision of
the house judiciary committee rejecting
an article of impeachment
against president nixon for tax fraud
the record of the house proceeding
establishes that the tax fraud article
against president nixon was rejected due
to insufficient evidence that he was in
fact guilty of tax fraud the house
judiciary committee never determined
that tax fraud by a president would not
be grounds for impeachment but leaving
aside the inaccurate characterization of
the house judiciary committee's action
the claim of the president's lawyers
that a president could commit tax fraud
and remain immune from impeachment and
removal is quite telling
it reveals a great deal about the sort
of standard that they would set
for the president of the united states
the claim that tax fraud a felony does
not rise to the level of a high crime or
misdemeanor was as you have heard
unequivocally rejected by the senate in
1986 in the case
of judge harry claiborne who was removed
from office for filing false income tax
returns
then senator albert gore jr summarized
the judgment of the senate that judge
claiborne
should be removed from office
the comments of senator gore bear
repeating
he said
it is incumbent upon the senate to
fulfill its constitutional
responsibility and strip this man of his
title
an individual who has knowingly
falsified tax returns has no business
receiving a salary derived from the tax
dollars of honest
citizens
of course the rationale expressed by
senator gore for the conviction of judge
claiborne for his criminal tax offenses
applies with equal if not greater force
to similar offenses committed by a
president of the united states
professor charles black jr in his essay
on the law of impeachment recognized the
appropriate application of these
principles to the office of the
presidency
professor black said a large-scale tax
cheat is not a viable chief magistrate
i would respectfully submit to the
senate that the argument of the
president's lawyers concerning tax fraud
by a president is not a viable argument
who can seriously argue that our
constitution requires that a president
guilty of crimes such as murder sexual
assault or tax fraud remain in office
undisturbed
who is willing to set such a standard
for the conduct of the president of the
united states who inc
and who can in good conscience accept
the consequences for our system of
government that would necessarily follow
could our constitution possibly
contemplate such a result
what other crimes of a president will we
be told do not rise to the level of high
crimes and
misdemeanors these are grave questions
that must be addressed by this senate
the president's defense requires that
these questions be asked and answered
contrary to the claims of the
president's lawyers there is not a
bright line separating official
misconduct by a president from other
misconduct of which the president is
guilty
some offenses will involve the direct
and affirmative misuse of governmental
power
other offenses may involve a more subtle
use of the prestige status and position
of the president to further a course of
wrongdoing
there are still other offenses in which
a president may not misuse the powers of
his office but in which he violates a
duty
imposed on him
under the constitution
such a breach of constitutional duty
even though it does not involve an
affirmative misuse of governmental power
may be a very serious matter it does
violence to the english language to
assert that a president who has violated
a duty entrusted to him by the
constitution is not guilty of official
misconduct
common sense indicates that official
misconduct has indeed occurred
whenever a president breaches any of the
duties of his office
as we have been reminded repeatedly the
constitution imposes on the president
the duty to take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
the charges against the president in
this case involve multiple violations of
that duty
a president who commits a calculated and
sustained series of criminal offenses
has by his personal violations of the
law
failed in the most immediate
direct and culpable manner to do his
duty under the constitution
in their defense of the president his
lawyers in essence contend that a
president may be removed for misusing
governmental power but not for corruptly
interfering with the proper exercise of
governmental power
this argument exalts form over substance
it unduly focuses on the manner in which
wrongdoing is carried out and neglects
to consider the actual impact of that
wrongdoing on our system of government
whether the president misuses the power
of vested in him as president or
wrongfully interferes with the power
with the proper exercise of the power
vested in other parts of the government
the result is the same
the due functioning of our system of
government is in some respect hindered
or defeated
there is no principled basis for
contending that a president who
interferes with the proper exercise of
governmental power as he clearly does
when he commits perjury and obstruction
of justice is constitutionally less
blame-worthy than a president who
misuses the powers of his office
a president who lies to a federal grand
jury in order to impede the
investigation of crimes is no less
culpable than a president who wrongfully
orders a prosecutor to suspend an
investigation of crimes
that may have been committed
the purpose and effect of the personal
perjury and of the wrongful official
command are the same
the laws of the united states are not
properly enforced
although neither the senate nor the
house has ever adopted a fixed
definition of high crimes and
misdemeanors there is much in the
background in history of the impeachment
process that contradicts the narrow view
of the removal power advanced by the
president's lawyers
there is no convincing evidence that
those who framed and ratified our
constitution intended to limit the
impeachment and removal power to acts
involving the abuse of official power
the key phrase defining the offenses for
which the president vice president and
other civil officers of the united
states may be removed
treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors
simply does not limit the removal power
in the way suggested by the president's
lawyers the truth is as
we have heard already today that treason
and bribery may be committed by an
official who does not abuse the power of
his office in the commission of the
offense
a president might for example
pay a bribe to a judge presiding over a
case to which the president is an
individual party or a judge might commit
an act of treason without exercising any
of the powers of his office in doing so
by the express terms of the constitution
those offenses would be impeachable
and there is no reason to impose a
restriction on the scope of high crimes
and misdemeanors that is not imposed on
treason and bribery
although having a means for the removal
of officials guilty of abusing their
power was no doubt very much in the
minds of the framers the purpose of the
removal power was not restricted to that
object
to properly understand the purpose of
impeachment
under our constitution consideration
must be given to the use of impeachment
by the english parliament
impeachment in the english system
did not require an indictable crime but
the proceeding was nevertheless of a
criminal nature punishment upon
conviction could extend to imprisonment
and even death
it was a mechanism used by the
parliament to check absolutism and to
establish the supremacy of the
parliament through impeachment
parliament acted to curb the abuses of
exalted persons who would otherwise have
free reign
impeachment was used by the parliament
to punish a wide range of offenses
misapplication of funds abuse of
official power neglect of duty
corruption encroachment on the
prerogatives of parliament and giving
harmful advice to the crown
in the english practice high crimes and
misdemeanors misdemeanors included all
of these
during the impeachment of lord
chancellor mcclesfield in 1725
sergeant pangeli summed up the purpose
of impeachment
it was he said for the punishment of
offenses of a public nature which may
affect the nation he went on to say that
impeachment was also for use in
instances where the inferior courts have
no power to punish the crimes committed
by ordinary rules of justice
or in cases where the person offending
is by his degree
raised above the apprehension of danger
from a prosecution carried on in the
usual course of justice and whose
exalted station requires the united
accusation of all the comments
in the case of warren hastings which was
proceeding at the time the constitution
was framed
edmund burke described the impeachment
process as
a grave and important proceeding
essential to the establishment of the
national character for justice
and equity
as the british legal historian
holdsworth has written the impeachment
process was a mechanism in service of
the ideal of government in accordance
with the law
it was a means by which the greatest
ministers of state could be made
responsible like humble officials to the
law
according to holsworth
the greatest services rendered by this
procedure to the cause of constitutional
government have been firstly the
establishment of the doctrine of
ministerial responsibility to the law
secondly its application to all
ministers of the crown and thirdly and
consequently the maintenance of the
supremacy of law
overall
thus the fundamental purpose of the
impeachment process in england was the
maintenance of the supremacy of law
overall those who were impeached and
called to account for high crimes and
misdemeanors where those who by their
conduct threaten to undermine the rule
of law
this english understanding of the
purpose of impeachment serves as a
backdrop
for the work of the framers of our
constitution
despite some important differences in
the functioning of impeachment in
england and in the united states the
fundamental purpose of impeachment
remain the same
defending the rule of law
the records of the proceeding of the
constitutional convention also
shed light on the meaning of high crimes
and misdemeanors
and the underlying purpose of the
impeachment mechanism
the primary focus of the relevant
discussions at the convention was on the
need for some means of removing the
president
early in the proceedings with respect to
impeachment the committee of the whole
agreed to make the president removable
on impeachment and conviction of
malpractice or neglect of duty although
concerns were expressed that impeachment
would give the legislative branch undue
control over the executive and violate
the separation of powers in the course
of the proceedings james madison stated
that some provision was needed
to defend the community against the
president if he became corrupt
incapacitated
or perverted his administration into a
scheme of speculation or oppression
arguing for a means of removing the
president george mason said
no point is of more importance than that
the right of impeachment should be
continued shall any man be above justice
above all shall that man be above it who
can commit the most extensive injustice
before the convention settled on the
language that was ultimately adopted a
proposal was considered that would have
limited impeachable offenses to treason
and bribery
an effort was made to broaden this
proposal by including mal administration
as an impeachable offense madison
objected
he objected that the inclusion of a term
as vague as male administration would
result in the president having tenure
during the pleasure of the senate
as a compromise the term mal
administration was dropped and high
crimes and misdemeanors was substituted
from this course of proceedings it can
reasonably be it can reasonably be
concluded that poor administration at
least if it does not involve corrupt
motives is not a sufficient ground for
impeachment in the debate concerning the
constitution and the various state
ratification conventions
the grounds for impeachment were with
some frequency said to include abuse or
betrayal of trust and abuse of power
making a bad treaty was also frequently
mentioned as justifying impeachment at
the virginia convention governor
randolph spoke of misbehavior and
dishonesty and james madison gave two
examples of impeachable conduct
pardoning a criminal with whom the
president was in collusion and summoning
only a few senators to approve a treaty
one of the most extensive recorded
discussions of impeachment occurred at
the north carolina ratification
convention and remarks made by james
aredel
ardell who later served as a justice of
the supreme court spoke of the supremacy
of the law under the system of
government proposed by the constitution
he said
no man has an authority to injure
another with impunity
no citizen is better than his fellow
citizens nor can pretend to any
superiority over the meanest man in the
country if the president does a single
act
by which the people are prejudiced he is
punishable himself
if he commits any misdemeanor in office
he is impeachable
arendelle also expressed the view that
impeachment may be used only in cases
where there is some corrupt motive he
said
when any man is impeached it must be for
an error of the heart and not of the
head
whatever mistake a man may make
he ought not to be punished for it nor
his posterity rendered infamous
but if a man be a villain
and willfully abuse his trust he is to
be held up as a public offender and
ignominiously punished
according to these principles i suppose
the only instances in which the
president would be liable to impeachment
would be where he had received a bribe
or acted from some corrupt motive or
other
ardell's comments buttress the view that
impeachment is not to be used as a
political weapon to resolve differences
of policy between the legislative branch
and the executive branch
impeachment is not an appropriate remedy
for errors even serious errors in the
administration of government
to justify impeachment there must be
some corrupt motive a willful abuse of
trust an error
of the heart
you will note that there is nothing in
ardell's comments to suggest that a
president who is engaged in a corrupt
course of conduct
by obstructing justice and committing
perjury would be immune from impeachment
and removal
another major discussion during the
debate over ratification occurs in the
federalist number 65 to which reference
has already been made in these
proceedings
for alexander hamilton describes the
impeachment process as a method of
national inquest into the conduct of
public men
and discusses the power of the senate in
their judicial character as a court for
the trial of impeachment
now before i discuss his views on
impeachment
i would like to say a word in defense of
alexander hamilton
who was a widely acknowledged
champion of our constitution
widely acknowledged as one of
the most eloquent
expositors and defenders of the
constitution
unfortunately the reputation of
alexander hamilton has in recent days
introduced
it is unjust to the memory of this great
man to compare his personal sins with
the crimes of president clinton
when hamilton was questioned about his
affair
he told the truth
he took responsibility for his conduct
there is no evidence that he ever
engaged in acts of corruption
he never lied under oath
he never obstructed justice
and not withstanding the efforts
of his lawyers president clinton by no
means benefits
from a comparison with alexander
hamilton
in the federalist
hamilton writes of the senate
the subjects of its jurisdiction are
those offenses which proceed from the
misconduct of public men
or in other words from the abuse or
violation of some public trust
they are of a nature which may with
peculiar propriety be denominated
political as they relate chiefly to
injuries done immediately to the society
itself
hamilton recognized that the focus of
the impeachment power is on the
misconduct of public men or the abuse or
violation of some public trust
impeachment is a remedy against
officials for injuries done to the
society itself
despite the claims of the president's
lawyers the comments of hamilton do not
support the view that a president can be
impeached and removed only for an abuse
of power
the misconduct of public men and the
abuser violation of some public trust to
which hamilton refers are not restricted
to offenses involving the misuse of
official power
the misconduct of public men encompasses
a whole range of wrongful deeds
committed by those who hold office when
those offenses are committed
the public trust is violated whenever a
public officer breaches any duty he has
to the public
injuries done to the society itself
similarly may occur as a result of
misconduct that does not involve the
misuse of the powers of office
now i would submit to the senate
that the english precedence the records
of the constitutional convention debates
and the general principle set forth by
hamilton ardell and others in the debate
over ratification
do not provide
a definitive list of high crimes and
misdemeanors but they do provide broad
guidance concerning the scope of the
impeachment power
the theme running through all these
background sources is that the
impeachment process is designed to
provide a remedy for the corrupt and
lawless acts of public officials
not surprisingly
those who have been on the receiving end
of impeachment proceedings have been
quick to argue for a restrictive meaning
of high crimes and misdemeanors
president clinton's lawyers follow in
that well-established tradition
they attempt to minify minimize the
significance of charges of perjury and
obstruction of justice
against the president in essence they
argue that treason and bribery are the
prototypical high crimes and
misdemeanors and the crimes charged
against the president
are insufficiently similar in both their
nature and seriousness to treason and
bribery
but as the comments of my fellow manager
mr boyer have made clear the crime set
forth in the articles of impeachment are
indeed serious offenses against our
system of justice
they were certainly viewed as serious
offenses by those who drafted and
ratified the constitution
as mr boyer has mentioned
in his discussion of offenses against
the public justice sir william
blackstone whose work james madison said
was in every man's hand during the
creation of the constitution listed the
offenses of perjury and bribery side by
side immediately after he listed treason
1790 the first congress
adopted as you have already heard a
statute entitled an act for the
punishment of certain crimes against the
united states
making perjury a crime punishable as a
felony
nothing could be clearer
perjury is a crime against the united
states it is not a private matter
as mr shabbat noted yesterday john jay
the first chief justice of the united
states
said that there is no crime more
extensively pernicious to society than
perjury
according to jay perjury discolors and
poisons the streams of justice
and by substituting falsehood for truth
saps the foundations of personal and
public rights
he said if oaths should cease to be held
sacred our dearest and most valuable
rights would become
insecure
given this understanding that was
current at the time the constitution was
adopted it is impossible to support the
conclusion that perjury and the related
defense of obstruction of justice are
somehow trivial offenses that do not
rise to the same level as the offensive
bribery which is enumerated in the
constitution
moreover perjury and obstruction of
justice are by their very nature akin to
bribery when the crime of bribery is
committed money is given
and received to corruptly alter the
course of official action
when justice is obstructed action is
undertaken to corruptly thwart the due
administration of justice
when perjury occurs false testimony is
given under oath in order to deceive
judges and juries and to prevent the
just determination of causes pending in
the courts
the fundamental purpose and the
fundamental effect
of each of these offenses
perjury obstruction of justice and
bribery alike
is to defeat the proper administration
of government
they are all crimes of corruption aimed
at substituting private advantage for
the public interest they all undermine
the integrity of the functions of
government
the use of the impeachment process
against misconduct which undermines the
integrity of government is a central
focus of two reports prepared in 1974 on
the background and history of
impeachment
and i would
humbly bring these reports to your
attention i commend them to you
for your consideration
one of the reports was prepared by the
staff of the nixon impeachment inquiry
the other was produced by the bar of the
city of new york
both of these reports have gained
bipartisan respect over the last 25
years for their balanced and judicious
approach
they provide a well-informed analysis of
the key issues related to impeachments
in doing so they stand in stark contrast
to the recent pronouncements by some
academics which substitute political
opinion for scholarly analysis
a review of these two documents from
1974 supports the conclusion that the
articles before the senate set forth
compelling grounds for the conviction
and removal of president clinton
there has been a great deal of comment
on the report on constitutional grounds
for presidential impeachment prepared
in february of 1974 by the staff of the
nixon impeachment inquiry
those who assert that the charges
against the president do not rise to the
level of high crimes and misdemeanors
have pulled some phrases from that
report out of context to support their
position in fact the general principles
concerning grounds for impeachment and
removal set forth in that report
indicate that perjury and obstruction of
justice are high crimes and misdemeanors
consider this key language from the
staff report describing the type of
conduct
which gives rise to the proper use of
the impeachment and removal power
in the report they said the emphasis has
been on the significant effects of the
conduct
undermining the integrity of office
disregard of constitutional duties and
oath of office
irrigation of power abuse of the
governmental process
adverse impact on the system of
government
the report goes on to state because
impeachment of a president is a grave
step for the nation it is to be
predicated only upon conduct seriously
incompatible with
either the constitutional form and
principles of our government or the
proper performance of constitutional
duties of the presidential office
perjury and obstruction of justice i
would submit to you
clearly undermine the integrity of
office i ask you
if these offenses do not undermine the
integrity of office what offenses would
their unavoidable consequence is to
erode respect for the office of the
president and to interfere with the
integrity of the administration of
justice
such offenses are seriously incompatible
with the president's constitutional
duties and oath of office and with the
principles of our government
establishing the rule of law
moreover
they are offenses which have a direct
and serious adverse impact on the system
of government
obstruction of justice is by definition
an assault on the due administration of
justice which is a core function of our
system of government
perjury has the same purpose and effect
the second report to which i have
referred the thoughtful report on the
law of presidential impeachment prepared
by the association of the bar of the
city of new york in january of 1974
also places a great deal of emphasis on
the corrosive impact of presidential
misconduct on the integrity of
government
the report summarizes the proper basis
for impeachment and removal in this way
it says it is our conclusion in summary
that the grounds for impeachment are not
limited to or synonymous with crimes
rather we believe that acts which
undermine the integrity of government
are appropriate grounds
whether or not they happen to constitute
offenses under the general criminal law
in our view
the essential nexus to damaging the
integrity of government may be found in
acts which constitute corruption in or
flagrant abuse of the powers of official
position
it may also be found in acts which
without directly affecting governmental
processes
undermine that degree of public
confidence in the probity of executive
and judicial officers
that is essential to the effectiveness
of government in a free society
perjury and obstruction of justice
serious felony offenses against the
united states
by a president are acts of corruption
which without doubt
undermine that degree of public
confidence and the probity of the
president that is essential to the
effectiveness of government in a free
society
such acts are high crimes and
misdemeanors because they inevitably
subvert the respect for law which is
essential to the well-being of our
constitutional system
a similar point is made by a
contemporary commentator who has argued
and i quote there are certain statutory
crimes that if committed by public
officials
reflect such lapses of judgment
such disregard for the welfare of the
state and such lack of respect for the
law and the office held by the occupants
that the occupants may be impeached and
removed for lacking the minimal level of
integrity and judgment sufficient to
discharge the responsibilities of office
such a lack of the minimal level of
integrity
necessary for the proper discharge of
the duties of the presidency is
evidenced by the commission of the
statutory crimes of perjury and
obstruction of justice
contrary to the claim that has been made
by some
the issue before the senate is not
whether the offenses of this president
will destroy our constitution
we all know that our system of
government will not come tumbling down
because of the corrupt conduct of
william jefferson clinton
our republic will survive the crimes of
this president no one doubts that
of course the same could be said of all
the other federal officials who have
been impeached and removed from office
and the same might be said of the crimes
serious as they were
of president richard nixon
but the removal power is not restricted
to offenses that would directly destroy
our constitution or system of government
the removal power is not so limited that
it can be brought into play only when
the immediate destruction of our
institutions is threatened on the
contrary
the removal power should be understood
as a positive grant of authority to the
senate to preserve protect and
strengthen our constitutional system
against the misconduct of federal
officials when that misconduct would
subvert
undermine or weaken the institutions of
our government
it is a power that has the positive
purpose of maintaining the health and
well-being of our system of government
this power
the awesome power of removal vested in
the senate carries with it an awesome
responsibility
this power imposes on the senate the
responsibility to exercise its judgment
in establishing the standards of conduct
that are necessary to preserve
protect and strengthen the constitution
which has served the people of the
united states so well for more than two
centuries
thus the crucial issue before the senate
is what standard will be set for the
conduct of the president of the united
states
in this case
the senate necessarily will establish
such a standard and make no mistake
about it
the choice the senate makes in this case
will
have consequences reverberating far into
the future of our republic
will a president who has committed
serious offenses against the system of
justice be called to account for his
crimes or will his offenses be regarded
as of no constitutional consequence
will a standard be established that such
crimes by a president will not be
tolerated or will the standard be that
at least in some cases a president may
remain in office with all his infamy
after lying under oath and obstructing
justice
regardless of the choice the senate
makes whether it acquits or convicts the
president a standard will be established
and that standard will become an
important part of the constitutional law
of this nation
the institutions of our government will
either be strengthened or weakened as a
result
and if the senate acquits this president
the conduct of future presidents will
inevitably be affected in ways that we
cannot now confidently predict
i would now like to take a very few
minutes to examine some of the other
specific arguments
that have been made that it is not
now a proper case before the senate for
the use of the removal power
some have suggested that in setting a
standard in this case the senate should
be guided by the popularity of the
president
it is urged that a popular president
regardless of the offenses he may have
committed should not be removed from
office
such a view finds no support however in
our constitution on the contrary the
framers understood that a popular
president might be guilty of crimes
requiring his removal from office
that's why
they included
the power of impeachment removal in the
constitution and that is no doubt why
they specifically provided that an
impeachment official who was convicted
and removed might also be perpetually
disqualified
to hold and enjoy any honor
any office of honor trust or profit
under the united states
the potential threat posed to our
institutions by presidential misconduct
would in fact be heightened by the
popularity of the offending president
the harmful influence and example of a
popular president would pose a far
greater danger to the well-being of our
government than the influence
an example of an unpopular president
moreover the very framework of our
constitution establishing a
representative democracy is at odds with
the notion that the institutions of our
government should respond mechanically
to the changing tides of public opinion
the senate
in particular was designed to act on the
basis of the long-term best interests of
the nation
rather than short-term political
considerations
when he was tried by the senate 130
years ago president andrew johnson was
overwhelmingly unpopular
if the senate had used presidential
popularity as a guide in the johnson
case there is no doubt that he would
have been convicted and removed from
office
yet today there is widespread agreement
that such action by the senate would
have been an abuse of the constitutional
process
and those who refuse to use presidential
popularity as their guide
or hail as great statesmen and heroes
those senators who then stood against
the tide of public sentiment today are
revered as champions of constitutional
government a popular president guilty of
high crimes and misdemeanors should no
more remain in office than an unpopular
president innocent of wrongdoing should
be removed from office
under the standards of the constitution
popularity is not a sufficient guide
nor should the senate be swayed by the
claims that setting a standard adverse
to this president will weaken the
institution of the presidency
describing the role of impeachment under
our constitution arthur m schlesinger jr
who
i will candidly admit takes a different
view of the matter today
wisely observed
the genius of impeachment lay in the
fact
that it could punish the man without
punishing the office
for in the presidency is elsewhere power
was ambiguous the power to do good meant
also
the power to do harm
the power to serve the republic also the
power to demean and defile it
rather than weakening the presidency the
removal from office of a president who
has violated his constitutional duty and
oath of office
will reestablish the integrity of the
presidency
setting a standard against the acts of
perjury and obstruction of justice
committed by president clinton will
reaffirm the dignity
and the honor of the office of chief
executive under our constitution
that will strengthen not weaken the
institution of the presidency
it has even been argued that the
impeachment and removal of president
clinton would result in the virtual
alteration of our system of government
it is contended that following the
constitutional process in this case
would move us toward a transformation of
our constitution
a quasi-parliamentary system with the
president serving
at the pleasure of the legislative
branch would replace the framework based
on the separation of powers
i am frankly reluctant to dignify this
argument by responding to it
president nixon was driven from office
for his crimes under threat of
impeachment and removal
the disruption of the framework of our
government did not ensue
president clinton may be removed from
office for his crimes
the constitutional system will remain
sound
who has so little confidence in the
durability of the institutions of our
government that he would allow a
president guilty of perjury and
obstruction of justice to remain in
office
simply on the basis of a fanciful and
irrational fear of the supposed
consequences of his removal
the constitution contains wise
safeguards against the misuse of the
impeachment and removal power as a
practical matter as we all know
the requirement of a two-thirds vote for
conviction virtually ensures that the
president will only be removed when a
compelling case for removal has been
made
and the periodic accountability to the
people of members of both the house and
senate serves as a check on the
improvement use of the impeachment power
for unworthy or insubstantial reasons
those who would abuse the power of
impeachment and removal will be deterred
by the certain knowledge that they
ultimately must answer to the people
but of course the ultimate safeguard
against the abuse of this power
is in the sober deliberation and sound
judgment of the senate itself
the framers of the constitution vested
the removal power and responsibility in
the senate because as hamilton observed
they thought the senate the most fit
depository of this important trust
the senate was in the view of the
framers uniquely qualified to exercise
the awful discretion which a court of
impeachment must necessarily have
as hamilton explained
where else
than in the senate could have been found
a tribunal
sufficiently dignified
or sufficiently independent
what other body would be likely to feel
confidence enough in his own situation
to preserve unawed and uninfluenced
the necessary impartiality between an
individual accused and the
representatives of the people his
accusers
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
this is the great trust
which the constitution has reposed in
you
it is a trust you exercise not only for
those who elected you but for all other
americans
including generations yet unborn
as you carry out this trust
we do not suggest that you hold this
president or any president to a standard
of perfection
we do not assert that this president or
any president be called to account
before the senate for his personal
failings or his sins
we will leave the president's sins to
his family and to god
nor do we suggest that this president or
any president should be removed from
office for offenses that are not serious
and grave
but we do submit that when this
president or any president has committed
serious offenses against the system of
justice
offenses involving the stubborn
and calculated choice to place personal
interest ahead of the public interest
he must not be allowed to act with
impunity
mr manager graham has reviewed the
recent precedence of the senate
establishing that offenses such as those
committed by this president are grounds
for removal from office
those precedents which were set in the
impeachment trials of federal judges are
rejected as totally irrelevant by the
president's lawyers they urge that a
lower standard of integrity be
established in this case for the
president of the united states than the
standard which the senate has already
established for federal judges
but the constitution contains a single
standard for the exercise of the
impeachment and removal power
you've heard it before but i will repeat
article 2 section 4 provides
the president vice president and all
civil officers of the united states
shall be removed from office on
impeachment 4 and conviction of treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors
and there is nothing in the constitution
suggesting that criminal offenses which
constitute high crimes and misdemeanors
if committed by one federal official
will not be high crimes and misdemeanors
if committed by another federal official
there is nothing in the constitution to
suggest that the president should be
especially insulated from the just
consequences of his criminal conduct
justice joseph's story warned long ago
against count countenancing so absolute
a despotism of opinion in practice
which might make that a crime at one
time or in one person which would be
deemed innocent at another time or in
another person
the senate should heed the warning of
justice story and refuse to arbitrarily
establish a different standard for
judging william jefferson clinton than
the standard it has imposed already
on others brought before the bar of the
senate sitting
as a court of impeachment
the senate has never accepted the view
that a separate standard applies to the
impeachment and removal of federal
judges indeed the senate has
specifically rejected attempts to
establish such a separate standard for
judicial officers
every judge who has been impeached and
removed from office has been found
guilty of treason bribery or other high
crimes and misdemeanors
contrary to the argument advanced by
some
the constitutional provision that judges
shall hold their offices during good
behavior does not establish any
authority to remove a judge for
misconduct other
than for those offenses involving
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors rather than establishing a
standard for removal the good behavior
clause simply provides for life tenure
for all article 3 judges to accept the
good behavior clause i would caution you
to accept it as a separate basis for the
removal of federal judges
would pose a serious threat to the
independence of the judiciary under our
constitution
members of the senate the integrity
of the administration of justice depends
not only on the integrity of justice of
judges
but also on the integrity of the
president
a president who has committed perjury
and obstruction of justice is hardly fit
to oversee the enforcement of the laws
of the united states
as professor jonathan turley has pointed
out and i quote as chief executive the
president stands as the ultimate
authority over the justice department
and the administration's enforcement
policies it is unclear
how prosecutors can legitimately
threaten let alone prosecute citizens
who have committed perjury or
obstruction of justice under
circumstances virtually identical to the
president's
such inherent conflict will be even
greater in the military cases in the
president's role as commander-in-chief
it would indeed be anomalous for the
senate to now hold the president of the
united states to a lower standard of
integrity than the standard applied to
members of the judiciary there is no
sensible constitutional rationale for
such a lower standard
who could successfully defend the view
that in the framework established by our
constitution the integrity of the chief
executive
is of less importance than the integrity
of any one of the hundreds of federal
judicial officers
it is the president who appoints
justices of the supreme court and all
other federal judges it is the president
who appoints the attorney general it is
the president who appoints the director
of the federal bureau of investigation
it is the president who has the
unreviewable power to grant pardons
the power of the president under our
constitution far surpasses the power of
any other individual under our
constitution
the authority and discretion vested in
him under the constitution and laws is
great and wide-ranging
the requirement that he act with
integrity
and that he be a person of integrity
is essential to the integrity of our
system of government
soon after the adoption of the
constitution
alexander hamilton wrote
that an inviolable respect for the
constitution and laws is the most sacred
duty and the greatest source of security
in a republic
hamilton understood
that respect for the constitution itself
grows out of a general respect for the
law
and he understood the essential
connection between respect for law
and the maintenance of liberty in a
republic
without respect for the law the
foundation of our constitution is not
secure
without respect for the law our freedom
is at risk
thus according to hamilton
those who set examples which undermine
or subvert the authority of the laws
lead us from freedom to slavery
early in our own century
century which is
soon coming to its end
justice brandeis spoke of the harm to
our system of government which occurs
when officials of the government act in
a lawless manner
justice brandeis said
decency security and liberty alike
demand that government officials
shall be subjected to the same rules of
conduct that are commands to the
citizens
in a government of laws existence of the
government will be imperiled if it fails
to observe the law scrupulously
our government is the potent
the omnipresent teacher
for good or ill
it teaches the whole people by its
example
crime is contagious if the government
becomes a law breaker it breeds contempt
for law it invites every man to become a
law unto himself
it invites anarchy
to conclude
i would observe that in the case before
it now
the senate must decide
if william jefferson clinton as
president will be
subjected to the same rules of conduct
that our commands to the citizens
it is no answer
that he may one day after leaving office
perhaps be called to account in a
criminal court proceeding somewhere
justice delayed is justice denied
because he has taken and violated the
oath as president
william jefferson clinton is answerable
for his crimes to the senate here and
now
will he as president be vindicated by
the senate in the face of crimes for
which other citizens are adjudicated
felons and sent to prison
or will this senate acting in accordance
with the provisions of the constitution
bring him as president into submission
to the commands of the law
will the senate give force to the
constitutional provision for impeachment
and removal
which justice story said
compels the chief magistrate
as well as the humble citizen to bend to
the majesty of the laws
for good or for ill
william jefferson clinton teaches the
whole people by his example as president
that is an undeniable fact
the president is not only the head of
government but also the head of state
as president he has a unique ability to
command the attention of the whole
nation in his words and his deeds he
represents the american people in our
system of government in a way that no
other american can
great honor and respect accrue to him by
virtue of the high office he holds
the influence of his example
is far-reaching
and profound
by his conduct
president william jefferson clinton has
set an example
this senate cannot ignore
by his example
he has set a dangerous and subversive
standard of conduct
his calculated and stubbornly persistent
misconduct while serving as president of
the united states
has set a pernicious example of
lawlessness
an example which by its very nature
subverts respect for the law
his perverse example has the inevitable
effect of undermining the integrity of
both the office of president and the
administration of justice ladies and
gentlemen of the senate i humbly submit
to you that this harmful example
this harmful example
as president must not stand
the maintenance and office of a
president guilty of perjury and
obstruction of justice is inconsistent
with the maintenance of the rule of law
in light of the historic purpose of
impeachment the offenses charged against
the president demand that the senate
convict and remove him he must not
remain in office with all his infamy
our constitution requires that this
president who has shown such
disrespect for the truth
such disrespect for the law
and such disrespect for the dignity of
his high office
be brought to justice for his high
crimes and misdemeanors thank you
the chair recognizes the majority mr
chief justice if there's no objection i
ask the court of impeachment standing
german for one hour we will return at
ten minutes after two
the absence of objection is so ordered
as the senate takes a one-hour break for
lunch in this the third day of the
impeachment trial of the president of
the united states we are once again
opening our phone lines for your
thoughts on whether you're for acquittal
or for conviction or if you're undecided
also your thoughts on what you've to be
found guilty the president of finding
guilty himself and uh
uh
pin him up to the wall because he gave
him the bad advice thanks louise
mr chief justice i believe we're ready
to proceed now uh with the next uh
manager i believe it's uh mr manager
geekes
the chair recognizes mr manager gakus
mr chief justice
to the president's council
to members of the house who form our
group of managers
and to the members of the senate
we bring you which
now may be
the
culmination of the work and effort
of the managers and of the house of
representatives for
what is fast closing in to be your final
consideration
and that is true the moment of truth
is fast approaching
that moment of truth will swoop down on
you at some point in the near future
at which time the millions of words that
have been spoken thus far the thousands
of pages
of documents and the
hundreds of exhibits and the dozens of
individuals that have been involved
in the preparation and the
annotation and the accumulation of all
the data and evidence all of that will
be
funneled into that last moment that you
will have right before
you cast that final vote
and that's an awesome moment
in the history of this chamber
and in the personal history of your own
careers
in public service and of your own life
as well your personal life your
surroundings your family all that means
anything and everything to you that
moment of truth encompasses all of that
in one fell swoop at that final time
that is
upon us
and we would not have even had to
contemplate nor you would have had to
if
very early on in the
factual
situation that arose in this case if
early on
president clinton had faced
his moment of truth
as i pointed out yesterday
that first
moment of truth that faced the president
in the legal proceedings that were to
engulf him at a later point
was his answers the answers that he had
fixed to that first set of
interrogatories under oath
the moment of truth was staring him
right in the face
and if he would have
acknowledged it
that moment
had paid
faith and allegiance to that moment
we would not be arguing here today
nor would we have even heard of a
possible impeachment inquiry
but the president chose to sweep away
that moment of truth which was at hand
and proceeded down that course which
has led us to this moment
in the words of
our colleagues who made magnificent
presentations of the facts and laws to
you
the words
truth and fairness
were some of the strongest and most
profound that we heard in various
degrees
and touching upon various subjects
that were important to our presentations
and
when i heard
my colleagues
emphasize those words
it dawned on me that
that element of fairness
is something which i submit to you and
certify to you that these managers and
members of the committee
who prepared this case
exalted in
in
making certain
would apply to their endeavors and to
all that we would present to you
fairness
when the
record
of the independent council the referral
reached our doorsteps back in september
of 97
and we first read the details and the
allegations that were contained therein
we did not as some people began to
accuse and to
to or rate
adopt
100 percent everything that the
independent council said were the
allegations and and accept them as fact
and then move on to that to skip from
september to this moment not having used
our intellect our sympathies
our
sense of right
our sense of wrong
our sense of fairness our elements of
truth our our experience our own
intellect our own conscious we didn't
set all of those aside and take the
referral of of kenneth starr and make
that
the final moment that precedes your
moment of truth
everyone should know that but it's not
recognized
we have been
pilloried many times
over the course of these proceedings
on
the notion that we simply
adopted that referral
and walked with it
into the senate chambers
one thing that has to be said right at
the outset
when i saw in those allegations of the
independent council
one that was
encompassed around the question of
executive privilege
in which the allegation was that the
assertion by the president by president
clinton of executive privilege in the
context of all that has transpired in
this case
that that constituted in that allegation
by
judge starr
an abuse of
power i must tell you that that hit me
right between the eyes
i could not by even reading it just
reading it accept it at face value
and from that moment until this i had
serious
grave doubts that we should embark upon
a course in which we would somehow
denigrate the issue and the privilege
known as
the executive privilege
as i worried about this and as i
moved on through the process trying to
do my duty along with everyone else
there came a time in the deliberations
of our committee of our managers group
that we felt
and we acted on that feeling
that executive privilege
is something that is owed to president
clinton
that we cannot fairly
strip that away from him or in any way
diminish
the power
and the usability of executive privilege
we felt that that was a trapping and a
power of the
executive of the president of the united
states
which no matter how it's exerted or
thereafter possibly set aside by the
court which is always a possibility and
history has shown that that has occurred
nevertheless the exertion of it the
assertion of it the use of it the feel
for it that the president of the united
states must have and should have in the
first instance to assert it
should not be
a part of our criticism
our
projection of this case
we felt pretty strongly about it and we
took action on that front by
deciding among ourselves that one of the
proposed articles
which was bound to reach you if we had
not
acted as we did we decided that we were
going to remove that from
the allegations
in any of the articles of impeachment
and not referred to it
except in the context in which i'm
referring to you that is reporting to
you
what happened with that particular issue
we did that
in the face of the knowledge that
in all our readings in all our
literature we noted that when president
nixon
attempted to use executive privilege he
was soundly criticized
and part of the impeachment process
carried his
alleged abuse of executive privilege as
one of the tenants of that proceeding
and the report shows executive privilege
as being ill
by president nixon
but here is the point
the managers and i
every member of the senate
every individual who
is with us here today
reveres the office of the presidency
we respect the office of the presidency
the presidency is we the president the
presidency is america the presidency is
the banner under which we all
work
and live and strive in this nation
we revere the presidency
any
innuendo or any
kind of impulse that anyone has to
attribute any kind of motivation on the
part of these men of honor who have
prepared this case for you today
on any whim on their part other than to
do their constitutional duty
should be rebuffed at every conversation
at every meeting
at every writing that will
ultimately flow from the proceedings
that we have embarked upon
we
revere the presidency
and as a matter of fact
when next week we face the prospect of
the president united states
entering the
house of representatives to deliver his
state of the union message
we will greet the president
we will accord him
the respect
for the office which he holds
he is our president
he occupies the presidency
and we will honor that
as so and so should we all
but
we are capable of and must in the face
of the solemn duty that we have
compartmentalize
in the purest sense
in greeting the president and applauding
his entrance into the state of the union
message as we will accord him that
that privilege
we do not set aside the impeachment
inquiry
we do not set aside the serious charges
that are
are
fostered against him at this at that
juncture
because we will resume the consideration
of them in due course
but in the meantime we compartmentalize
ourselves as americans
recognizing
that he holds the
most powerful
most respected
and most
admired office
on the face of the
globe that is part of our duty
as it is our duty to impart our
knowledge our work
our theory our analysis to the
impeachment proceedings
which are at hand
these are
times that try men's soul someone said
it was not my mother
and and it is true
but
anyone who
can feel that the final vote
that will take place on the part of each
individual member of the senate
that
a vote for conviction
based on a distaste for bill clinton
hatred of bill clinton
that kind of vote for conviction
should never be recognized or
countenanced and history will condem any
individual
who does that
and if a vote
at the last moment that this moment of
truth is based
on
an admiration of president clinton a
friendship with president clinton a a
deep tie to and with the president on on
family and community and and national
matters
a vote of acquittal should not be based
on that
but only the senate and each individual
conscience
will determine how that final vote is
cast
all we can we cannot account for the
friendship or enmity that might exist
with
with and for president clinton all we
can do is to do the job that was thrust
upon us that was placed in our hands by
a statute that this congress created
that independent council statute
the congress said that we had to listen
to the referral to accept the referral
the congress said that we must look
towards whatever recommendations might
be contained in that it was the congress
our congress
many of you who voted for that statute
which mandated that we consider all of
this we did not simply walk around one
day and then seize upon a moment of deep
thought said let's impeach the president
let's find something upon which we can
base a a full six months inquiry into
the president's
actions in front of a court
this was a duty much as it is your duty
to stay here and listen to what i am
saying
the duty that i have of presenting it to
you and speaking to you is born of the
same
statute and of the same process and of
the same constitutional background
that we all share
so it it worries me and us
that
any
awkward motivation can be
attributed to any one of us or
collectively to us
and once you render your vote
i'm not going to question what it was
done out of blind loyalty or
enmity or friendship with the president
or enmity with the president
i'm going to judge it as an american
citizen
a member of the house of representatives
a member of congress
an interested
community leader
and
last but not least
as a
pure
american citizen
eager to do one's duty
as the
moment of truth
approaches
there is only one
[Music]
speaker left
for us in the
senate chambers here to contemplate and
that is the summation to be given by
the esteemed chairman of our committee
and
you should know
as we all feel
that
the most stringent
duty that he ever performed
the gentleman from illinois
was to manage the managers
but he did that just as well and as
profoundly as he has approached every
single facet of this case
whereas he sums up know
for a certainty
that he brings to the podium
our collective thoughts
our collective emotions our passions for
our work and our duty
and with an eye towards serving you
as we serve
our constituents
as we serve the congress
as we serve america
we are 20 minutes closer now
to that moment of truth
keep in mind
your own histories
the history of
your relationship to your colleagues in
the congress
and above all
the duty to the united states
mr hyde
the chair recognizes mr manager hyde
thank you mr chief justice
so
thank you asa very much mr chief justice
counsel for the president
distinguished members of the senate
139 years ago 136 years ago
at a small military cemetery in
pennsylvania
one of illinois's most illustrious sons
asked a haunting question
whether a nation conceived in liberty
and dedicated to the proposition that
all men are created equal
can long endure
america
is an experiment never finished it's a
work in progress
and so that question has to be answered
by each generation for itself just as we
will have to answer whether this nation
can long endure
this controversy
began with the fact that the president
united states took an oath to tell the
truth
in his testimony before the grand jury
just as he had on two prior occasions
sworn a solemn oath to preserve protect
and defend the constitution
and to faithfully execute the laws of
the united states
one of the most memorable aspects of
this entire proceeding
was the solemn occasion wherein every
senator
in this chamber took an oath to do
impartial justice under the constitution
but i must say despite massive and
relentless efforts to change the subject
the case before you senators is not
about sexual misconduct infidelity
adultery
those are private acts and are none of
our business
it's not even a question of lying about
sex
the matter before this body is a
question of lying under oath
this is a public act
the matter before you
is a question of the willful
premeditated deliberate corruption of
the nation's system of justice
through perjury and obstruction of
justice these are public acts
and when committed by the chief law
enforcement officer of the land the one
who appoints every united states
district attorney
every federal judge every
member for the supreme court the
attorney general
they do become the concern of congress
and that's why your judgment
respectfully should rise above politics
above partisanship above polling data
this case is a test of whether what the
founding fathers described as sacred
honor
still has meaning in our time 222 years
after those two words sacred honor were
inscribed in our country's birth
certificate
our national charter of freedom
our declaration of independence
every school child in the united states
has an intuitive sense
of the sacred honor that is one of the
foundation stones of the american house
of freedom for every day in every
classroom in america our children and
grandchildren pledge allegiance to a
nation under god
that statement is not a prideful or
arrogant claim it's a statement of
humility
all of us as individuals stand under the
judgment of god or the transcendent
truths
by which we hope finally to be judged so
does our country
the presidency is an office of trust
every public office is a public trust
but the office of the president
is a very special public trust
the president is the trustee of the
national conscience
no one owns the office of the president
the people do
the president is elected by the people
and their representatives in the
electoral college and accepting the
burdens
of that great office the president in
his inaugural oath enters into a
covenant
a binding agreement of mutual trust and
obligation with the american people
shortly after his election and during
his first few months in office president
clinton spoke with some frequency about
a new covenant
in america in this instance let's take
the president at his word that his
office is a covenant
a solemn pact of mutual trust and
obligation with the american people
let's take the president
seriously when he speaks of covenants
because a covenant is about promise
making
and promise keeping
for it's because the president has
defaulted on the promises he made it's
because he has violated the oaths
he has sworn that he has been impeached
the debate about impeachment during the
constitutional convention of
1787 makes it clear that the framers
regarded impeachment and removal from
office on conviction as a remedy for a
fundamental
betrayal of trust by the president
the framers had invested the
presidential office with great powers
they knew that those powers could be and
would be abused if any president were to
violate in a fundamental way
the oath he had sworn to faithfully
execute the nation's laws
for if the president did so violate his
oath of office the covenant of trust
between himself and the american people
would be broken
today we see something else that the
fundamental trust between america and
the world can be broken
if a presidential perjurer represents
our country in world affairs
if the president calculatedly and
repeatedly violates his oath if the
president breaks
the covenant of trust he's made with the
american people he can no longer be
trusted and because the executive plays
so large a role in representing our
country to the world america can no
longer be trusted
it's often said we live in an age of
increasing interdependence
if that's true and the evidence for it
is all around us
then the future will require an even
stronger bond of trust
between the president and the nation
because with increasing interdependence
comes an increased necessity of trust
this is one of the basic lessons of life
parents and children know it
husbands and wives know it teachers and
students know it
as do doctors patients suppliers
customers lawyers clients clergy and
parishioners the greater the
interdependence the greater the
necessity of trust
the greater the interdependence the
greater the imperative of promise
keeping trust
not what james madison called the
parchment barriers of laws is the
fundamental bond
between the people and their elected
representatives between those who govern
and those who are governed trust is the
mortar that secures the foundations of
the american house of freedom
and the senate of the united states
sitting in judgment on this impeachment
trial
should not ignore or minimize or dismiss
the fact
that that bond of trust has been broken
because the president has violated both
his oaths of office
and the oath he took before his grand
jury testimony
in recent months it's often been asked
so what
what is the harm done by this lying
under oath by this perjury
well what is an oath
an oath is in
asking almighty god to witness to the
truth of what you're saying
truth telling truth telling
is the heart and soul of our justice
system
i think the answer
would have been clear to those who once
pledged their sacred honor to the cause
of liberty
the answer would have been clear to
those who crafted the world's most
enduring written constitution
no greater harm can come can come
than breaking the covenant of trust
between the president and the people
between the three branches of our
government and between our country and
the world for to break that covenant of
trust
is to dissolve the mortar that binds the
foundation stones of our freedom into a
secure and solid edifice
and to break that covenant of trust by
violating one's oath is to do grave
damage
to the rule of law among us
that none of us is above the law as a
bedrock principle of democracy to erode
that bedrock is to risk even further
injustice to erode that bedrock
is to subscribe to a divine right of
kings theory of governance in which
those who govern
are absolved from adhering to the basic
moral standards
to which the governed are accountable we
must never tolerate one law for the
ruler and another for the ruled if we do
we break faith with our ancestors from
bunker hill lexington concord to
flanders fields
normandy iwo jima panmunjon
saigon and desert storm
let's be clear the vote you are asked to
cast is
in the final analysis a vote about the
rule of law
the rule of law is one of the great
achievements of our civilization
for the alternative to the rule of law
is the rule of raw power
we here today are the heirs of three
thousand years of history
in which humanity slowly and painfully
and at great cost evolved a form of
politics in which law
not brute force is the arbiter of our
public destinies
we're the heirs of the ten commandments
and the mosaic law a moral code for a
free people who having been liberated
from bondage saw in law
a means to avoid falling back into the
habits of slaves
we're the heirs of roman law the first
legal system
which peoples of different cultures
languages races and religions came to
live together to form a political
community
oh we're the heirs of the magna carta by
which the free men
of england began to break the arbitrary
and unchecked power of royal
absolutism we're the heirs
of a long tradition of parliamentary
development in which the rule of law
gradually came
to replace royal prerogative as the
means for governing a society of free
men and free women
yes we're the heirs of 1776
and of an epic moment in human affairs
when the founders of this republic
pledged their lives
their fortunes and yes their sacred
honor
to the defense of the rule of law
you know we're the heirs of a tragic
civil war which vindicated the rule of
law over the appetites of some for
owning others
we're the heirs of the 20th century's
great struggles against totalitarianism
in which the rule of law was defended at
immense cost
against the worst tyrannies in human
history
the rule of law is no pious aspiration
from a civics textbook the rule of law
is what stands between us and the
arbitrary exercise of power by the state
the rule of law is the safeguard of our
liberties the rule of law is what allows
us to live our freedom
in ways that honor the freedom of others
while strengthening the common good
lying under oath is an abuse of freedom
obstruction of justice is a degradation
of law
there are people in prison for such
offenses
what in the world do we say to them
about equal justice
if we overlook this conduct by the
president
some may say
as many have in recent months that this
is to pitch the matter too high
the president's lie it is said was about
a trivial matter
it was a lie to spare embarrassment
about misconduct on a private occasion
the confusing of what is essentially a
private matter and none of our business
with lying under oath to a court and a
grand jury
has been only one of the distractions
we've had to deal with
senators as men and women with
a serious experience of public affairs
we can all imagine a situation in which
a president might shade the truth
when a great issue of national interest
or national security is at stake
we've been all over that terrain we know
the thin ice
on which any of us gates when blurring
the edges of the truth
for what we consider a compelling
demanding public purpose
morally serious men and women can
imagine the circumstances at the far
edge
of the morally permissible when
with the gravest matters of national
interest at stake a president could
shade the truth
in order to serve the common good
but under oath
for a private pleasure
in doing this the office of the
president of the united states has been
debased
and the justice system jeopardized
in doing this he's broken his covenant
of trust with the american people
the framers also knew that the office of
the president
could be gravely damaged if it continued
to be unworthily occupied that's why
they devised the process of impeachment
by the house and trial by the senate it
is in truth a direct process
if on impeachment the president is
convicted
he's removed from office and the office
itself suffers no permanent damage if on
impeachment
the president is acquitted
the issue is resolved once and for all
in the office is similarly protected
from permanent damage
but if on impeachment the president is
not convicted
and removed from office despite the fact
that numerous senators are convinced
that he has in the words of one
proposed resolution of censure
egregiously failed the test of his oath
of office
violated the trust of the american
people
and dishonored the office by which
they entrusted to him
then the office of the presidency has
been deeply and perhaps permanently
damaged
and that is a further reason why
president clinton must be convicted of
the charges brought before you by the
house and removed from office to fail to
do so
while conceding that the president has
engaged in egregious and dishonorable
behavior that has broken the covenant of
trust between himself and the american
people is to diminish
the office of president of the united
states in an unprecedented
and unacceptable way
now senators
permit me a word
on my own behalf and on behalf of my
colleagues in the house
i want to clarify an important point
none of us comes to this chamber today
without a profound sense of our own
responsibilities in life
and of many ways in which we have failed
to meet those responsibilities to one
degree or another
none of us comes to you
claiming to be a perfect man or a
perfect citizen
just as none of you imagines yourself
perfect all of us
members of the house and senate know we
come to this difficult task as flawed
human beings
under judgment
that is the way of this world flawed
human beings must according to the rule
of law
judge other flawed human beings
but the issue before the senate of the
united states is not the question of its
own member's personal moral condition
nor is the issue before the senate the
question
of the personal moral condition of the
members of the house of representatives
the issue here
is whether the president
has violated the rule of law and thereby
broken
the covenant of trust with the american
people this is a public issue
involving the gravest matter of public
interest
and it's not affected one way or another
by the personal moral condition of any
member of either house
of congress or by whatever expressions
of personal chagrin
the president has managed to express
senators we
of the house don't come before you
today lightly
and if you will permit me it is a
disservice to the house to suggest
that it has brought these articles of
impeachment before you in a
mean-spirited
or irresponsible way that is not true
we have brought these articles of
impeachment because we're convinced in
conscience
that the president of the united states
lied under oath that the president
committed perjury on several occasions
before a federal grand jury we have
brought these articles of impeachment
because we are convinced in conscience
that the president willfully obstructed
justice and thereby threatened the legal
system he swore a solemn oath to protect
and defend these are not trivial matters
these are not
partisan matters
these are matters of justice
the justice that each of you has taken a
solemn oath to serve in this trial
some of us have been called clinton
haters
i must tell you distinguished senators
that this impeachment trial is not
for those of us from the house
a question of hating anyone this is not
a question of who we hate it's a
question of what we love
and among the things we love are the
rule of law equal justice before the law
and honor in our public life all of us
are trying as hard as we can to do our
duty as we see it
no more and no less
senators the trial
is being watched around the world some
of those watching
thinking themselves superior in their
cynicism wonder what it's all about
but others know political prisoners know
that this is about the rule of law the
great alternative to arbitrary and
unchecked state powers
the families of executed dissidents know
that this is about the rule of law
the great alternative to the lethal
abuse
of power by the state
those yearning for freedom know this is
about the rule of law the hard one
structure by which men and women can
live
by their god-given dignity and secure
their god-given rights in ways that
serve the common good
if they know this
can we not know it
if across the river in arlington
cemetery there are american heroes who
died in defense of the rule of law
can we give less than the full measure
of our devotion
to that great cause
i wish to read you a letter i recently
received that expresses my feelings far
better than my
poor
words dear chairman hyde
my name is william preston summers
how are you doing
i am a third grader in room 504
at chase elementary school in chicago
i'm writing this letter because i have
something to tell you
i have thought of a punishment for the
president of the united states of
america
the punishment should be that he should
write a 100 word essay by hand
i have to write an essay when i lie
it is bad to lie because it just gets
you in more trouble
i hate getting in trouble
it's just like the boy who cried wolf
and the wolf ate the boy it is important
to tell the truth i like to tell the
truth
because it gets you in less trouble if
you do not tell the truth
people do not believe you
it is important to believe the president
because he is a important person
if you cannot believe the president who
can you believe
if you have no one to believe in then
how do you run your life
i do not believe the president tells the
truth anymore right now
after he writes the essay and tells the
truth i will believe him again
william summers
then there's a ps from his dad
dear representative hind i made my son
william either write you a letter or an
essay
as a punishment for lying
part of his defense for his lying was
that the president lied
he's still having difficulty
understanding
why the president can lie
and not be punished
mr chief justice and senators on june
the 6th
1994
it was the 50th anniversary of the
american landing at normandy
and i went ashore
on normandy at normandy and walked up to
the
cemetery area where as far as the eye
could see there were white crosses
stars of david and the british had a
bagpipe banned
scattered among the crucifixes the
crosses playing
amazing grace with that pearceful
mournful sound that only the bagpipe can
make
and if you could keep your eyes
dry you were better than i
but i walked up to one of these crosses
marking a grave because i wanted to
personalize the experience i was looking
for a name
but there was no name it said here lies
in honored glory
a comrade in arms known but to god
how do we keep faith with that comrade
in arms
well go to the vietnam memorial on the
national mall and press your hands
against the 58 000
a few of the 58 000 names carved into
that wall and ask yourself
how we can redeem the debt we owe all
those who purchased our freedom with
their lives
how do we keep faith with them
i think i know
we work to make this country
the kind of america they were willing to
die for
that's an america where the idea of
sacred honor
still has the power to stir men's souls
my solitary solitary hope is
that a hundred years from today people
will look back
at what we've done and
say they kept the faith
i'm done
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice pursuant to the
previous consent agreement i now ask
unanimous consent the senate standing
adjournment under that order
without objection it's so ordered
the senate under previous order stands
adjourned until 9 30 a.m third tuesday
january 19th
at which time it will reconvene in
legislative session
under that same order the senate will
next convene as a court of impeachment
on tuesday january 19th at 1 o'clock p.m
the senate stands adjourned
the third day of the impeachment trial
of the president of the united states a
great deal banks ohio the senate is in
session sergeant arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
the majority leader is recognized
mr chief justice uh it is my
understanding that the white house
excuse me presentation day will last
approximately two and one half hours
uh maybe a little more maybe a little
less uh but i would therefore suggest
that a short recess be taken in
approximately an hour around two o'clock
to allow the chief justice and all
members to take a brief break
and i remind all senators that they
would remain standing at their desk each
time the chief justice enters and
departs the chamber
if there's a need for another break i
will kind of keep an eye on the white
house council to see if they need a
break and we'll act accordingly uh of
course i remind senators again uh
tonight uh if you would be in the
chamber at 8 35 so that we can proceed
to the joint session i thank my
colleagues for their attention i yield
the floor mr chief justice and i believe
we're ready to begin
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date personal to the provisions of
senate rule 16 the council for the
president have 24 hours to make the
presentation of their case the senate
will now hear you
uh
the chair recognizes mr counsel rough to
begin the presentation of the case for
the president
mr chief justice
members of the senate
distinguished managers
william jefferson clinton
is not guilty of the charges
that have been preferred against him
he did not commit perjury
he did not obstruct justice
he must not
be removed from office
now merely to say those words brings
into sharp belief the fact
that i and my colleagues are here today
in this great chamber defending the
president of the united states
for only the second time in our nation's
history
the senate has convened to try
the president of the united states on
articles of impeachment
there is no one who does not feel the
weight of this moment
nonetheless our role as lawyers
as much as it would be in any other
forum
we will not be able to match the
eloquence
of the thirteen managers who spoke to
you last week
we will try however
to respond to the charges levied against
the president
as directly
and candidly
as possible
and to present his defense
as clearly and as cogently as we are
able
we seek on his behalf no more
than
we know you will give us
a fair opportunity to be heard
a fair assessment of the facts and the
law
and a fair judgment
we will defend the president on the
facts
and on the law
and on the constitutional principles
that must guide your deliberations
some have suggested
that we fear to do so
we do not
i begin with a recitation
of some of the events that have brought
us here today
although many of them may be familiar
they merit some discussion
because they form the backdrop against
which you must assess the evidence
i will then move to a discussion of the
constitutional principles
that we submit should guide your
consideration of these matters
and finally to an overview of the
allegations contained in the articles
with a view towards focusing your
attention
on what we believe to be the principal
legal and factual flaws
in the case presented by the managers
my colleagues
will follow tomorrow and the following
day with a more detailed analysis of the
facts underlying the articles
and the end of our presentation
we will have demonstrated beyond any
doubt
that there is no basis
on which the senate can
or should
convict
the president of any of the charges
brought against him
now let me begin with
a brief recital of the
essential events in the paula jones
litigation
which underlies so much of
what we've been discussing for the last
week
on may 6 1994
paula jones
sued president clinton in the united
states district court for the eastern
district of arkansas
she claimed that then governor clinton
had made in 1991 some unwelcome overture
to her in an arkansas hotel room
and that she suffered adverse employment
consequences and was subsequently
defamed
after the supreme court decided in may
1997
that civil litigation against the
president
could go forward while he was in office
the case was remanded to the district
court
and over the fall in the winter
of 1997
the jones lawyers deposed numerous
witnesses
and inevitably despite the strict
protective order
entered by judge wright
and the continuing exhortation
to counsel not to discuss any aspect of
the case with the press
information flowed from those
depositions
into the public forum
clearly with only one purpose
to embarrass the president
now the principal focus of the discovery
being conducted by the jones lawyers
during this period was not on the merits
of their client's case
they demoted most of their time and
their energy
to attempt to pry into the personal life
of the president
mr bennett president's council objected
to those efforts on the ground that they
had no relevance to ms jones's claims
and were intended to do nothing other
than advance the agendas of those who
were supporting ms jones's lawsuit
jones lawyers however pursued their
efforts to inquire into the president's
relations with other women
and on december 11 1997
judge wright issued an order allowing
questioning regarding
only quote any individuals with whom the
president
had sexual relations or proposed or
sought to have sexual relations and who
were doing it during the relevant time
frame
state or federal employees
then on december 5th 1997
the jones lawyers placed on their
witness list
the name of monica lewinsky
and on december 19 she was served with a
subpoena for a deposition to be
scheduled in january
consistent with rulings issued by judge
wright in connection with the jones
lawyer's efforts to secure the testimony
of a number of other women
some had sought to avoid testifying by
submitting affidavits to the effect that
they had no knowledge
relevant to ms jones's lawsuit or that
they otherwise did not meet the tests
that judge wright had established before
permitting this invasive discovery to go
forward
on january 7th 1998 ms lewinsky did
execute such an affidavit
and her lawyer provided copies
to lawyers for ms jones and for the
president on january 15.
the jones lawyers deposed the president
on january 17th 1998.
he began the deposition by proffering to
him
a multi-paragraph definition
of the term sexual relations that they
intended to use in questioning him
and they're followed in extended debate
among council and the court concerning
the propriety and the clarity of that
definition
mr bennett objected to its use arguing
that it was unclear
that it would encompass conduct wholly
irrelevant to the case and it was unfair
to require the president
to apply a definition that he had never
seen before to each question he was
asked
indeed mr bennett urged the lawyers for
ms jones to ask the president specific
questions about his conduct but they
declined to do so
judge wright
acknowledged the over breadth of the
definition
but she ultimately determined that the
jones lawyers could use
a heavily edited version of the
definition that left in place only the
two lines
of paragraph one
with which you are already familiar
immediately after this extended legal
skirmish
jones lawyers began asking about monica
lewinsky
mr bennett objected
questioning whether council had a
legitimate basis for their inquiry
in light of ms lewinsky's affidavit
denying any relationship with the
president
the judge wright overruled that
objection and permitted the jones
lawyers to pursue their inquiry
four days later
the independent council's investigation
became a public matter
and on january 29th responding to a
request by the independent council to
bar further inquiry relating to ms
lewinsky
judge wright ruled that evidence
relating to her relationship with the
president
would be excluded from the trial
she reaffirmed this ruling on march 9
stating that the evidence was not quote
essential to the core issues in this
case
of whether plaintiff herself was the
victim of sexual harassment hospital
work environment or intentional
infliction
intentional affliction of emotional
distress
on april first 1998 right
[Applause]
apologize for the logistical
problems but why don't i just hold it
on april 1st 1998 judge wright granted
summary judgment
in favor of president clinton dismissing
the jones suit in its entirety
she ruled that no evidence that ms jones
had offered
or that her lawyers had discovered made
out any viable claim of sexual
harassment or intentional infliction of
emotional distress
importantly judge wright ruled that
evidence of any pattern or practice
of comparable conduct by the president
was not important to the case
i want to take just a moment to read the
relevant portion
of judge wright's opinion
not to demean in any sense
plaintiffs with claims of sexual
harassment or to suggest that we must be
other than vigilant to protect the
rights of all citizens
but simply to bring into slightly
sharper focus
the president's deposit the role that
the president's deposition played
in the real jones litigation
judge wright wrote
whatever relevance such evidence may
have
to prove other elements of plaintiff's
case
it does not have anything to do with the
issues presented by the presidents and
ferguson's motions for summary judgment
i.e whether plaintiff herself
was the victim of alleged quid pro quo
or hostile work environment
sexual harassment whether the president
and ferguson conspired to deprive her of
her civil rights or whether she suffered
emotional distress
so severe in nature that no reasonable
person could be expected to endure it
whether other women may have been
subjected to workplace harassment and
whether such evidence has allegedly been
suppressed
does not change the fact
that plaintiff has failed to demonstrate
that she has a case worthy of submitting
to a jury
now ms jones appeal judge wright's
decision to the a circuit
heard arguments on october 20th 1998
and on november 13th 1998 before a
decision was rendered ms jones and the
president settled the case
briefly then to
what was happening on the front
of the independent council's office
in mid-january 1998
linda tripp had brought to the
independent council information that she
had been gathering surreptitiously for
months about ms lewinsky's relationship
with the president and her involvement
in the jones case
and thus began
the penultimate chapter
as you will see
ms tripp's relationship with ms lewinsky
and her role
in these matters
is more than merely a backdrop to the
succeeding events
independent council met with miss tripp
informally granted her immunity from
federal prosecution
promised to assist her in securing
immunity from state prosecution where
she had been illegally taping the
telephone calls with ms lewinsky
on january 13th ms tripp agreed to a
conversa to tape a conversation with ms
lewinsky under fbi auspices and on
january 15th armed with that tape the
independent council first contacted the
department of justice to seek permission
from the attorney general to expand its
jurisdiction to cover the investigation
it had already begun
on january 16th
that permission was granted by the
special division of the court of appeals
now the president's deposition was
scheduled to take place the very next
day saturday january 17th
on the 16th in his trip
invited ms lewinsky to have lunch with
her in the pentagon city mall
and there she was greeted by a corps of
fbi agents and independent council
lawyers and taken to a whole hotel room
where she spent the next several hours
this trip was in the room next door for
much of that time
when she left that evening she went home
to meet with the jones lawyers with whom
we know she has been in contact for many
months
in order to brief them about her
knowledge of the relationship between ms
lewinsky
and the president so that they in turn
could question the president the next
morning
as the independent council himself has
acknowledged
this trip was able to play this oddly
multifaceted role
because although as part of her immunity
agreement the oic could have prevented
her from talking about ms lewinsky
they inexplicably
chose not to
the existence of the oic investigation
was made public on the january 21st
edition
of the washington post and was the
all-consuming focus
of media coverage for the ensuing eight
months
on august 17th the president's
deposition was taken
by the independent council for use by
the grand jury
and on september 9 there was delivered
to the house of representatives a
referral from independent council star
containing what purported to be
information concerning acts
quote that may constitute grounds for
impeachment
the referral was accompanied by some 19
boxes
documents grand jury transcripts
and a videotape of the president's grand
jury testimony
the referral was made public by the
house on september 11th
on september 21st additional materials
were released along with the president's
grand jury videotape which was then
played
virtually non-stop on every television
station in the country during that day
the committee held a total of four days
of hearings
one for preliminary presentations by
majority and minority council
one for testimony by independent council
star
and two
in which the president was permitted to
call witnesses
and present his defense
in addition the constitutional
subcommittee
held one hearing
on the standards for impeachment
and the committee convened in its
oversight capacity to hear witnesses on
the meaning of perjury
the committee called
no fact witnesses
despite numerous efforts to extract from
the committee
some description of the specific charges
against which the president would have
to defend himself
it was not until approximately 4 30 on
december 9
as i was completing my testimony before
the committee
that any such notice was provided
and then it came
in the form of four draft articles of
impeachment
three days later the committee reported
out those articles
and on december 9
the house completed its action
referring to the senate article 1
charging perjury in the grand jury
defeating article 2
which alleged perjury in the jones
deposition
exhibiting article 3
which charged obstruction of justice
and defeating article 4 which alleged
false statements to the house of
representatives
and so we are here
but before moving on let me pause on an
important procedural point
although the senate has asked that the
parties address the issue of witnesses
only after these presentations have been
completed
the managers spent much of their time
last week explaining to you why
if only witnesses could be called
you would be able to resolve all of the
supposed conflicts in the evidence
tell me then how is it
that the managers can be so certain of
the strength of their case
they didn't hear any of these witnesses
the only witness they called the
independent counsel himself
acknowledged that he had not even met
any of the witnesses who testified
before the grand jury
yet they appear before you to
tell you that they are convinced of the
president's guilt
and that they are prepared to demand his
removal from office
well the managers would have you believe
that the judiciary committee and the
house were really nothing more than
grand jurors
serving as some routine screening device
to sort out impeachment chaff from
impeachment wheat
thus as they would have it
there was no need for anything more than
a review
of the cold record prepared by the
independent council
no need for them to make judgments about
credibility or conflicts
indeed they offered you a short lesson
in grand jury practice telling you that
u.s attorneys do this thing all the time
that calling real live witnesses before
a grand jury is the exception to the
rule
well it's been a few years since i
served as u.s attorney for the district
of columbia
so there may have been
a change in the way prosecutors go about
their business
but i don't think so
and so what lesson can be learned
from the process followed by the house
i suggest that what you have before you
is not the product
of the judiciary committee's
well-considered
judicious assessment of their
constitutional role
know what you have before you
is the product of nothing more than a
rush to judgment
and so how should you respond to the
manager's belated plea
that more is needed to do justice
you should reject it you have before you
all that you need to reach this
conclusion
there was no basis for the house to
impeach
and there is now and never will be
any basis for the senate to convict
now the managers have not shown and
could not on this record or any record
prove that the president committed any
of the offenses charged in the articles
but even if they could
these offenses would not want your
deciding to remove the president from
office
in this regard an impeachment trial is
unlike any other
you are the judges of the law and the
facts and the appropriate sanction
before casting a vote of guilty or not
guilty
you must decide not only whether the
president committed the act with which
he is charged
but whether those acts so seriously
undermine the integrity of our
governmental structure
that he must be removed from office
i want to deal here for just a moment
with an argument that was advanced in
the press by one of the managers
and that is that the question whether
the offense is described in the articles
are impeachable
is not really before you
that it has already been decided by the
house
as the manager put it in a press
interview
quote are these impeachable offenses
which i think has already been resolved
by the house
i think constitutionally that's our job
to do
now i trust in light of last week's
extended discussion that the managers no
longer press that notion
for it was remarkable in at least three
respects
first it's entirely inconsistent with uh
don't worry about it this is just a
routine procedural process leave the
difficult decisions to the senate
argument
so frequently heard
during the proceedings in the house
second it's an argument that rings
hollow coming from those
who did not even debate the
constitutional standards or seek any
consensus on what those standards should
be
and third and most importantly
it arrogates to the house
the critical constitutional judgment
which is yours alone
far be it from me or indeed anyone else
to instruct this body
on its constitutional role
but i do think that it would help us all
to be reminded of the words
of alexander hamilton and federalist
number 65
because impeachment necessarily deals
with injuries
done immediately to society
alexander hamilton wrote
the prosecution of them for this reason
will so them fail
to agitate the passions of the whole
community
and to divide it into parties more or
less friendly or inimical to the accused
in many cases it will connect itself
with pre-existing factions
and will enlist all their animosities
partialities influence and interest
on one side or on the other
and in such cases there will always be
the greatest danger
that the decision will be regulated more
by the comparative strength of parties
than by the real demonstrations of
innocence or guilt
the delicacy and magnitude of the trust
which so deeply concerns the political
regulation
and existence of every man engaged in
the administration of public affairs
speak for themselves
the difficulty of placing it rightly in
a governmental government resting
entirely on the basis of periodical
elections
will as readily be perceived when it is
considered that the most conspicuous
characters in it
will from that circumstance
be too often the leaders or the tools
of the most coming or the most numerous
faction and on this account can hardly
be expected to possess the requisite
neutrality
towards those whose conduct may be the
subject of scrutiny
and then
the convention it appears
fought the senate
the most fit depository
of this important trust
now the president may be removed from
office only upon impeachment
for and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors
the offenses charged here even if
supported by the evidence do not meet
that lofty standard
a standard that the framers
intentionally set
at this extraordinarily high level to
ensure that only the most serious
offenses
and in particular those that subverted
our system of government would justify
overturning
a popular election
impeachment is not a remedy for private
wrongs
it's a method of removing someone whose
continued presence in office
would cause grave danger to the nation
listen to the words of 10 republican
members of the 1974
judiciary committee
one of whom now sits in this body
after president nixon's resignation in
an effort
to articulate a a measured and a careful
assessment of the issues they had
confronted
they reviewed the historical origins
of the impeachment clause and wrote
it is our judgment
based upon this constitutional history
that the framers of the united states
constitution
intended that the president should be
removable by the legislative branch
only for serious misconduct
dangerous to the system of government
established by the constitution
absent the element of danger
to the state we believe the delegates to
the federal convention of 1787
in providing that the president should
serve for a fixed elective term
rather than during good behavior or
popularity
struck the balance
in favor of stability in the executive
branch
now where did this lesson in
constitutional history come from
it came directly from the words of the
framers in 1787.
impeachment was no strange arcane
concept to them
it was familiar to them as part of
english constitutional practice and was
part of many state constitutions
it is therefore not surprising
that whether to make provision for
impeachment of the president became the
focus of contention
especially in the context of concern
whether in our new republican form of
government
the legislator ought to be in trust
entrusted with such a power
on this latter point
perhaps foretelling the notion that
impeachment ought to be a matter of
constitutional last resort
benjamin franklin noted
that it at least had the merit
of being a peaceful alternative to
revolution
now governor moore is one of the
principal moving forces behind the
language that ultimately emerged from
the convention
believe that provision for impeachment
should be made but that the offenses
must be
limited and carefully defined
his concern was very clearly for the
corrupt president who may be bribed by a
greater interest to betray his trust as
he wrote
and no one would say that we ought to
expose ourselves to the danger of seeing
the first magistrate in foreign pay
without being able to guard against it
by displacing it
drafts as they emerge from the
convention
move through one that authorized
impeachment
for treason or bribery or corruption
and then the more limited treason or
bribery
until the critical debate december
september 8 1787
when pointing to the then current
example of the impeachment
of warren hastings george mason moved to
add the word mal administration
to that definition
it was in the face of objections from
james madison and morris however
that this term was too vague
and would be the equivalent to tenure
during the pleasure of the senate
that mason withdrew his proposal
and the convention then adopted the
language
other high crimes
and misdemeanors against the state
as morris put it
an election every four years will
prevent
mal administration
there's no question that the frame is
reviewed or viewed this language
as responsive to mason's concerns excuse
me tomorrow's concerns that the
impeachment be limited and well defined
to argue then as the managers do
that the phrase other
crimes and misdemeanors
was really meant to encompass a wide
range of offenses that one might find in
a compendium
of english criminal law simply flies in
the face of the clear intent of the
framers
who carefully chose their language knew
exactly what those words meant and knew
exactly what risks they intended to
protect against
looking back on this drafting history
the 1974
minority report described the purpose of
the framers in these words
they were concerned
with preserving the government
from being overthrown by the treachery
or corruption of one man
now the managers have made fun of the
notion
that hundreds of distinguished scholars
and historians expressed their opinion
that the offenses with which the
president has been charged are not high
crimes or misdemeanors indeed they
suggested
not too subtly that they must have
signed those letters because they were
political supporters of the president
to quote them
you go out and obtain from your
political allies and friends in the
academic world
to sign a letter saying the offenses as
alleged in the articles of impeachment
do not rise to the level of an
impeachable offense
well
as i understand the manager's position
it is that
gary wills sold his intellectual soul
because he's a political supporter of
the president
stephen ambrose sold his political soul
his intellectual soul because he's a
political supporter of the president
steven woodward sold his intellectual
soul because he's a political supporter
of the president
is it possible instead that
distinguished scholars of all political
persuasions
thought it important to offer their
professional opinion on a matter of the
greatest historical
and legal import because they cared
about our country
because they cared that the
constitutional process not be the base
perhaps it's the majority members of the
full judiciary committee
had paused for even a moment to consider
these issues
they'd taken even a few hours to debate
the question
of what constitutional standards should
apply
one might now give greater credence
through the belated constitutional
exposition
that they have offered here
instead perhaps the majority was
convinced by their own
rhetoric by the oft-repeated mantra that
impeachment is merely a preliminary step
in the process
and the house need not be concerned with
its weighty constitutional duty
i saw little reason to explore the
constitutional underpinnings
of that duty
or perhaps
they understood that a full and candid
exploration
would reveal
that the proposed articles had no
constitutional underpinning at all
now the central premise of the manager's
argument appears to be this
perjury is an impeachable offense no
matter the forum
or the circumstances
in which it is committed
second
three judges have recently been
convicted and removed on the basis of
articles charging that they committed
perjury
the president committed perjury
therefore the president must be removed
as well
that premise is simple
but wrong
the first leg on which it rests
was removed by the house itself when it
voted to defeat article 2
alleging perjury in the civil deposition
and the house thus rejected the
committee's core argument
that perjury in a civil deposition
warrants impeachment as much as perjury
in any other setting
as to the committee's view that the
constitutional standard for impeachment
requires that all perjury be treated
alike thus the house concluded no
and properly sell
and as to the committee's view that it
makes no difference whether perjury
occurs in one forum or another in a
private or an official proceeding
again the house said no
and properly so
what then of the manager's argument that
the senate's recent conviction of three
judges
requires conviction on the articles
before you today
again
they simply have it wrong
both as a matter of senate precedent
and as a matter of constitutional
analysis
they argue that because the judge has
obliged faithfully to ex to carry out
the law just as the president is
each must be removed if he commits
perjury or obstructs justice
judges and presidents
and one would presume all other civil
officers if you follow their argument
towards logical delusion including
assistant secretaries and others
must in their view be removed from
office if the senate finds that they
committed either offense
removed without a second thought
but judges are different
indeed every civil officer other than
the president of the united states is
different
they're different because
before deciding
whether to impose the ultimate sanction
of removal
the senate must weigh in the balance
dramatically different
considerations
first
the answer to the ultimate impeachment
question
that is whether the conduct charge so
undermines
the official's capacity to perform his
constitutional duties that removal is
required despite the institutional
trauma it may cause
must be very different
for one of 900 or a thousand judges with
lifetime tenure who can only be removed
by impeachment
than it is for one person
elected every four years by the people
to serve as the head of the executive
branch
surely the managers recognize
that
the senate here faces a far different
question
a far different constitutional issue
than it did for example when it asked
whether judge nixon
convicted and imprisoned
for perjury
should be permitted to retain his office
or whether
judge hastings who lied
about taking a bribe to fix a case
before
should remain on the bench
indeed a telling rejoinder to the house
manager's argument
comes from president ford
on many occasions we have all seen cited
his statement in 1970 in connection with
a proposal to impeach
associate justice william o douglas
that impeachment is in essence whatever
the majority of the house of
representatives considers it to be
but no one really notes the more
important part of president ford's
statement
29 years ago
i want to read it to you
i think it is fair to come to one
conclusion however
from our history of impeachments
a higher standard is expected of federal
judges than of any other civil officers
of the united states
the president and the vice president
and all persons holding office at the
pleasure can be thrown out of office by
the voters at least every four years
to remove them in mid-term
it has been tried only twice
and never done
would indeed require crimes of the
magnitude of treason and bribery
now the senate must ask here whether the
conduct charged against president
clinton
would in its nature be inconsistent
with a decision to allow him
to continue to perform the duties of his
office
just as you would ask if you had a judge
before you or another civil officer
before you
whether the charges are similarly
inconsistent
with the notion that he or she
should be allowed to continue to perform
those duties
as former house judiciary committee
chairman peter rodino
who surely understood the difference
between impeaching a president
and impeaching a judge
explained during the claiborne
proceedings before this body
the judges of our federal courts
occupy a unique position of trust and
responsibility in our government
they are the only members of any branch
that hold their office for life
they are purposely insulated from the
immediate pressures and shifting
currents of the body politic
but he said
with the special prerogative of judicial
independence
comes the most exacting standard
of public and private conduct
a similar theme can be found
running through the debate in very
recent years over a proposal to
establish a process other than
impeachment for the removal of judges
who fail to live up to the good behavior
standard
both the proponents of the proposal and
the legal opinion offered in support of
it
emphasize that the standard to which
judges must adhere
is stricter than the impeachment
standard noting
that quote the terms treason bribery and
other high crimes and misdemeanors are
narrower than the malfeasance in office
and failure to perform the duties of the
office which may be grounds for
forfeiture of office held during good
behavior
thus whether weighing the constitutional
and governmental implications of removal
or asking whether the accused can be
expected to perform his duties
the senate has always recognized that
the test will be different depending on
the office
that the accused holds
this analysis is wholly consistent with
the framers intent in drafting the
impeachment clause
that removal of a present by the
legislature must be an act of last
resort
when the political process can no longer
protect the nation
nothing in the cases brought before the
senate in the last 210 years
suggests a different result
and the managers also attribute to the
president
the argument that impeachment can never
reach
personal conduct
that is not our position
as i told the judiciary committee on
december 9th when i testified before
them
not all serious misconduct flowing from
one of the president's official roles
is impeachable
neither
is all serious misconduct flowing from
his personal conduct
immune from impeachment
judgments must be made
and they must be based on the core
principles
that inform the framers decisions
but the managers would in effect ask you
to issue making these judgments
they speak of perjury and obstruction of
justice in general terms
and they argue that they are offenses
inimical to their system of justice
no one here would dispute that
simplistic proposition
but the managers will not walk with you
down the difficult path
they will not speak of facts of
differing circumstances and differing
societal interests
they will not
because they do not appear to recognize
that those questions must be asked
now perhaps the one exception
to this was in the very last moment of
chairman hyde's closing
when he suggested with what might
to many seem
almost an inverted logic
that a lie to spare embarrassment about
misconduct on a private occasion
was more deserving of removal
than a lie about
as he described it important matters of
state
now although i submit that that
conclusion might have struck
the framers as somewhat odd
one can certainly conceive of acts
arising out of personal conduct
that would warrant conviction and
removal
but you cannot ignore
the circumstances in which the conduct
occurs
or abandon the core principle
that impeachment should be reserved for
those cases
in which the president's very capacity
to govern is called into question
perjury about some
official act
may indeed be a constitutionally
acceptable basis
for impeachment
perjury about a
purely private matter should at the very
least add lead this body
to question whether no matter how
seriously we take
the person's violation for example of
the witnesses oath
the drastic remedy of removal from
office is the proper response
indeed in a sense that is the message
sent
by the house when it defeated article
two
the principle that guides your
deliberations i suggest must not only be
faithful to the intent
of the framers
it must be consistent with the
governmental structure that they gave us
and the delicate relationship between
the legislative branch and the executive
branch that is the hallmark of that
structure
it must above all
reflect the recognition that removal
from office is an act of extraordinary
proportions to be taken only when no
other response
is adequate to preserve the integrity
and viability of our democracy
on this point and here i'll fend off the
wrath or maybe the scorn of the managers
by quoting not a scholar or a professor
but rather a witness called by the
majority members of the judiciary
committee to testify as an expert
on the issue of perjury
a witness who had served on the
judiciary committee in 1974
judge charles wiggins told the members
of the committee this
when you were called upon
as i think you will be called upon to
vote as a member of the house of
representatives
your standard should be
the public interest
and i confess to you
said judge wiggins
that i would recommend that you not vote
to impeach the president
now beyond the question of what
constitutes an impeachable offense
each senator must also confront the
question of what standard the evidence
must meet to justify a vote of guilty
we recognize that the senate has chosen
in the cleburne proceedings and
elsewhere
not to impose its on itself any single
standard of proof but rather to leave
that judgment to the conscience of the
individual senator
many of you were present for the debate
on that issue
and chose a standard for yourselves
many of you come to the issue refresh
and none of you thankfully
has had to face the issue
in the setting of a presidential
impeachment
now we argued before the judiciary
committee that it must treat a vote to
impeach as a vote to remove
and that that judgment ought not to be
based on anything less than a clear and
convincing standard
a standard indeed adopted by the
watergate committee 25 years ago
and surely no lesser standards should be
applied here
indeed we submit to you
that given the gravity of the decision
you must reach
each of you should go further and ask
whether the house has established guilt
beyond a reasonable ballot
and this submission is made even more
compelling by the manager's own position
in which they made clear to you
last week that proof of criminal conduct
in their view was required to justify
conviction
now lawyers in layman too often i think
treat
the standard of proof as meaningless
legal jargon
with no real application to the world of
difficult decisions
but i suggest to you that it is much
more than that
it is the guidepost
that shows you the way through the
labyrinth of conflicting evidence
it tells you to look within yourself and
ask
would i make the most important
decisions of my life
based on the level of certainty i have
about these facts
and in the unique legal political
setting of an impeachment proceeding
it protects against partisan
overreaching
and it assures the public
that a grave decision is being made with
due care
it is the disciplining force i think
that you will carry with you into your
deliberations
and let me say that even if the clear
and convincing standard that you applaud
for judicial impeachments
it does not follow that it should be
applied for the presidency itself is at
stake
with judges the senate must weigh
and balance its concern for the
independence of the judiciary against
the recognition that because a judge is
appointed for life
impeachment is the only available method
for removing from office those who are
corrupt
on the other hand when a president is on
trial the balance is very different
here you were asked in effect to
overturn the will of the elector
to overturn the results of an election
held two years ago in which the american
people selected the head of one of the
three coordinate branches of government
moreover you have been asked to take
this action in circumstances
where even taking the darkest view of
the manager's position there is no
suggestion of corruption or misuse of
office
or any other conduct that places our
system of government at risk in the two
remaining years of this president's term
when once again the people will get the
chance to decide
who should lead them
in this setting we submit
you should test the evidence by the
strictest standard you know
i want to talk for a few minutes
about what we see as the constitutional
deficiency of the articles you have
before you
when the framers took
from english practice the parliamentary
weapon
of impeachment
they recognized that the form of the
government they had
created with its finely tuned balance
among the branches
was inconsistent with the parliamentary
dominance inherent in the english model
they chose therefore to build a
quasi-judicial
impeachment process one that had
admittedly political overtones
but that carried with it the basic
principles of due process
embodied in the constitution they had
written
among those principles is the sixth
amendment's guarantee that the accused
shall have the right
to be informed of the nature and cause
of the accusation against him
that right has been recognized to have
special force in perjury cases
where it is the rule uniformly enforced
by the courts
that an indictment must inform the
defendant specifically what false
statement he is alleged to have made
this is not some mere technicality it is
the law it's the law because our courts
have recognized that if a criminal
charge is to be based on the words
uttered by a fallible human being
he must be allowed to defend the
truthfulness of the specific words he
used and not be convicted
on the basis merely of some prosecutor's
summary or interpretation
this is not some legal nicety that the
house of represents can ignore as it has
many other elements of due process this
is not an argument we raise with this
body merely in passing as a lawyer's
gambit this is an important principle of
our jurisprudence
and i suggest that it is one
that this body must honor
there's not a court anywhere from
highest to lowest
who would hesitate
if they were confronted with an
indictment written like these articles
to throw it out
indeed if you want some evidence of how
others have perceived this issue look to
the hastings and nixon cases
in both of which
the article's charging impeachment
specifically stated the false statements
that they were accused of having made
why if the house understood the
importance of specificity in those cases
they did not understand
the if anything greater importance of
telling the president of the united
states what he was charged with
if you compare the closing argument of
majority council
and the majority report filed by the
committee
and the trial brief filed by the house
and the presentation of the managers
last week
you will begin to understand what has
happened here
i challenge any member of the senate
indeed any manager
to identify the charges that the house
authorized them to bring
just to take one example
we do not know to a certainty that the
house decided or we do know to a
certainty that the house decided not to
charge perjury in the civil deposition
yet to listen to the manager's
presentation last week
one would be hard put to include to
conclude that
one would be hard put to include to
conclude that they understood that
they have in essence treated these
articles as empty vessels to be filled
with some
witches brew of charges considered
charges considered an abandoned and
charges never considered at all
both article 1 and article 2 are
constitutionally deficient for other
reasons as well
in particular each charges multiple
offenses
and is therefore void in the criminal
justice vernacular for duplicity
because
in a criminal case and here as well
lumping multiple offenses together in
one charging document
creates a risk
that a verdict may be based not on a
unanimous finding of guilt
as to any particular charge
but instead may be composed of multiple
individual judgments
and though that risk
is in direct violation
of the requirement of the constitution
that this body agree by a two-thirds
majority
before the president may be removed
now the house responds to the
president's concerns in this regard
by arguing that
uh well the amendment of senate rule 23
which prohibits division of the articles
somehow addressed this concern
and that our argument would undermine
the senate's own rules
but that is not so
rule 23 was approved to permit the most
judicious and effective
handling of the questions presented to
the senate
it can't be
that the senate
in passing that rule and you know surely
better than i
decided to purchase efficiency and
impeachment proceedings
at the price
of violating the constitutional mandate
to ensure a two-thirds
vote for removal
now three years after the revision
of rule 23
in the trial of judge nixon
this very issue was presented
and senator senator cole captured
that problem
although the first and second articles
of impeachment allege that judge nixon
had committed specific
violations of the perjury statute
the third article was a catch-all
alleging that he made quote one or more
of fourteen different false statements
and i would note for you that that
language one or more
was identical to the language
specifically inserted
into article one at the request of
congressman rogan during the judiciary
committee proceedings
in addressing the
propriety of such a charging device
senator cole said
the managers should not be allowed to
use a shotgun or blunderbuss
we should send a message to the house
please do not bunch up your allegations
charge each act of wrongdoing in a
separate count
such a change would clarify things
and allow for a cleaner vote
on guilt or innocence
and senator dole who surely knew
something about senate rules and
precedence
certainly didn't think that rule 23
bound
the result in that nixon case
he first voted to dismiss
article three and then later voted to a
quick judge nixon because it was
redundant complex and confusing
33 senators joined senator dole
in voting to dismiss the article
and a total of 40 vote to acquit
when it came to a judgment of guilt or
innocence
senators cole biden and murkowski
each spoke about the danger posed by
this formulation
and i'll look once more to senator a
call
this wording presents a variety of
problems
first of all it means that judge nixon
can be convicted even if two-thirds of
the senate does not agree and which is
political in which
his political statements were false
the house is telling us
that it's okay to convict judge nixon on
article three
even if we have different version
visions of what he did wrong
but that's not fair to judge nixon
to the senate
or to the american people
those senators were not acting in
derogation of the senate senate rules or
precedence they were acting in a spirit
of fairness to the accused
and in the very best tradition
of american due process
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice uh i believe that the
uh
council has indicated that willingness
to take a break at this point therefore
i'd ask unanimous consent that we take a
brief 15-minute uh recess in the
proceedings without objection it's so
ordered
for one thing
i i'm undecided and i don't envy
anybody in the senate by having to deal
with this
i think what happened is that the pat
the president panicked
and uh in panicking
this just got blown all out thanks
florida the chair recognizes the
majority leader
mr chief justice i believe we will
continue now with a
further statement from uh mr uh of the
council ruff
the chair recognizes mr counsel ruff to
continue his presentation
thank you mr chief justice uh my first
question is
is it working
thank you very much i apologize for the
mechanical difficulties earlier
i could go back over the first hour but
i'll move on
i want now to move to
an overview of the articles of
impeachment themselves
as i said as i came to
the end of the first hour
these articles are constitutionally
defective
they are also unsupported by the
evidence
as we have noted both articles
are framed in the broadest generalities
and composed of multiple different
offenses
nothing contained in the judiciary
committee's majority report
or in the trial brief or in the
presentation of the managers can cure
the constitutional infirmity that effect
infects these articles
nonetheless in framing our defense they
provide
the only way through this uncharted
landscape
we have divided our substantive response
to the articles
into three parts
tomorrow mr craig
will address the art of charges in
article one
that the president committed perjury
before the grand jury
second ms mills
will address
those parts of article 2 that charge
the president with obstructing justice
by
causing the concealment of gifts he had
given to ms lewinsky
and that he engaged in witness tampering
in his conversations with miss curry
and third mr kendall
will address the remaining allegations
of obstruction
which will be on thursday
and then we will close by hearing from
senator bumpers
before i move to an overview of the
articles and the response you'll hear
over the next couple of days
i want to suggest to you an approach to
one of the most difficult questions
that you face
how does one sitting in judgment on a
case like this
assess the reliability of what he or she
hears and sees
let me offer one
test
those of you who have practiced on one
side or the other in the criminal
justice system
know that that system places a special
responsibility
on prosecutors
a burden to be open and candid and
forthcoming
in argument and most importantly in
representing the facts
so that when a prosecutor recites the
facts
he's not expected to ignore the
unfavorable ones
he's expected to be open with judge and
jury
of course he can make an argument
as to why a particular fact is really
not so important
but he can neither conceal it
nor misrepresent it
and so when you hear a prosecutor
or team of prosecutors
misstate a fact or not tell you the
whole story
you should wonder why
you should ask yourself whether the
misstatement was an inadvertent error
or whether it signals some underlying
flaw in the prosecution's case
some problem that they're trying to
conceal
and what ought to be particularly
skeptical
when the fact that is concealed or isn't
fully revealed
is claimed by the prosecutors themselves
to be crucial to their case
now we all sometimes speak with less
than complete care
and we are just criticized when we make
mistakes
if i tell you something inadvertently
that proves to be wrong
i expect to be held to account for that
and similarly we must hold the managers
accountable for their mistakes
last week for example you will recall
that mr manager sensenbrenner told you
that during my appearance before the
judiciary committee
in his words
charles ruff was asked directly
did the president lie
during his sworn grand jury testimony
and mr ruff could have answered that
question directly
he did not
and his failure to do so
speaks a thousand words
now just to be certain that the record
is straight
let me read to you from the transcript
of that judiciary committee hearing
representative sensenbrenner
the oath that witnesses take require
them to tell the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth and i seem to
recall that there were a lot of people
myself included when asked by the press
what advice we would give to the
president when he went into the grand
jury in august was to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
mr ruff indeed
representative sensenbrenner did he tell
the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth when he was in the grand jury
mr ruff
he surely did
i'm certain that mr sensenbrenner would
not intentionally mislead the senate
that his arrow is one of inadvertents
but in any event now the record is clear
of considerably more importance than
this momentary lapse are there many
substantive flaws
and that we will point out to you in the
coming days sometimes pure errors of
facts sometimes errors of interpretation
sometimes unfounded speculation
my colleagues will deal with many of
these flaws at greater length
as they discuss the specific charges
against the president
but i'll give you a couple of examples
as i reach the appropriate points in my
overview today
because i want you to have in mind
throughout our presentation
and indeed throughout the rest of these
proceedings this one principle
be wary
be wary
of the prosecutor who feels it necessary
to deceive the court
and begin with article one
our system of justice recognizes the
difficulties inherent
in testifying under oath and it affords
important protections
for the witness who may be charged with
perjury
and thus the judiciary committee's
dissatisfaction with the president's
answers because they thought they were
narrow or even hair splitting
in some sense
reflects a dissatisfaction with the
rules that have been applied for
centuries in prosecuting this offense
perjury requires proof that a defendant
knowingly made a false statement about a
material fact
the defendant must have had a subjective
intent
to lie
testimony that's provided as a result of
confusion or mistake or faulty memory or
carelessness or misunderstanding
is not perjury
the mere fact that the recollections of
two witnesses may differ
does not mean that one is committing
perjury
common sense and the stringent
requirements of the law dictate that war
is required
as the supreme court has noted
quote equally honest witnesses
may well have differing recollections of
the same event
and thus quote a conviction for perjury
ought not to rest entirely upon an oath
against an oath
this is the rationale for the common
practice of prosecutors to require
significant corroborating evidence
before they bring a perjury case indeed
the department of justice urges that its
prosecutors
seek independent corroboration either to
witnesses or corroborating evidence of
equality
to assure that a guilty verdict is
really well founded
now this isn't merely an argument we
make because we are advocates for the
president
a bipartisan panel of former federal
prosecutors about whom you will hear
more
testified that neither they nor any
reasonable prosecutor would charge
perjury based upon the facts in this
case
tom sullivan former u.s attorney for the
northern district of illinois
told the committee that the evidence set
out in the star report would not be
prosecuted
as a criminal case by a responsible
federal prosecutor
richard davis former colleague of mine
in the watergate special prosecution
force
testified that no prosecutor would bring
this case of perjury because the
president acknowledged to the grand jury
the existence of an improper
relationship and argued
with prosecutors questioning him
that his acknowledged conduct was not a
sexual relationship as he understood the
definition of that term
used in the jones deposition
and that
is where you need to begin your focus
as you look at the charge that the
president
perjured himself in the grand jury in
august of last year
any assessment of that testimony must
begin with one immutable fact
he admitted that he had in his words
inappropriate intimate contact with
monica lewinsky no one who is present
for that testimony has read the
transcript
watched the videotape could come away
believing anything other than that the
president
and ms lewinsky engaged in sexual
conduct
indeed even the prosecutors who surely
cannot be accused of being reluctant to
find presidential misconduct
contended not that the president had
lied about the nature of his
relationship
but only about
the details
yet the managers in their eagerness to
find misconduct where none had found it
before
have searched every nook and cranny of
the grand jury transcript and sent
forward to you a shopping list of
alleged misstatements
obviously in the hope that among them
you will find one with which you
disagree
but they hope in vain
the record simply will not support a
finding that the president
purged himself before the grand jury
now much of the questioning by the
prosecutors and much of the grand jury
testimony about which the house now
complains
so vociferously dealt with the
president's efforts to explain why his
answers in the jones deposition
certainly not pretty
were in his mind truthful albeit
narrowly and artfully constructed we are
not here to talk to you today
about the president's testimony in the
jones deposition we do seek to convince
you that
before the grand jury
the president was open
candid truthful
now the managers begin
by asking you to look at the prepared
statement that the president
offered at the very beginning
of his grand jury appearance
before the president actually began his
testimony his lawyer mr kendall
spoke to mr starr and told him that at
the first moment at which there was an
inquiry concerning the detailed nature
of the relationship with ms lewinsky he
wished to make a prepared statement and
he was permitted to do so
that statement acknowledged the
existence of an intimate relationship
but it did not discuss the specific
physical details
in what i think we will all understand
to have been an effort to preserve the
dignity of the office
now the house has charged that this
statement was somehow
a quote premeditated effort to thwart
the oic's investigation
that is apparent nonsense
even the independent council saw no such
dark motive in this statement
now first the managers advance the
baseless charge that the president
intentionally placed the beginning of
his relationship with ms lindsky
lewinsky in 1996 rather than 1995
as she has testified
interestingly they don't even purport to
offer any support for this charge other
than ms lewinsky's testimony and they
offer not even the somewhat odd
explanation originally offered by the
independent council to explain why the
president
having admitted the very worst things a
father and a husband can conceive of
admitting
would have shifted the time
by three months
next the managers
assert that the president's admission
that he engaged in wrongful conduct
quote on certain occasions
unquote was false because the president
actually engaged in such conduct some 11
times
and they assert as well that when the
president admitted he had occasional
telephone conversations that included
inappropriate discussions
that was false because they had actually
had 17 such phone conversations
now the president gave his best
recollection of the frequency of those
contacts
ms lewinsky gave hers
assuming that the majority is correct in
its assumption that there were 11 or 17
can anyone imagine a trial
in this court or in any other court
in which the issue of whether certain
occasions by definition could not mean
17
and occasionally could not refer to 11
would be the issue
being litigated
the independent council again
who could of course have pressed the
president for specific
numbers
had they thought it important
did not take issue with this testimony
so thus the perjury charge on article
one again comes down to the same
allegations contained in the independent
council's referral that the president
lied to the grand jury about two things
his subjective his personal subjective
understanding of the definition used in
the jones deposition
and
second
he lied when he denied that he engaged
in certain
details of inappropriate conduct
now to conclude that the president lied
to the grand jury about his relationship
with ms lewinsky you must determine
forgive me that he touched certain parts
of her body
but for proof you have only her oath
against his own
those among you who have been
prosecutors or criminal defense lawyers
know that perjury prosecutions as rare
as they are
would never be pursued on the evidence
available here
and those among you who do not bring
that special experience
at least bring
your common sense and are equally able
to assess
the weakness of the case that would rest
on such a foundation
common sense also is enough to tell you
that there cannot be any basis
for charging a witness with perjury on
the ground that you disbelieve his
testimony about his own subjective
belief in a definition of a term used in
a civil deposition
not only is there no evidence to support
such a charge here
it is difficult to contemplate what
evidence the managers might hope to rely
on to meet that burden
now it's worth noting that mr bennett
the time of the deposition
pressed the jones lawyers to ask the
president specific questions about his
conduct
rather than rely on this confusing
definition they proffered
in fact when the president was asked in
the grand jury whether he would have
answered those questions he said of
course if the judge had ruled them
appropriate he would have answered
truthfully
but jones lawyers
persisted in their somewhat strange
course
strange unless one asked whether
armed with ms tripp's intelligence they
purposely saw it in some fashion
to present the independent council a
record that would permit just the sort
of dark interpretation both he and the
managers have proffered
i point you to one thing if you seek
evidence
that the president took the definition
he was given seriously
and they responded carefully to the
questions put to him even if they
required the most embarrassing answers
one need only looked to the painful
admission
that he did have relations with another
woman
and he testified to the grand jury the
definition required that he make that
admission here's what he said to the
grand jurors
i read this carefully and i thought
about it and i thought about what
contact meant and i thought about
other phrases
my interpolation and i had to admit
under this definition
that i'd actually had
relations with jennifer flowers
now undeterred in its search for some
ground
on which to base the charge that the
president lied to the grand jury
article one abandons even the modest
level of specificity
found in the independent council's
referral and advances the claim quote
the president gave progeria's false and
misleading testimony regarding prior
statements of the same nature he made in
his deposition
there can be no stronger evidence
of the constitutional deficiency of this
article
and this strangely amorphous charge
and it's a deficiency that becomes even
more obvious
when you finally stumble across the
theory on which the managers rely
to the extent one can determine what the
judiciary committee had in mind when
drafted this clause
it appears that they intended to charge
the president with perjury before the
grand jury
because he testified that he believed
believed
that he had in his words quote work
through the minefield of the jones
deposition without violating the law
and that they hoped to support that
charge
by reference to various allegedly false
statements in his deposition as charged
in article two
unhappily for the managers however the
house rejected article two
and it is not before you in any form
moreover there is not a single
suggestion in the committee debate
or more importantly in the house debate
that those voting to impeach the
president believe that this one line
that i've quoted to you from the
president's grand jury testimony somehow
absorbed into article one
his entire deposition testimony
if there's to be any regard for
constitutional process the managers
cannot
be allowed to rely
on what the judiciary committee thought
were false statements encompassed in a
rejected article two
to flesh out the unconstitutionally
non-specific charges of article 1.
the house's vote on article 2 foreclosed
that option
for old time
now article one next alleges that the
president lied to the grand jury
about the events surrounding certain
statements made by mr bennett during the
jones deposition
specifically the matters to our
manager's charge that the president was
silent when mr bennett
characterized the lewinsky affidavit as
meaning
there is no sex of any kind in any
manner shape or form with president
clinton
and that the president then gave a false
explanation
to the grand jury when he testified that
he wasn't really paying attention
when his old lawyer said that
now as we noted earlier mr bennett
argued to judge wright that in light of
ms lewinsky's affidavit denying a
relationship the jones lawyers had no
good faith basis for questioning the
president about her
the president was not involved in the
lengthy back and forth among the judge
the jones lawyers and mr bennett
he said nothing when he was asked in the
grand jury about mr bennett's statement
he said
i'm not even sure i paid much attention
to what mr bennett was saying
now the managers assert that this is
false
because the videotape shows that the
president was in fact paying attention
but a fair review of the videotape i
suggest to you
shows a president looking indeed in mr
bennett's direction and in the direction
of the judge
but giving no sign that he was following
the discussion he did not his head he
didn't make facial expressions he had
nothing to reflect the awareness of the
substance of what was
happening much less what was said in mr
bennett's statement
i don't know how large a group this
would be but any of you who's ever
represented a witness or been a witness
in a deposition
will readily understand the president's
mindset
as the lawyers and the judge
debated these issues
and you will understand too
that to charge him with perjury for
having testified falsely about his own
state of mind
with nothing more to rely on than a
picture
with strain credulity in any
prosecutor's office
and flies past the bounds of
constitutional reason
in this chamber
i move now to the allegations in article
2
charging the president
with obstruction of justice in the jones
lawsuit and in the grand jury
investigation want to talk first about
what's become known as the concealment
of gifts theory
the allegation that the president
participated in some scheme to conceal
certain gifts he had given to ms
lewinsky centers on two events allegedly
occurring on december 28
1997.
first a conversation between the
president and ms lewinsky in the white
house in which the two discussed the
gifts
at least briefly that he had given to ms
lewinsky
and b
miss curry's picking up
a box of gifts from ms lewinsky and
storing them under her bed
the managers as was true of the majority
report and the independent council rule
before them
build their theory in this
case
not on any pillars of obstruction
but on shifting sand castles of
speculation
monica lewinsky met with the president
on december 28 1997 sometime shortly
before 8 am
to exchange christmas presents
to ms lewinsky they briefly discussed
the subject of gifts
she had received from the president in
connection with her received some days
earlier of a subpoena in the jones case
and this was the first and the only time
she says
in which the subject was ever discussed
and the managers quote one version of ms
lewinsky's description of that december
28th conversation
as follows
at some point i said to him well
you know should i
maybe i should put the gifts away
outside my house somewhere or give them
to someone maybe betty
and he sort of said
i think he responded i don't know or let
me think about that
and left that topic
but the senate should know that in fact
ms lewinsky has discussed this very
exchange
on at least 10 different occasions
and that the very most she alleges
in any of them
is that the president said i don't know
well let me think about it when she
raised the issue of the gifts
indeed in many of her versions
she said
among other things there really was no
response
that the president did not respond
that she didn't have a clear image in
her mind what to do next
she also testified
that ms curry's name did not come up
because
the president really didn't say anything
and most importantly in not a single one
of her
multiple versions of this event
did she say that the president ever
initiated any discussion about the gifts
nor did he ever suggest to her
that she concealed
now there being no evidence of
obstruction in that conversation the
managers would have you believe that
after ms lewinsky left the white house
that day the president must have told
betty curry to retrieve the gifts from
ms lewinsky
but there's absolutely no evidence
that that discussion ever occurred
the only two parties who would have
knowledge of it the president and ms
curry
both denied it ever took place
now in the absence of any such evidence
the managers
have relied on ms lewinsky's testimony
that ms curry placed a call to her and
told her depending on ms lewinsky's
version
either the president had said
to betty ms lewinsky had something for
her or merely that she missed curry
understood that ms lewinsky had
something for her
in this regard it's important to
remember that ms lewinsky herself
testified
that she was the one who first raised
with the president the notion uh
that ms curry could hold the gifts
and it's important to recognize that
contrary to the manager's suggestion to
you that ms lewinsky's memory of this
event has always been consistent and
unequivocal i think was their word
she herself acknowledged that her last
grand jury appearance that a memory of
the crucial conversation is less than
crystal clear
to whit
a juror
do you remember betty curry saying that
the president had told her to call
ms lewinsky
right now i don't remember
and now we come to the first example i
promised you of prosecutorial
what shall we call it fudge
starting from the premise that betty
curry called monica lewinsky
and told her that she understood
she had something for her and then went
to pick up
a sealed box containing some of the
gifts
she had received that ms lewinsky had
received from the president
first the independent council concluded
and then the majority report concluded
and now the managers have concluded that
the president must have instructed ms
curry to go pick up these gifts
to call ms lewinsky and make the
arrangements
so that they determined that when ms
curry said it was
ms lewinsky who called her
ms curry was mistaken
or
if you listen carefully maybe worse
and when the president testified
that he didn't tell ms curry to call ms
lewinsky he was
well just worse
and this surmise is made absolutely
certain
in the view of the managers because a
newly discovered unknown even to the
independent council cell phone record
shows that ms curry called ms lewinsky
at 3 32 2 p.m
on december 28th
and that must be the call that ms
lewinsky remembered
let's look now
at how the majority council
for the committee put it in his closing
argument to the judiciary committee
and i put his
words up on the chart
and you all should have it in front of
you as well
there is key evidence said majority
council
that ms curry's fuzzy recollection is
wrong
monica said that she thought betty
called her from cell phone
but look at this record show to you in a
moment
this is betty's cell phone record it
corroborates monica lewinsky and proves
conclusively that ms curry called monica
from her cell phone several hours after
she had left the white house
why did betty curry pick up the gifts
from ms lewinsky
the facts strongly suggest
the president directed her to do so
well there's a slight problem
with the majority council's epiphany
as it has been passed down
to the managers and then to you
before you see
and here is the cell phone record
it reflects
that at 3 32 pm on december 28th
from arlington virginia to washington
d.c that's ms lewinsky's number
there was
a call of a minute it says here
and then we have to ask
does this timing fit
with the rest of the testimony
well the answer is no it doesn't
because on three separate occasions
ms lewinsky testified
that ms curry came over to pick up the
gifts at two o'clock in the afternoon
an hour and a half before the phone call
now it's not as though we've been hiding
the ball on this senators
we discussed this issue at length
in our trial briefing
and the managers do seem to have
recognized at least some of the problem
because they have told you albeit
without the slightest evidentiary
support
that maybe ms lewinsky just
miscalculated a little bit
well maybe she just miscalculated a
little bit
three times
look at the record
fbi interview july 27th
lewinsky met curry on 28th street
outside lewinsky's apartment at about
2pm and gave curry the box of gifts
fbi interview august 1st
lewinsky gave the box to betty curry
when curry came by the watergate about
2pm
grand jury testimony three weeks later i
think it was around 2 p.m or so
around 2 in the afternoon
now the managers speculate
that if only the oh the independent
council had had this phone record
when they were interviewing ms lewinsky
they could have refreshed her
recollection
now having been one i can tell you
that's prosecutors speak for
if we'd only known about that darn
record we could have gotten her to
change her testimony
but the managers have one other problem
that they didn't address
the phone record if we can go back to
that for a moment
the phone record shows a call
lasting one minute
and all of us who have cell phones know
that that really means
it lasted well short of a minute
because the phone company rounds things
up to the nearest minute just to help us
all with our bookkeeping
so now it would be necessary not only
for ms lewinsky's memory to be refreshed
about the hour
of the pickup
but to explain
how the arrangements for it could have
been made between ms lewinsky and ms
curry
in somewhere between 1 and 60 seconds
now putting these factual difficulties
aside
this charge must fail for another reason
as you all know from
the presentations earlier the president
gave ms lewinsky
several gifts
on the very day that they met december
28th
faced with having to explain why on the
day
that the president and monica lewinsky
were conspiring to conceal gifts from
the jones lawyers
the president gave her additional ones
the manager surmised that
the real purpose
was because it was part of a subtle
effort to keep ms lewinsky on the team
but in truth the only reasonable
explanation for these events is the one
the president gave to the grand jury
he was simply not concerned about gibbs
he gave a lot he got a lot
and he saw no need to engage in any
effort to conceal them
the president did not urge ms lewinsky
to conceal the gifts he'd given her
and of course he did not lie to the
grand jury about that subject
the next point i want to discuss with
you is
the statements that the president made
to betty curry on the day after his
jones deposition
january 18th of last year
there's no dispute in the record no
conflict and testimony that the
president did meet with his secretary
betty curry on the day after the jones
deposition and he dis and they discussed
monica lewinsky
the managers cast
this conversation this recitation this
state series of statements and questions
put by the president to ms curry in the
most sinister light possible and allege
that the president attempted to
influence the testimony of a witness
quote witness unquote by pressuring ms
curry to agree with an inaccurate
version of the facts surrounding his
relationship with ms lewinsky
president clinton has adamantly denied
that he had any such intention
and that denial is fortified by the
undisputed factual record
establishing that betty curry neither
was an actual or a contemplated witness
in the jones litigation
nor did she perceive
that she was being pressured in any
respect by the president to agree
with what he was saying
first ms curry status is a witness
and the only proceeding the president
knew about at that moment the jones case
miss curry was neither an actual nor a
prospective witness
as to the only proceeding which he
ultimately became a witness
no one would suggest managers no one
else would suggest the president knew
that the independent council
was conducting an investigation into his
activities
in the entire history of the jones case
ms curry's name had not appeared on any
of the witness lists
nor was there any reason to suspect ms
curry would play any role in the jones
case
discovery was down to its final days
now the managers speculate that the
president's own references to ms curry
during his deputy deposition then she
was sure to be
called by the jones virus
yet in the days
weeks following the deposition
jones lawyers never
listed her never contacted her never
added to any witness list
they never deposed her they never
noticed her deposition
indeed when the independent council
interviewed the jones lawyers
they apparently
neglected
to ask
whether they'd ever intended
to call betty curry as a witness
and one can be sure that if such intent
existed
they would have asked
and it would have been included in the
referral
moreover it's a sure bet
that the jones lawyers already knew
about betty curry
and her relationship with monica
lewinsky
why because we know from her own
recorded telephone conversations that
miss tripp had been in contact with the
jones lawyers for months
and we know that she spent the evening
before the president's deposition
telling them everything she knew
it didn't take a few references to his
secretary by the president to trigger a
subpoena for betty curry if they'd ever
wanted to do that
and they never did
nor did the president ever pressure
ms curry to alter her recollection
despite the prosecutor's best efforts to
coax ms curry into saying she was
pressured to agree with the president ms
curry adamantly denied it
let me quote just briefly
a few lines of her grand jury testimony
question
now back again to the four statements
that you testified the president made to
you that were presented as statements
did you feel pressured when he told you
those statements
answer
none whatsoever
question
what was your impression that he wanted
to say because he would end each of the
statements was right with a question
answer
i do not remember what he wanted me that
he wanted me to say right
he would say right and i could have said
wrong
question
but he would end each of those questions
with a right and you could either say
whether it was true or not true
answer correct
question did you feel any pressure to
agree with your boss
answer
none
whatsoever
now to understand on a human level why
the president reached out for betty
curry on the day after his deposition
you need only to understand that he had
just faced unexpected detailed questions
about his worst nightmare
as he candidly admitted to the grand
jury he had long feared that his
relationship with ms lewinsky would
ultimately become public
and now with questioning about her in
the jones case
publication of the first internet
article
the day of reckoning had arrived
the president knew that a media storm
was about to erupt and it did
now if you're looking for
evidence
on which to base an inference
about the president's intentions
with respect to ms curry's testimony
look what he said to her
when he knew that she was
going before the grand jury
and i remember when i knew she was going
to have to testify on the grand jury
and i felt terrible because she'd been
through the loss of her sister this
horrible accident christmas that killed
her brother and her mother was in the
hospital
i was trying to make her understand that
i didn't want her to be untruthful to
the grand jury and if her memory was
different than mine it was fine
just go in there and tell them what she
thought
so that's all i remember
president united states did not tamper
with a witness
now
next
the managers argue
that
mr clinton
corruptly encouraged
ms lewinsky to submit a false affidavit
to the jones lawyers and to lie if she
were ever deposed
but the uncontroverted evidence refutes
that charge
indeed ms lewinsky herself has
repeatedly and forcefully denied that
anyone ever asked her to lie
there's no way to get around
that
flat denial
even
with the independent council's edition
of the word explicitly
there was no explicit implicit or any
other direction
to ms lewinsky to lie
indeed the only person to whom ms
lewinsky said anything inconsistent with
her denial
was the ubiquitous mistrip
and as mrs lewinsky later told the grand
jury
i think i told her that you know at
various times the president mr jordan
had told me i have to lie
that wasn't true
i left with this record the manners
resort to arguing that ms lewinsky
understood that the president wanted her
to lie because he could not have wanted
her to file an affidavit detailing their
relationship
but the only factual support for this
theory cited by the majority
is the testimony of ms lewinsky that
while the president never encouraged her
to lie he remained silent
about what she should have to say or do
and by such silence she said
i knew what he meant
the very idea that the president of the
united states
should face removal from office not
because
he told monica lewinsky to lie or
anything of the sort but because he was
silent
and ms lewinsky quote knew what that
meant unquote
is i suggest more than troubling
and so to bolster their flawed i knew
what he meant theory
the managers assert that the president
knew the affidavit would have to be
false in order for ms lewinsky to avoid
testifying but the evidence here too
is that the president repeatedly
testified
that ms lewinsky could and would file
a truthful affidavit
and of course
ms lewinsky herself has made it clear
that her definition of
the critical term
that might be used in such an affidavit
was consistent with the presidents
further testimony for ms lewinsky
herself repudiates any suggestion that
she was ever encouraged by anyone to lie
if she were deposed in the jones case
in a colloquy with a grand juror she
explicitly and unequivocally
rejected the notion that president
clinton encouraged her to deny the
relationship after she was learned she
was a witness
referring to discussions about the
so-called cover stories that the
managers allege were to be used in her
testimony a grand jury asked her
it is possible that you had these
discussions
after you learned that you were a
witness in the paula jones case answer
i don't believe so no
question can you exclude that
possibility
answer i pretty much can
now the managers would have you conclude
the contrary from a brief snippet of the
conversation on december 17th
in which ms lewinsky said that at some
point i don't know if it was before or
after the subject of the affidavit came
up the president sort of said
well you know you can always say you
were coming to see betty or that you
were bringing new letters
but ms lewinsky told the fbi when she
was interviewed
to the best
this is the fbi talking to the best of
ms lewinsky's memory she does not
believe they discussed in this december
17th conversation the content of any
deposition that ms lewinsky might be
involved in at a later date
and she told the grand jury the same
thing
describing the very same december 17th
conversation
she testified that she
and the president
did not discuss the idea of her denying
their relationship
ms lewinsky i really don't remember it i
mean it would be very surprising for me
to be confronted with something that
would show me different but i it was 2
30 and the i mean the conversation i'm
thinking of mainly would have been
december 17th which was the juror
interjects the telephone call was
lewinsky right and it was you know two 2
30 in the morning i remember the gist of
it and i really don't think so
and it is on that basis
that the managers suggest to you
that the president
obstructed justice
fourth
article two alleges that the president
obstructed justice
by denying to his closest aides that he
had a sexual relationship with monica
lewinsky the very same denial he made to
his family and his friends and the
american people
these allegedly impeachable denials
took place in the immediate aftermath
of the public revelation of the lewinsky
matter
at the very time that the president was
denying that relationship
to the entire country
on national television
having made the announcement to the
whole country
it is simply absurd i suggest to you to
believe that he was somehow attempting
corruptly to influence
his senior staff
when he told them virtually the same
thing at the same time
now the managers do not allege as they
could not
that the president attempted to
influence the aids testimony about what
they themselves knew
concerning his relationship with ms
lewinsky had they seen her in a
particular place had they talked to her
had they talked to the president about
before all of this broke
indeed the only evidence these aides had
was the very same denial
that the entire
american people had
indeed every member of the grand jury
had probably seen this denial by the
president on their own television
sets under the theory profit by the
managers in essence
every person who heard the president's
denial
could have been called to the grand jury
in order to create still an additional
charge of obstruction of justice
the point here was not that the
president
believed that his staff
would be witnesses
and that he somehow wanted to influence
their testimony
as he explained to the grand jury what
he was trying to do was avoid making
them witnesses but of course he had to
say something to him
he had to say in the aftermath of
january 21st something to reassure them
and he told them exactly what he told
every one of you and everyone in the
gallery and everyone who watched
television in those days
following january 21st
and let me just make this one point
there's absolutely no conflict in the
evidence here
despite the managers somewhat puzzling
suggestion that the senate's
deliberations would somehow be aided
if two of the senior staff members could
be called as witnesses
not only is there no conflict in the
evidence
there's absolutely no basis for the
charge that the president was in any way
seeking to influence the testimony of
his staff before the grand jury
and now we come to the last
of the obstruction charges
the managers ask you to find
that the president of the united states
employed his friend
vernon jordan
to get monica lewinsky a job in new york
to influence her testimony or
perhaps
in a somewhat
forlorn
effort to escape the reach of the
federal rules of civil procedure
actually to hide her from the jones
lawyers
in the 8 million people that live in
that city
there is of course absolutely no
evidence to support this conclusion and
so the managers have constructed out of
sealing wax and string and spiders webs
a theory that would lead
that would lend to a series of otherwise
innocuous in
indeed exculpatory events
of dark and sinister caste
the undisputed record establishes the
following
one
mrs lewinsky's new york job search began
on her own initiative
two the search began long before her
involvement in the jones case
three the search had no connection to
the jones case
four
vernon jordan agreed to help her not at
the direction of the president but at
the request of miss curry mr jordan's
longtime friend
and
five the idea to solicit mr jordan's
assistant
again came not from the president
but from his trip
as i thought about this particular
aspect of it i have to say i was sort of
reminded of the iago and desdemona's
handkerchief but we'll pass on
both ms lewinsky and mr jordan
have repeatedly testified that there was
never an agreement a suggestion and
implication
that ms lewinsky would be rewarded with
a job for her silence or her false
testimony
as mr jordan succinctly put it
quote
unequivocally
indubitable
no
it was only to appease
ms tripp
that ms lewinsky ultimately told her
that she had told mr jordan she wouldn't
sign the affidavit until she had a job
but as she told the grand jury quote
that was definitely a lie
based on something that linda had made
me promise
on january 9th
now although the manager's dismissed as
irrelevant ms lewinsky's job search
before december
the fact is that ms lewinsky had
contemplated looking for a job in new
york
as early as july 1997
and her interest was strengthened in
early october when ms tripp told her
that it was unlikely that she'd ever get
another job in the white house
it was then that ms tripp and ms
lewinsky discussed the prospect
of having vernon jordan help her get a
job in new york and ms lewinsky
mentioned that i did to the president
later in october
part of this ongoing search
u.n ambassador and ambassador richardson
agreed to interview ms lewinsky at the
suggestion of then deputy chief of staff
podesta
who had been asked to help by ms curry
and ambassador richardson offered her a
job and she had that job in hand
throughout the supposedly critical
december time frame
didn't actually turn it down
until early january
and further in late october early
november she actually went to her boss
at the pentagon and asked for his help
to find a job in new york
but meanwhile
and now we come to what for the managers
is the very heart of their case
on november 5th ms lewinsky had a
preliminary meeting with mr jordan
and they discussed a list of potential
employers
and all the managers then contend that
nothing happened
from november 5th that first meeting
until december 11
signifying as they see it
that it must have been ms lewinsky's
appearance on the witness list
that galvanized mr jordan into action
that's simply false
ms lewinsky had a follow-up telephone
conversation with mr jordan around
thanksgiving in which he told her he was
working on the job search
and asked her to call him in the first
week of december
you'll remember that the president
learned that ms lewinsky was on the
jones witness list
sometime on december 6th
he met with mr jordan the very next day
december 7th
but oddly
if one adopts the manager's view
there was no discussion of ms lewinsky
or the jones case
much less job searches
and then on december 8th
ms lewinsky called mr jordan's office
and made an appointment to meet with him
on december 11th
now the president had absolutely nothing
to do with that call or that appointment
and mr jordan denied that there was any
intensified effort to find ms lewinsky a
job
he said oh no
i do not recall any heightened sense of
urgency in december what i do recall is
that i dealt with it
when i had time to do it
and now for my second example
of prosecutorial fudge making
the managers have devoted much attention
to the magic date of december 11th
arguing vigorously that it was on that
day
that getting a job for ms lewinsky
suddenly became
a matter of high priority for the
president and hence for mr jordan
why is that so
well again i'll let the majority counsel
for the judiciary committee tell you in
his own words
during his closing argument
and again you should have this before
you if you can't see the chart
but why the sudden interest
why the total change in focus and effort
nobody but betty curry really cared
about helping ms lewinsky throughout
november even after the president
learned that her name was on the
prospective witness list
did something happen to move the job
search from a low to a high priority on
that day
oh yes something happened
on the morning of december 11
1997
judge susan weber wright ordered that
paula jones was entitled to information
regarding any state or federal employee
with whom the president had sexual
relations or proposed or sought to have
sexual relations
to keep monica on the team
was now of critical importance
remember they already knew that she was
on the witness list although nobody
bothered to tell her
and that same thing
was picked up last week by mr manager
hutchinson
both in his recitation of the events of
that day
and in the exhibits he showed you
if i'm
lucky we will
put up on the easel to my right
the exhibit
that manager hutchinson used
you'll see the order
that this exhibit places
for on the critical
events
of november and december the november
5th meeting
the november no job search action
president receives the witness list and
then
of special interest
december 11th first event
judge wright's order permitting
questions
about lewinsky
2
on december 11 the president and jordan
talk about a job for monica
and now
let me ask you to focus
on what mr hutchinson told you about the
events of december 11th
sounding somewhat like majority council
he asks and so what triggered
let's look at the chain of events
the judge the witness list came in the
judge's order came in that triggered the
president into action and the president
triggered vernon jordan into action and
that chain reaction here is what moved
the job search along
remember what else happened on that day
december 11th again
that was the same day the judge wright
ruled that the questions about other
relationships could be asked by the
jones attorneys
now it appears to me that the managers
are suggesting
again with not a great deal of subtlety
that vernon jordan one of this country's
great lawyers and great citizens
was prepared to perjure himself to save
the president
so let's just imagine
the manager's examination of mr jordan
in this chamber
that would let you make your own
judgment about his truthfulness
question
mr jordan isn't it a fact that you met
with ms lewinsky on december 11th to
help get her a job
answer yes
question and isn't it a fact that before
and after you met with her you made
calls to potential employers in new york
yes
and isn't it true that the reason for
all this activity on december 11th
was that judge wright had on that very
day
issued an order authorizing the jones
lawyers to depose certain women like ms
lewinsky
no
question
what do you mean no
isn't it true that the judge had issued
her order before you met with ms
lewinsky and before you made the calls
answer
i had no knowledge of any such order
the fact that ms lewinsky was a
potential witness had nothing to do with
my helping her
i'd made an appointment to see her three
days earlier
question
well
isn't it a fact that judge wright filed
her order on december 11th before you
met with ms lewinsky
well actually no
let me show you the official report of
the judge's discussion with the lawyers
in the jones case on that date
and you have this before you as well
a conference call
between the judge
and the lawyers
which is memorialized in a
formal document prepared by her clerk
and
on file in the case
in arkansas
notes that the conference call began
at 5 33
pm
central standard time
if i have my calculations right that's 6
33 pm
in washington
now i want to stop here for just a
second
so you know where mr jordan was when
that happened can we see the next chart
by the way i was
this is mr jordan testifying again
i was actually on a plane
for amsterdam
by the time the judge issued
her order
so he testified in the grand jury i left
on united flight 946 at 5 55 from dulles
airport and landed amnesty the next
morning
we go back mike to the
previous one
so the conference call begins
at 6 33 eastern standard time
the court takes up another a variety of
matters
and the judge
didn't even tell
the lawyers
that she was going to issue an order
on their motion to compel these various
depositions
until the very end of the call
around 7 45
eastern standard time and that the clerk
would actually fax them
a copy
at that point
and so to return to mr jordan's
mythical testimony
and so to summarize
let me show you something that tells you
what the real sequence of events was on
december 11.
vernon jordan
makes a
possible job call at 9 45
another at 12 49
another at 107. he meets with ms
lewinsky from 115 to 145.
he gets on his plane at 5 55 in the
afternoon
and
an hour or so later
the lawyers are informed
that the judge had issued her order
in fact just as a little
phillip
president's out of town
and returns to washington
on 110 at 1 10 a.m
and actually judge wright's order is
filed not on the 11th but on the 12th
question
oh i see
well never mind
now do you think
does any of you think
that you need to look mr jordan in the
eye
and hear his tone of voice
to understand that the prosecutors have
got it wrong
and have had at least since the majority
council's closing argument
now you will also learn from us but not
from the managers
that mr jordan placed no pressure on any
company to give ms lewinsky a job
indeed two of the companies he called
didn't even offer her a job
and just as the manners dramatic
managers dramatically misstate the
record relating to mr jordan's efforts
to help ms lewinsky find a job so too do
they invent a non-existent link between
the call mr jordan made ultimately to mr
perlman the ceo of mcandrews and forbes
revlon's parent
and the offer ms lewinsky finally
received from revline with her signing
of the affidavit in the jones case
we will demonstrate
beyond any question
once again
the conclusions the managers have drawn
are simply false
begin with the fact that both mr jordan
and mr lewinsky have testified that
there was no such link between between
the job
and the affidavit
and the only person to ever suggest such
a link
was once again
his trip
now i presume
that it is not the manager's intention
to suggest that we bring this trip
before you
to explore her motivations for making
that suggestion
next take ms lewinsky's interview with
the mcandrews
official
which she described as having gone
poorly
a characterization adopted by the
managers for obvious reasons because it
suggests that there was a desire on
their part
to heighten the supposed relevance of
the call that mr jordan made to mr
pearlman
in other words under their theory
ms lewinsky's job prospects of mcandrews
and forbes
where revlon were kaput
until vernon jordan
made the call and resurrected
her chances
unfortunately like so much of the
obstruction case
the facts do not bear this can out this
convenient theory
in fact the man who interviewed ms
lewinsky at mcandrews was impressed with
her
because there was nothing available in
his area
sent her resume to revlon
where she was hired
by someone who did not know
about mr jordan's call to mr perlman
so much for obstruction by judge job
search
that then is an overview
of the charges contained in these
articles
you'll hear about them in greater detail
than i could offer you today
and my colleagues
speak in the next
two days
but i want to bring
my presentation to you to a close
we are not here to defend
william clinton the man
he like all of us
will find his judges elsewhere
we are here to defend william clinton
the president of the united states
for whom you are the only judges
you are free to criticize him to find
his personal conduct distasteful but ask
whether this is the moment when for the
first time in our history
the actions of a president have so put
at risk
the government the framers created that
there is only one solution
you must find not merely that removal is
an acceptable
option
that we will be okay
the day after you vote
you must find that it's the only
solution that our democracy should not
be
made to sustain two more years of this
president's service
you must put that question because the
one thing that our form of government
cannot abide
is the notion that impeachment
is merely one more
weapon
the congress can use
in the contest between the legislative
and executive branches
let me be very clear we do not believe
that president clinton
committed any of the offenses
charged by the managers
and for the reasons we'll set out at
length over the next two days we believe
the managers have misstated the record
have constructed their case out of
tenuous extrapolations without
foundation
have at every turn assumed the worst
without the evidence to support their
speculations
you put these lawyers
in a courtroom and they win 10 times out
of 10.
but suppose we are wrong
suppose that you find
that the president committed one or more
of the offenses
that the managers are charged
then there remains only one issue before
you
whatever your feelings may be about
william clinton
the man
or william clinton the political ally or
opponent
or william clinton the father and the
husband
ask only this should william clinton the
president
be removed from office
are we at that horrific moment
in our history
when our union can be preserved only by
taking the step
that the framers saw as a last resort
now i'm never certain how to respond
want an advocate on the other side of a
case
calls up images of patriots
over the centuries who sacrificed
themselves
to preserve our democracy
i have no personal experience with war
i've only visited normandy as a tourist
but i do know this
my father was on omaha beach 55 years
and i know how he would feel
if he were today
he didn't fight no one fought
for one side of this case or the other
he fought as all those did
for our country
our constitution
and as long as each of us
manager
president's council
senator
does his or her constitutional duty
they those who fought for their country
will be proud
we the people of the united states
have formed a more perfect union
we've formed it we nurture it
we've seen it grow
we have not been perfect
and it is perhaps the most extraordinary
thing about our constitution
that it thrives despite our human
imperfections
when the american people hear the
president talk to congress tonight
they will know the answer to the
question
neighbor house stands the union
it stands strong
vibrant
free
and i closed as i opened two hours ago
two and a half hours ago
william jefferson clinton is not guilty
of the charges that have been brought
against him he didn't commit perjury he
didn't obstruct justice
he must not
be removed from office
thank you
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice in a moment the senate
will recess until 8 35 pm this evening
at which time the senate will proceed as
a body over to the house of
representatives for a joint session to
receive a message from the president
following the joint session uh the
senate will adjourn until 11 a.m
tomorrow morning as a reminder to all
senators the leaders lecture series is
scheduled for tomorrow evening at 6 pm
in the old senate chamber with former
president george bush as the guest
speaker i now ask the senate stand in
recess under the previous order in the
absence of objection it's so ordered
the fourth day of the impeachment trial
of the president of the united states
now complete the first day of the
president's defense white house counsel
charles ruff speaking to senators for
about two and a half hours with a short
break earlier as we mentioned before we
will again take this opportunity to open
our phone lines for your thoughts on
what you've seen these past few days but
also today with the white house council
having its first day to make arguments
in defense of the president the
grand jury testimony he lied and he lied
about that we got to remember that he
shouldn't have rights thanks wichita of
impeachment
uh the centers may be seated the deputy
sergeant-arms will make the proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states
the majority leader is recognized
mr chief justice it's my understanding
that the white house council
presentation today will last until
sometime between five and six o'clock
uh i've been informed that mr greg craig
and ms sheryl mills will be making
today's presentations
as we've done over the past week we'll
take a couple of short breaks during the
proceedings
i'm not exactly how we'll do that we'll
just sort of keep an eye on everybody
the chief justice and and the council
but i assume after about an hour hour
and 15 minutes we'd probably take a
break and then we would take another one
in the afternoon uh
at some point so we'd have an
opportunity to stretch and take a break
i remind all senators again if they
would remain standing to death each time
the chief justice enters and departs the
chamber also as a further reminder on a
different subject the leader of lecture
series continues tonight will be held at
6 00 p.m in the old senate chamber
former president george bush will be our
guest speaker i thank my colleagues for
their attention heal the floor i
understand mr chief justice that uh
council greg craig is going to be the
first presenter
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings as to the trial are approved
to date pursuant to the reserve
provisions of senate resolution 16 the
council for the president have 21 hours
and 45 minutes remaining to make the
presentation of their case the senate
will now hear you the chair recognizes
mr council craig
[Music]
mr chief justice ladies and gentlemen of
the senate
distinguished managers from the house
good afternoon
my name is greg craig and i'm special
counsel to the president i'm here today
on behalf of president clinton
i'm here to argue that he is not guilty
of the allegations of grand jury perjury
set forth
in article one
i welcome this opportunity to speak for
president clinton he has a strong and a
compelling case
one that is based on the facts
in the record on the law
and on the constitution
but first and foremost
the president's defense is based on the
grand jury transcript itself
i urge you to read that transcript
watch the videotape
you will see this president make painful
difficult admissions
beginning with his acknowledgment of an
improper
and wrongful relationship with monica
lewinsky
you will see that the president was
truthful
and after reading seeing hearing and
studying the evidence for yourself
not relying on what someone else says it
is
not relying on someone else's
description
characterization or paraphrase of the
president's testimony
we believe that you will conclude that
what the president did and said in the
grand jury
was not unlawful
and that you must not remove him from
office
i plan to divide my presentation into
three parts first
to tell you how really bad this article
is legally structurally and
constitutionally
and to argue that it falls well below
the most basic minimal standards and
should not be used to impeach and remove
this president or any president from
office
second
to address the various allegations
directly and third
to give you a few larger thoughts in
response to some of the arguments from
last week
at the conclusion
you will have had much more than 100
percent
of your minimum daily requirements for
lawyering
for which i apologize
article 1 accuses the president of
having given quote for jurious false and
misleading testimony to the grand jury
concerning one or more of four different
subject areas
first
when he testified about the nature and
details of his relationship with ms
lewinsky
second
when he testified about his testimony in
the jones deposition
third when he testified about what
happened during the jones deposition
when the president's lawyer
robert bennett made certain
representations about monica lewinsky's
affidavit
and fourth
when he testified about alleged efforts
to influence the testimony of witnesses
and impede the discovery of evidence
it is noteworthy that the second and
third subject areas are attempts to
revisit the president's deposition
testimony in the jones case
there was an article that was proposed
alleging that the president also
committed perjury in the jones case in
the jones deposition
that article was rejected
by the house of representatives and
there were very many good reasons
for the house to take that action
those allegations have been dismissed
and you must not allow the managers to
revive them
last week they tried to do that
the managers mixed up and merged two
sets of issues
allegations of perjury in the grand jury
and allegations of perjury in the jones
case
these are very different matters
and i think the result was confusing and
also unfair to the president
you will notice that the third and the
fourth subject areas correspond to
coincide and overlap with many of the
allegations of obstruction of justice in
article two
this represents a kind of double
charging that you might be familiar with
if you've either been a prosecutor or a
defense lawyer
once the defendant is charged for the
core offense
secondly the defendant is charged for
denying the core offense under oath this
gives the managers two bites at the
apple
and it's a dubious prosecutorial
practice that is frowned upon by most
courts
the upshot though is this with respect
to subparts three and four
of this first article
if you conclude as i trust you will that
the evidence that the president engaged
in obstruction of justice is
insufficient to support that charge
it would follow logically that the
president's denial
that he engaged in any such activity
would be respected and he would be
acquitted on the perjury charge
simply put if the president didn't
obstruct justice
he didn't commit perjury when he denied
it
but the most striking thing about
article 1
is what it does not say
it alleges perjury generally
but it does not allege a single
persuasive statement specifically
the majority drafted the article this
way despite pleas from other members of
the committee and from
council for the president
that the article take care to be precise
when it makes its allegations
such specificity as many of you know is
the standard practice of federal
prosecutors all across america
and that is the practice recommended by
the department of justice
in the manual distributed to united
states attorneys
who enforce the criminal code in federal
courts throughout the nation
take a look at the standard form it's
exhibit five in the collection that
we've handed you this is given to
federal prosecutors
this is the model that they are used
that they are told to use to allege
perjury in a criminal indictment in
federal court
now there's a very simple reason why
prosecutors identify the specific
quotation that is alleged to be perjury
and why it is included in a perjury
indictment
if they don't quote the specific
statement that's alleged to be progerias
courts will dismiss the indictment
concluding that the charge of perjury is
too vague and the defendant is not able
to determine what precisely he is being
charged with
the requirement that a defendant be
given adequate notice of what he is
charged with
carries constitutional dimensions and
the failure to provide that notice
violates due process of law
this is something that applies to all
criminal offenses when they're charged
and you can understand why that kind of
notice is required imagine a robbery
indictment that failed to indicate who
or what was robbed
and what property was stolen how could
you possibly defend against the charge
that you just stole something but you
don't know what it is
and it's nothing specific imagine a
murder indictment without identifying a
victim
but this requirement is even more
stringent for perjury prosecutions
descriptions paraphrases
summaries of testimony that has alleged
to be perjurious are not accepted the
quotation must be there or it's the
definition should be so close that there
can be no doubt as to what is intended
in the past when the house has returned
articles of impeachment alleging perjury
with respect to federal judge you will
see that the house has followed this
practice
and if you go back through american
history and review the articles that
have alleged perjury and that have been
approved by the house and the senate you
will find that the statements that are
alleged to be pejorias are specifically
identified in the articles let me read
from article one from the resolution of
impeachment against judge walter nixon
quote the the false or misleading
statement was in substance
that the forest county district attorney
never discussed
this case with judge nixon unquote
there's no doubt about that that's very
clear from the alastie hastings articles
of impeach impeachment the false
statement was in substance that judge
hastings and william borders never made
any agreement to solicit a bribe from
defendants in united states versus
romano
a case tried before judge hastings why
is it that in this case
surely the most serious perjury trial in
american history
the house decided that specific
allegations just aren't necessary
now the failure of the house to be
specific in his charges of perjury
has in fact violated the president's
right to due process and fundamental
fairness and as you will see as i go
through the procedural history of these
allegations
it put us and the president at a
significant disadvantage as we tried to
respond to the allegations that now are
set forth in this article but there's
yet another reason
why this vagueness and lack of
specificity is so very dangerous
and it raises a constitutional question
that i think only this body can resolve
article 1 section 2 clause 5 of the
constitution
states
quote the house of representatives shall
have the sole power of impeachment
the sole power of impeachment
by failing to be specific in this
article as to what it is precisely that
the president said
that should cause him to be removed from
office
has the house effectively and
unconstitutionally
ceded its authority under this precision
provision of the constitution
to the managers
who are not authorized to exercise that
authority
by bringing general charges in this
article
the house judiciary committee
and then the house of representatives
generally
gave enormous discretion
power and authority
to the floor managers and their lawyers
to decide what precisely
the president was going to be charged
with
they didn't have that authority under
the constitution
only the house of representatives has
that authority
they have been allowed to pick and to
choose
what allegations will be leveled against
the president of the united states
it would be extremely dangerous to the
integrity of the process for the house
to level such general charges
against the president
creating empty vessels to use mr russ
term to be filled by lawyers and floor
managers
and this argument i think will take on
more importance
as we take a closer look at the charges
themselves
and we see what kind of which is brew to
use mr ruff again
what kind of content was poured into
these vessels and find out where they
came from and why and when
i'd like to talk about
how these charges have been a moving
target for us throughout this entire
process
on september 9th when kenneth starr
submitted his referral
to the house of representatives he
claimed that there was substantial and
credible information to suggest that the
president committed perjury
and the grand jury on three separate
occasions
to his credit the star referral was
moderately specific we could understand
what they were talking about in those
allegations on october 5th
when house majority council david
shippers first made his presentation to
the house judiciary committee
he discarded two of mr starr's theories
and invented a new one of his own and he
included only two counts in his
presentation alleging perjury in the
grand jury
those two counts were unbelievably broad
and included no specifics whatsoever
on november 19th
mr starr appeared before the house
judiciary committee
and gave a two-hour opening statement in
that statement
he delivered one or two sentences on the
subject of grand jury perjury
then on december 9th when the committee
majority released its four proposed
articles
of impeachment the article that alleged
perjury in the grand jury which is the
one we have before us today
failed to tell us or the american people
what words the president actually used
that should cause the congress to remove
him from office
as you know these proposed articles were
released
just as mr ruff and the president's
defense was being completed
in fact it may have been two or three
minutes before he completed his final
argument before the committee so we had
no advance notice and no chance to
discuss these articles to respond to
them
or in any way to react
in truth
i must say that because of the vagueness
of the articles that were ultimately
returned had we be given such advance
notice it wouldn't have made much
difference because simply put there is a
stunning lack of specificity in article
one
so where do we look for guidance how do
we know what to defend against in this
case
after the judiciary committee had
completed its deliberations
after the members had voted to send
four articles of impeachment to the full
house
the majority issued its report on
december 16th
only three days before the house took
its final vote
it was never debated by let alone
approved by the house of representatives
and thus this report has no formal
standing in these proceedings
but until the managers filed their trial
brief and made their presentations just
last week
the majority report written by mr
shippers and his staff was our only
place to go to look for guidance as to
what those four subparts of this first
article really meant
now when it comes to perjury before the
grand jury the majority report argued
that the president
had not made two
not three but a whole host of progeria
statements before the grand jury
some statements that were not contained
in the star referral and had never been
identified charged discussed or debated
by the members during the impeachment
inquiry
for example
the majority report alleged that the
prepared statement that the president
made and delivered to the grand jury at
the start of his testimony admitting his
relationship with ms lewinsky was
perjurious false and misleading
an astonishing allegation that went far
beyond anything that kenneth starr had
ever claimed
and a claim that no member of the
judiciary committee had ever made in the
course of the committee's deliberations
obviously we had no opportunity
whatsoever to respond to this allegation
before the committee or before the house
the allegation was never debated or
discussed by members of the committee
nor was it discussed during the debate
on the floor of the house
the majority report also alleged that
the president committed perjury in the
grand jury when he testified that
his goal in the jones deposition was to
be truthful
and when he said that
he believed that he had managed to
complete his testimony in that
deposition
quote without violating the law
again this allegation was brand new to
us never before made by star not
included in shippers closing argument
never mentioned by chairman hyde or by
anyone else in the committee never
addressed by the president's council
never debated by members of the
committee never discussed on the floor
the majority port
made many other new allegations of the
same kind and pedigree all new
undiscussed untested
they had not come
ladies and gentlemen of the senate these
allegations did not come from starr's
referral
nor did they come from any evidence that
had been gathered
in the course of the impeachment inquiry
nor had they ever been unveiled during
the impeachment inquiry to allow the
president's council to respond or the
members of the judiciary committee to
debate them
to our knowledge many of these
allegations were never discussed or
debated by the members of the committee
and if you read the closing arguments of
the members of the house judiciary
judiciary committee
you will search in vain for any specific
reference to many of these new
allegations which are the subject of
article one
then we found ourselves in the senate
our only guide being the articles
themselves which as you know are general
and the majority report
which has no formal standing in which
was filled with allegations and theories
that had never been discussed much less
adopted
as the trial in the senate began
just three days before the managers were
scheduled to open their case on january
11th
the house managers filed their trial
brief
we discovered that the allegations of
grand jury perjury against the president
were still changing still expanding
still increasing in number
the trial brief made eight proffers
incredibly presented quote merely as
examples
that still in very general terms
described instances when the president
allegedly provided for
jurious false and misleading testimony
to the grand jury
but we were warned these proffers were
only salient examples of grand jury
perjury
the house manager said quote
the examples set forth in the trial
brief are merely highlights of the grand
jury perjury there are numerous
additional examples
and when we heard mr manager rogan's
presentation we realized that the trial
brief was absolutely right
mr rogen unveiled
allegations that had not been included
even in the trial brief
the uncertainty the fluidity
the vagueness of the charges in this
case and the unwillingness of the
prosecutors ever to be specified to ever
to specify and be bound
by the statements
that are at issue
has been an aspect of this process that
i submit has been profoundly unfair to
this president
and is also unconstitutional for the
arguments that i gave to you
the articles have come to include
specific allegations of grand jury
perjury that did not come from the star
referral
and that never would have been approved
by the house had the house been required
to review them
there is one other element of unfairness
that mr ruff referred to
even as the house managers have
consistently tried to stretch the scope
of article one to cover allegations
never considered
by the house they have tried to twist
the scope of article one to cover
allegations specifically rejected by the
house now let me be clear here i am not
charging the managers with going beyond
the record
of the case
these new allegations come from the
record in the case
uh they're not beyond the record they're
in the record but the star referral did
not
find it uh suitable to make these
allegations and they were not made in a
timely way before the house judiciary
committee and i would submit in a timely
way before the house of representatives
when the house i go back to this second
element of unfairness that has to do
with the jones article
when that jones article was rejected we
would argue that that rejection
should have been recognized for what it
was
a clear instruction from the house of
representatives
not to argue that the president should
be impeached and removed because of his
testimony in the jones deposition
but the managers have sought to merge
the jones testimony with the grand jury
testimony
to confuse these two events to blend and
blur them together
the senate must understand that these
two events were different in every way
in the president's testimony in the
jones case the president was evasive
misleading
incomplete in his answers
and as i said to the house judiciary
committee
maddening
but
in the federal grand jury
president clinton was forthright
and forthcoming he told the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
for four long hours
and the american people saw that
testimony
and they know that president clinton
when he appeared before the grand jury
did not deny a sexual relationship with
miss lewinsky he admitted to one
they know that he did not deny that he
was alone with ms lewinsky he repeatedly
acknowledged that he had been alone with
her on many occasions
the managers argued that the jones
testimony is relevant because they say
the president perjured himself
when he told the grand jury
that his testimony in the jones case was
truthful
and it wasn't say the managers
that characterization of the president's
testimony they say is simply not
accurate
what he said was
my goal in this deposition was to be
truthful but not particularly helpful
i was determined
to walk through the minefield of this
deposition with without violating the
law
and i believe i did these are opinions
he's characterizing his state of mind
the house manager on the basis of this
testimony must not be allowed to do
what the house of representatives told
them they could not do
which is to argue
about the president's testimony
in the jones case even if you believe
that the president crossed the line in
his jones deposition
you cannot conclude that he should be
removed for it
he was not impeached for it
this case is about the grand jury and
the grand jury alone
now in fact the vagueness and
uncertainty as to the specific
allegations of perjury
whether in the grand jury or in the
paula jones deposition
have created enormous confusion in the
public
about the president's conduct and about
his testimony
this confusion i think has done enormous
damage to the president
because out of this confusion has
emerged a wholly inaccurate conventional
wisdom
about what president clinton said when
he testified in the grand jury
and that conventional wisdom is based on
certain common
mischaracterizations of the president's
testimony
last december 8th i gave an opening
statement in the president's defense
before the committee and when it came
time for me to talk about the charges of
perjury
i urged the members of the committee to
open their minds
and because of widespread misinformation
about the facts
to focus on the record
i make the same plea to you again today
keep an open mind and look at the real
record read the transcript watch the
videotape do not rely upon anyone else's
version
we speak from some disappointing
experience on this issue
over and over again
inaccurate descriptions of the
president's grand jury testimony have
been launched into the public debate
sometimes innocently sometimes
negligently
but the result has been the same
the president's critics have created a
conventional wisdom about the
president's grand jury that is based on
myth not reality
there has been a merging
of the president's testimony in the
jones deposition
with that of his testimony
in the grand jury and this dynamic has
been unfair to the president we're at
number six
with the exhibits
let me just cite a few examples there
are many more available
but they're from people and sources
that are familiar with the case and
close to the evidence
and some coming from the presentations
of just last week
at the conclusion of the impa the
impeachment inquiry conducted by the
judiciary committee the final arguments
before the votes were taken in front of
the committee
congressman mccollum stated quote the
president gave sworn testimony in the
jones case in which he swore he could
not recall being alone with monica
lewinsky and that he had not had sexual
relations with her
he repeated those assertions a few
months later to the grand jury and the
evidence shows he lied about both
that is not an accurate characterization
of the president's testimony in front of
the grand jury
in the majority report written by
majority council the author stated
repeatedly
that president clinton testified before
the grand jury that he did not have
sexual relations with ms lewinsky
members of the senate those descriptions
of the president's grand jury testimony
are absolutely false when he appeared
before the grand jury the president
admitted he did not deny an
inappropriate
intimate
wrongful personal relationship with miss
lewinsky
when he made this admission there was no
doubt in any anyone's mind what he meant
it meant and the whole world knew that
it meant that the president of the
united states had engaged in some form
of sexual activity or sexual contact
with miss lewinsky in his appearance on
a national news program on cnn
television this is another example
over the new year's weekend
mr manager graham was asked for the most
glaring example
of the president's alleged perjury
before the grand jury and he said quote
i think when the president said he
wasn't alone with her he lied unquote
that characterization of the president's
grand jury grand jury testimony is not
true
there can be absolutely no doubt that
during his grand jury testimony the
president acknowledged he did not deny
he repeatedly acknowledged that he had
been on certain occasions alone with ms
lewinsky
he acknowledged that fact in the opening
sentence of his prepared statement to
the grand jury let me read it
let me read you the first words in the
president's opening statement of the
grand jury quote
when i was alone with ms lewinsky on
certain occasions in early 1996 and once
in early 1997
i engaged in conduct that was wrong
when i was alone with ms lewinsky
that is what the president of the united
states said
that is what the transcript says
and no amount of eloquence or lawyerly
skill from the managers can change that
fact
facts are stubborn
he also
engaged in a lengthy colloquy
with the prosecutors about how many
times he had thought he had been alone
with miss lewinsky and there can be no
doubt in anyone's mind
that he answered that he had been alone
with ms lewinsky on frequent occasions
he was asked and he answered and he said
yes and he made clear what he meant he
went on to say
i did what people do when they do the
wrong thing
i treated i tried to do it where nobody
else was looking at it
i'd have to be an exhibitionist not to
have tried to exclude everyone else
these are not the words of someone who
is trying
to hide the fact of his relationship
with ms lewinsky
and it is difficult to understand how
reading these words as well as the long
and detailed testimony
in front of the grand jury how one could
think or contend
that the president repeated or ratified
his deposition testimony before the
grand jury about not ever being alone
in the manager's trial brief issued just
three days before they made their
presentation to the senate the brief
makes the following statement this is a
mischaracterization number four
the president falsely testified
that he answered questions truthfully at
his deposition concerning
among other subjects
whether he had been alone with ms
lewinsky
members of the senate as i just outlined
in connection with manager graham's
statement this characterization of the
president's grand jury testimony is
misleading
the lawyers for the office of the
independent council asked many questions
and ex engaged in extensive colloquy
with the president about being along
with ms lewinsky but they never asked
him to explain affirm defend or justify
his testimony about that same topic in
the jones deposition
and he did not do so
members of the senate if justice is to
be done these misstatements and
mischaracterizations
must not be allowed to stand and must
not be allowed to influence your
judgment
as you look at the evidence so please
look at the real record
it is the record of the president's
testimony
not the jones deposition
his testimony before the grand jury that
should be the senate's sole concern
now
it's timely i think to talk a little bit
about legalisms and technicalities and
hair splitting
because those who have engaged in this
process over the past months in this
enterprise of defending the president
have also been the subject of much
criticism
the majority council accused us of
quote legal hair splitting prevarication
and assembling
and urged the members of the senate and
the house to pay no attention
to the obfuscations and legalistic
pyrotechnics of the president's
defenders
and during his presentation just last
week on january 15th
congressman mccollum implored you not to
get hung up on some of the absurd and
contorted explanations of the president
and his attorneys
to the extent that we have relied on
overly legal
or technical arguments
to the ted to defend the president from
his attackers
we apologize to him
to you and to the american public
we do the president no earthly good
if in the course of defending him
we offend both the judges the jurors and
the american public
and mr ruff had it just right
when he expressed his concern to the
members of the judiciary committee
that our irresistible urge to practice
our profession
should not get in the way
of securing a just result
in this very grave proceeding
for this very special client
but
when an individual
any individual
is accused of committing a crime such as
perjury
the prosecutors must be put to their
full proof
every element of the crime must be
proven
and if a criminal standard is going to
be used here it must be proven beyond a
reasonable doubt
now the managers have taken it upon
themselves
directly and aggressively to accuse this
president of criminal activity
they say that this criminal activity as
at the very heart
of the effort to remove him from office
as congressman mccollum said to you last
week
the first thing you have to determine is
whether or not the president committed
crimes
if he didn't obstruct justice or witness
temper
or commit perjury
no one believes no one believes he
should be removed from office
allegations of legal crimes invite
indeed they call out for legal defenses
and you will not be surprised to learn
that in defending the president of the
united states we intend and we will use
all the legal defenses that are
available to us
as would they would be available to any
other citizen of this country
teddy roosevelt quoted earlier in this
proceeding said at best no man is above
the law and no man is below the law
either
in fact the mere act of alleging perjury
as those of you in this body
know who have tried perjury cases the
mere act of alleging perjury
invites precisely the kind of hair
splitting everyone seems to deplore
if it's the will of the congress to
change the crime of perjury to modify it
to eliminate certain judicially created
defenses to that offense so be it
but the crime of perjury has developed
the way it has for some very good
reasons and it has a long and
distinguished pedigree
its essential elements
are well and clearly established and
manager chabot's presentation was clear
on those points although you'll not be
surprised to learn that i disagree with
his conclusions
courts have concluded
that no one should be convicted of
perjury
without demonstrating
that the testimony in question was in
fact false
that the person testifying knew it to be
false
and that the testimony involved an issue
that is material to the case
one that could influence the outcome of
the matter one way or another
in addition courts and prosecutors are
in general agreement
that prosecutions for perjury should not
be brought on the basis of an oath
against an oath
the supreme court has spoken on this
issue
holding that a conviction for perjury
quote ought not to rest entirely upon an
oath against an oath
now ladies and gentlemen of the senate
when we presented our case to the
judiciary committee last december we
invited five experienced prosecutors
to examine the record of this case
and to give us their views as to whether
they would bring charges of perjury and
obstruction of justice against the
president based on that record
these five attorneys
are five of the best the most
experienced the most tested prosecutors
the country has ever seen
three served as high officials in
republican departments of justice
two served during democratic
administrations
all were in agreement
that no
responsible
prosecutor
would bring this case against president
clinton
i'd like to run the tape recordings of
testimony from
two
of the individuals that testified tom
sullivan former united states attorney
from the northern district of illinois
as he describes the law of perjury
and richard davis an experienced trial
lawyer with prosecutorial experience in
the department of justice and the
department of the treasury
the law of perjury can be particularly
arcane
including the requirements that the
government proved beyond a reasonable
doubt
that the defendant knew his testimony to
be false at the time he or she testified
that the alleged false testimony was
material
and that any ambiguity or uncertainty
about what the question or answer meant
must be construed in favor of the
defendant
both perjury and obstruction of justice
are what are known as specific intent
crimes
putting a heavy burden on the prosecutor
to establish the defendant's state of
mind
furthermore
because perjury and obstruction charges
often arise from private dealings with
few observers the courts have required
either two witnesses who testify
directly to the facts establishing the
crime
or if only one witness testifies to the
facts constituting the alleged perjury
that there be substantial corroborating
proof to establish guilt
responsible prosecutors do not bring
these charges lightly
the next testimony you'll here is from
richard davis
who was acting deputy attorney general
excuse me he was uh an assistant from
the southern district of new york
task force leader for a watergate
special prosecution force and assistant
secretary of treasury for enforcement
and operations from 77 to 81.
in the context of perjury prosecutions
there are some specific considerations
which are present when deciding whether
such a case can be won
first it is virtually unheard of to
bring a perjury prosecution based solely
on the conflicting testimony of two
people the inherent problems in bringing
such a case are compounded to the extent
that any credibility exist issues exist
as to the government's sole witness
second questions and answers are often
imprecise
questions sometimes are vague or use too
narrowly defined terms and interrogators
frequently ask compound or inarticulate
questions and fail to follow up in
precise answers
witnesses often meander through an
answer wandering around a question but
never really answering it in a perjury
case where the precise language of a
question and answer us irrelevant this
makes perjury prosecutions difficult
because the prosecutor must establish
that the witness understood the question
intended to give a false not simply an
evasive answer and in fact did so
the problem of establishing such
intentional falsity is compounded in
civil cases by the reality that lawyers
routinely counsel their clients to
answer only the question asked not to
volunteer and not to help out an
inarticulate questioner
legalistic though some of these
legal defenses may be
these are the respectable and respected
acceptable and expected
defenses available to anyone charged
with this kind of a crime
so to accuse us of using legalisms to
defend the president
when he's being accused of perjury
is only to accuse us
of defending the president
we plead guilty to that charge and the
truth is
that an attorney who failed to raise
these defenses
might well be guilty of malpractice
but putting the legal defenses aside
it is not a legal legalistic issue to
point out that the president did not say
much of what he is accused
of having said it is not legalistic to
point out that a witness did not say
what some rely on her testimony to
establish
and it is not too legalistic to point
out that a president of the united
states should not be convicted of
perjury and removed from office over an
argument
a dispute about what is and what is not
the commonly accepted meaning
of words in his testimony
i'd like to make one additional point
about the office of the independent
council and the star prosecutors
they as you know have had a long and
difficult relationship
with the white house
it's been intense
adverse
frequently hostile
they were the ones who conducted the
interrogation of the president before
the grand jury
these attorneys from the office of
independent counsel were identified by
mr star as being experienced and
seasoned and professional
in the referral that they sent over to
the house of representatives
they make three allegations of grand
jury perjury
and the managers based on
my analysis of mr rogan's speech
appear to have adopted two of those
allegations
what is most remarkable
is the fact that the managers make many
many allegations of grand jury perjury
that the independence independent
council declined to make that were not
included in the referral
think about it for a moment
the lawyers working for the office of
the independent council
they were in charge of this
investigation
they were the ones that called the
president
they were the ones running the grand
jury it was their grand jury
they conducted the questioning of the
president
they picked the topics
they asked the follow-up questions
you should remember one additional fact
their standard for making a referral is
presumably much lower than the standard
you would expect from the managers
in making a case for the removal of the
president in an article of impeachment
the independent council act calls upon
the independent council to make a
referral when there is credible and
substantial information
of potential impeachable offenses
they looked at the record the same
record that the managers had
and they did make a referral
and they did send recommendations to the
house of representatives
but these lawyers mr starr and his
fellow prosecutors did not see fit to
allege most of the charges that we are
discussing today
it's fair for us to assume
that the office of independent counsel
considered and declined to make the very
allegations of perjury that the house
managers have presented to you last week
apparently the managers believe that ken
starr and his prosecutors have been
simply too soft on the president
this should cause the members of the
senate some concern and some additional
reason to give very careful scrutiny to
these charges
when you do you will find the following
the allegations are frequently trivial
almost always technical
often immaterial
and always insubstantial
certainly not a good or justifiable
basis
for removing any president from office
finally
as we go through the allegations and the
evidence that i will be discussing
please ask yourself what witness do i
want to hear about this issue
will live witnesses really make a
difference
in the way that i think about this
are they necessary for this case and
this article to be understood and
resolved
subpart one
has to do with testimony
about the nature and details of the
relationship with monica lewinsky
and once again because article one does
not identify with any specificity
what the president said to the grand
jury that is allegedly
for jurious
the house managers have been free to
include whatever specific allegations
they not the house of representatives
have seen fit to level
against
the president
and we have been left to guess so
this is my guesswork
we have been left to guess what the
specific allegations are and we have
done so
and we have tried to identify the
precise testimony at issue
based on
the manager's trial brief and on mr
manager rogan's presentation
now as you will see in these allegations
in subpart one
it is the managers
who resort to legalisms who use
convoluted definitions and word games to
attack the president
it is the managers who employ
technicalities
and legal mumbo-jumbo who distort the
true meaning of words and phrases in an
effort to convict the president and we
are the ones who must cry foul we are
the ones who must point out
what the managers are trying to do here
they seek to convict the president
and remove him from office
for perjury before a grand jury by
transforming wholly innocent statements
about immaterial issues
into what are alleged to be perjurious
false and misleading testimony
i begin with what is identified in the
majority report
as quote direct lies
first
the managers claim that the president
perjured himself before the grand jury
that he told a direct lie and should be
removed from office
because in his prepared statement
he acknowledged having inappropriate
contact
with ms lewinsky on quote certain
occasions
this was a direct lie say the managers
because according to ms lewinsky
between november 15 1995 and december 28
1997
they were alone at least 20 times and
had she says 11
sexual encounters
to use the words on certain occasions in
this context is
according to the managers perjurious
false and misleading
now this particular charge was not
included in mr starr's referral and it
was not debated by the members of the
judiciary committee or the house of
representatives
the managers also say that the president
lied to the grand jury
and should be removed from office
because the president acknowledged that
on occasion
he had telephone conversations that
included sexual banter this was also in
the prepared statement
when the managers say the president and
ms lewinsky had
17 such telephone conversations over a
year period of time
to use the word on occasion in this
context
is according to the managers
a direct lie to the grand jury for which
the president should be removed from
office
now this charge was not included in mr
starr's referral it was not debated by
the members of the house judiciary
committee and it was not debated on the
floor of the house
in responding to these two charges
it may make some sense to begin with the
dictionary definition of occasional
to satisfy ourselves that the
president's statement
is in fact a more than reasonable and
actually an accurate use of that word
under the circumstances
now there are 774 days in the time span
between november 1995
and december 1997.
i submit that it is not a distortion
it is not dishonest
to describe their activity
which ms lewinsky claims occurred on 11
different days
and from
from our examination of her testimony we
can only locate 10
but she says 11.
as having occurred on certain occasions
look at the calendar
now that phrase on certain occasions
carries no inference of frequency or
numerosity
sort of means it happened every now and
then
and the same can be said for the word
the use of the word on occasion when
they were talking about telephone
conversations to describe 17 telephone
conversations that included explicit
sexual
language now as you consider the second
line the second allegation having to do
with the telephone calls
you might also read the grand jury
testimony of miss lewinsky herself on
august 20th
1998 at page 11-11
there a grand jury a grand juror asks
her how much of the time
and how often
when she was on the phone with the
president did they engage in these kinds
of graphic conversations
miss lewinsky answered quote
not always
on a few occasions
the managers
are trying to remove the president from
office
when he used the word on occasions
when ms lewinsky described that
frequency or that event precisely the
same way
there is simply no way that the
president's use of the words on certain
occasions or on occasion can be taken as
an effort to mislead
or deceive the members of the grand jury
or to conceal anything
there is simply no way that a reasonable
person can look at this testimony and
conclude or agree with the managers that
it is a
quote direct lie
what message do the manager send to
america and to the rest of the world
when they include these kinds of
allegations
as reasons to remove this president from
office
it is hard to take the charges seriously
when in each case they boil down to
arguments over semantics
does anyone here really believe that the
members of the house of representatives
would have voted to approve these
allegations as the basis for impeaching
and removing this president
if they had been given the chance with
specific identified for juris testimony
in a proposed article of impeachment but
here we are in the well of the senate
defending the president of the united
states against allegations that the
managers believe
and have seriously argued should cause
the president to be removed from office
and even prosecuted and convicted in a
criminal court
the president is also accused of lying
before the grand jury and the managers
have asked you to convict him and remove
him from office
because in the prepared statement that
he read to the grand jury in august he
acknowledged that he engaged in
inappropriate conduct with ms lewinsky
on certain occasions in early 1996 and
once in 1997.
the managers call this a direct lie
because the president did not mention
1995.
and in their trial memorandum they write
notice the president did not mention
1995.
there was a reason
on three occasions in 1995 ms lewinsky
said she engaged in sexual contact with
the president
now this was one allegation that the
office of the independent council did
include
in its referral to the house and this
charge was in fact discussed and debated
by the members of the judiciary
committee
when they conducted their impeachment
inquiry let me show you what two members
of that committee
now managers for the house in this trial
thought about this particular charge of
perjury when congressman barney frank
ridiculed it during the debate
the chairman of the judiciary committee
mr hyde
we're missing an exhibit here i think
it's number 10
said it didn't strike doesn't strike me
as a terribly serious count
congressman kennedy in his closing
argument at the final
stages of that proceeding said he
thought
i freely acknowledge that reasonable
people can disagree about the weight of
the evidence on certain of the charges
for example
i think there is doubt about the
allegations that the president willfully
lied
concerning the date his relationship
with ms lewinsky began
this allegation involves an utterly
meaningless disparity in testimony about
dates
that are of absolutely no consequence
whatsoever
the most likely explanation here
is that there was an honest
difference in recollection
there is no dispute about the critical
facts
that ms lewinsky was young very young
too young
when she got involved with president
clinton
but her age didn't change between
november 1995
and january 1996
her birthday is in july
she was 22 years old in november and 22
years old in january
despite the fact that every manager
persists in stating
erroneously not perjuriously erroneously
that she was 21 years old
when she first became involved with the
president
nothing of any importance in the case
took place between december 1995 and
january 1996.
she was an intern in the early stages of
that period and she became a government
employee
so it didn't change the relationship
that she had with the president
it modified her title
any dispute over this immaterial issue
is silly
direct lie
because the president did not mention
1995
and in their trial memorandum they write
notice the president did not mention
1995.
there was a reason
on three occasions in 1995 ms lewinsky
said she engaged in sexual contact with
the president
now this was one allegation that the
office of the independent council did
include
in its referral to the house and this
charge was in fact discussed and debated
by the members of the judiciary
committee
when they conducted their impeachment
inquiry let me show you what two members
of that committee
now managers for the house in this trial
thought about this particular charge of
perjury when congressman barney frank
ridiculed it during the debate
the chairman of the judiciary committee
mr hyde
we're missing an exhibit here i think
it's number ten
said it didn't strike doesn't strike me
as a terribly serious count
congressman kennedy in his closing
argument at the final
stages of that proceeding said he
thought
i freely acknowledge that reasonable
people can disagree about the weight of
the evidence on certain of the charges
for example i think there is doubt about
the allegations that the president
willfully lied
concerning the date his relationship
with ms lewinsky began
this allegation involves an utterly
meaningless disparity in testimony about
dates
that are of absolutely no consequence
whatsoever
the most likely explanation here
is that there was an honest
difference in recollection
there is no dispute about the critical
facts
that ms lewinsky was young
very young
too young when she got involved with
president clinton
but her age didn't change between
november 1995
and january 1996
her birthday is in july
she was 22 years old in november and 22
years old in january despite the fact
that every manager persists in stating
erroneously not perjuriously erroneously
that she was 21 years old
when she first became involved with the
president
nothing of any importance in the case
took place between december 1995 and
january 1996.
she was an intern
in the early stages of that period and
she became a government employee
so it didn't change the relationship
that she had with the president
it modified her title
any dispute over this immaterial issue
is silly
and it is
unreasonable to argue
as we heard from the house managers last
week that if you believe monica lewinsky
and disbelieve the president on this
issue
as to which date was the date that they
began their relationship
and had the inappropriate contact that
you must convict the president and
remove him from office
i confess i find myself in agreement
with congressman hyde when he says that
this allegation
is not serious not terribly serious and
i agree with congressman kennedy
when he suggests that there is room for
doubt
as to whether the president had any real
reason or motive to have lied about
these days
and i truly wonder if the house of
representatives
had it been identified as a specific
statement
for them to consider would have made
and included this allegation in the
articles of impeachment
aimed at removing president clinton from
office
is this conflict and testimony really
such a serious issue
that if you find the president to be
mistaken he should be removed from
office
and is it important enough to require
the testimony of live witnesses
is it material of anything of interest
to the grand jury at the time this
testimony was given i don't think so
now between the time of the vote in the
house and the time that the managers
filed their trial brief the managers
came up with another allegation of
perjury and put it into the mix
they argue that this element of the
president's grand jury testimony should
also cause him to be removed from office
this allegation involves the president's
statement that there was some period of
friendship with ms lewinsky that led to
inappropriate contact
but it's immaterial
unimportant
and fundamentally frivolous as an
allegation
and it was not needless to say included
in the star referral
i'm sure the
attorneys in the office of independent
counsel knew about this statement and
chose not to include it it was never
discussed by the members of the
judiciary committee during the
impeachment inquiry
we never heard about it never saw it
never had a chance to deal with it it
was never mentioned on the floor of the
house of representatives
and according to my
examination which may be flawed
but my thinking is that it made its
first appearance in this matter
only after the house of representatives
had voted on the articles of impeachment
when the managers filed their trial
brief
does anyone really believe that the
house of representatives would have
voted to approve this allegation as the
basis for convicting and removing this
president from office
then the managers turned to what the
majority report they call the heart of
the perjury
that is the president's grand jury
testimony that his encounters with ms
lewinsky
did not constitute sexual relations as
defined by the jones lawyers in the
jones deposition
before dealing with this allegation
however it is important to understand
that in the course
of his testimony the president was
required to deploy two different
definitions
of sexual relations one was his own
and the other was the definition
supplied to him by the jones lawyers
and modified by judge susan weber wright
during his deposition
first if you turn to exhibit number 11
you will find the president's definition
his own personal definition
as reported to the grand jury
next let me direct your attention to
this transcript of the telephone
conversation between monica lewinsky i'm
talking here about
exhibit 12 monica lewinsky and linda
tripp
where ms lewinsky explains her
definition of sexual relations
and this conversation occurred
incidentally many weeks before ms
lewinsky executed her affidavit
for the jones case
finally look at the dictionaries
and and read their definitions that you
can see at exhibit 13.
by the way
exhibit 12 which includes ms lewinsky's
definition
uh is confirmed by other parts of the
of the record where she talks to other
individuals fbi agents she she refers to
this understanding and definition in her
proffer so it's not just this one
telephone conversation to establish what
lin what monica lewinsky
says she thought at that time the
definition was
although some might think that the
president definition is unduly limited
and that both of them are splitting
hairs
there is some reasonable basis and
there's reputable authority to support
their view
it seems clear that ms lewinsky could
think
and probably did think and reassured
herself at the time she wrote and
executed her affidavit
that the affidavits she submitted in the
jones case was in fact
accurate
and thus knowing ms lewinsky's view of
that situation and sharing her
definition
the president could reasonably say
absolutely yes
when mr bennett asked the president if
ms lewinsky's affidavit stating that she
had never had sexual relations with the
president was true
how can you accept the argument of the
house managers that the president should
be removed from office
because his definition which is the
dictionary definition
does not comport with theirs
we're going to play the videotape
this is we're going to talk about the
definition that was the second
definition that was given to the
president
in the jones deposition
which is also a subject of grand jury
testimony
and we're going to play
14 minutes of that videotape
at the beginning of the jones of the
president's appearance
at the time when he was first handed the
definition and sits at the table
and this may be a good time to take a
break because it would be a 14 minute
span of time
the chair recognizes the majority leader
chief justice uh has consent that we uh
take a 10 minute recess at this time in
the proceedings i urge the senators to
relax a moment but come right back to
the chamber so we can proceed and watch
this video
canada new york good afternoon good
afternoon
uh
senate will be in order i don't thanks
chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice i believe you're ready
to proceed uh with mr uh council craig's
uh video perhaps or do you have some
other practice
the chair recognizes mr council craig
thank you mr chief justice
exhibit number 14
in your collection of exhibits
is the definition
that the president was handed
when he went into his deposition
testimony to give his deposition
testimony
now there's two or three things i'd like
to say about this
exhibit
before we go look at the videotape the
first is this
many of the president's critics have
accused the president
of himself coming up with this tortured
and convoluted definition
so that he could get away
with denying having sex
with miss lewinsky that he was the one
that came up with a bizarre and unreal
definition
that would give him some plausible
deniability and allow him to conceal his
relationship
with ms lewinsky from the jones lawyers
but in truth
this definition was not his idea not his
work product
not his own definition
and it is unfair and inaccurate to
settle him
with inventing such a silly and
truncated definition
and the events that flowed from that my
second point is this
the mere fact that the lawyers in jones
felt the need to use a definition
for sexual relations is
by itself standing alone
evidence to support the notion
that at least they recognized
that the precise meaning of the term
can and does differ from person to
person
it is precisely then when there is some
uncertainty or ambiguity
about the meaning and common usage of
words
that lawyers turn to created definitions
in an effort to have clarity uniformity
and common understanding
and the very fact that the lawyers in
jones seem to think that a definition
was needed means that without such a
definition there is no commonly accepted
no universally agreed upon meaning of
this phrase
and what is or is not included with the
ambit of that definition then becomes an
argument
and nothing more
certainly not perjury
the third point
to remember before we watch the
president
as he first sees
this piece of paper is this
to understand what was going on in the
president's mind at the time he
testified
about this definition
during the jones deposition you must
look at what was deleted
as well as looking at that part of the
definition that was left behind
you will see that in the third paragraph
of the definition
there is a
description which in fact more closely
approximates
what went on
between ms lewinsky and the president
then does the first paragraph and this
part of the definition
was deleted by the judge
there is an additional point on the tape
you will hear the president's lawyer mr
bennett
and mr ruff referred to this yesterday
urging
the jones lawyers to abandon this
definition to leave it behind and ask
direct questions of the president
as to what he did
uh the record would certainly have been
clearer for all of us if he had followed
mr bennett's advice
and there's another voice that you hear
in addition to mr bennett mr fisher who
is the jones lawyer
the judge judge wright
and that's the voice of the lawyer for
the president's co-defendant in this
case danny ferguson
now let me just briefly tell you what to
look for the president
first saw this definition when he
entered the room and sat down to testify
not before
you will see him as he sits there and is
handed a piece of paper with the
definition typed on it
neither he nor his lawyer had ever seen
that definition before
he was then required to sit down to
study it and to understand it
and if we look at
the next exhibit
this is what he said
about what he thought and did
later in the grand jury i think this is
definition this is exhibit number
15.
and you watch him as he does this i
might also note
that when i was given this
and began to ask questions about it
i actually circled number one
this is my circle here
i remember doing it so i could focus
only on those two lines
which is what i did
and this is the actual
deposition exact uh exhibit
with his circle around number one
and let us remember finally
what his testimony is about his
intentions in this deposition
my goal was to be truthful
but i didn't want to help them
let's watch what happened
[Music]
good morning my name is jim fisher sir
and i'm an attorney from dallas texas
and i represent the plaintiff paula
jones in this case
do you understand who i am and who i'm
representing today
yes
and do you understand sir that
your answers to my questions today are
testimony that is being given under oath
yes
and your testimony is subject to
the penalty of perjury do you understand
that sir
i do
sir i'd like to hand you what has been
marked deposition exhibit one
so that
the record is clear today and that we
know that we are communicating
this is a definition of a term that will
be used in the course of my questioning
the term is sexual relations
i will inform the court that the wording
of this definition is patterned after
federal rule of evidence 413
would you please take
whatever time you need to read this
definition because when i use the term
sexual relations this is what i'm
meaning today
[Music]
is there a copy for the
court you pass that please
[Music]
your honor uh as an introductory matter
i think this could really lead to
confusion
uh and i think it's important
that the record be clear for example it
says the last line
contact means intentional touching
directly or through clothing
i mean just for example one could have a
completely innocent shake of the hand
and i don't want this record to reflect
i think we're here today
for counsel for the plaintiff to ask the
president what he knows
about various things what he did what he
didn't do
but i i have a real problem with this
definition which means all things to all
people in this particular context
what this
what the
deposing attorney should be looking at
is exactly what occurred and he can ask
the witness to describe
as exactly as possible what occurred but
to use this as an antecedent to his
questions it would put him in a position
if the president admitted shaking hands
with someone that under this truncated
deposition or definition he could say or
somehow construe that to mean that that
involves some sort of sexual relations
and i think it's very unfair frankly i
think it's a political trick
and i've told you before how i feel
about
the political character of what this
lawsuit is about
the honor
this man was fine
the purpose of this is to avoid
everything that they have expressed
concern about it is to allow us to be
discreet and to make the record crystal
clear
there is absolutely no way that this
could ever be construed
to include a shaking of the hand
well mr fisher let me refer you to
paragraph two it says contact between
any part of the person's body
or an object and the genitals
or anus of another person what
if the president patted me and said i
had to lose 10 pounds off my bottom i
you could be arguing that i had sexual
relations with iran this is going to
lead
to confusion why don't they ask the
president what he did what he didn't do
and then we can argue in court later
about what it means but let me make a
ruling on this it appears that uh this
really is not the definition of
contact under rule 413 because
uh rule 413 deals with non-consensual
contact
uh this definition would encompass
uh contact that is consensual
and of course the court has ruled that
some consensual contact is relevant in
this case and uh
so if with the record reflected the
court disagrees with council that this
is not the death this is about it being
the definition under rule 413 it's not
it is more in keeping
uh with however the court's previous
rules
but
i certainly agree
with the president's council
that this
definition number
two
is two and
it's too broad
and so is
definition number three
um definition number one
in
encompasses uh intense
and so that would be by
but
but numbers two and three is just are
just too broad
um
all right your honor and
number one
uh is not
uh too broad
however uh so i'll let you use that
definition as long as we understand that
that's not rule 413 it's just the rules
that would apply
in this case to intentional sexual
content
yes your honor and
had i've been allowed to develop this
further everyone would have seen that
deposition exhibit 2 is actually the
definition of sexual assault or
offensive sexual assault which is the
term in world 413 your honor i object to
this record
being filled with these kinds of things
this is going to leak why don't they
have they have got the president of the
united states in this room for several
hours why don't they ask him questions
about what happened or didn't happen i
will permit him to refer to definition
number one which encompasses
uh knowing and potential
sexual contact uh for the purpose of
arousing our gratifying sexual desire
i'll permit that go ahead
mr president in light of the court's
ruling
uh
you may consider
subparts two and three of deposition
exhibit one to be stricken
and so when in my questions i use the
term sexual relationship
i'm talking only about
uh part one
and the definition at the bottom
do you understand that sir i do
i'm now handing you what has been marked
deposition exhibit two
[Applause]
please take whatever time you need to
read deposition exhibit 2.
your honor again
[Applause]
what i am very worried about your honor
is first of all
uh
this this
this appears to be uh
i mean what i don't want to do is have
anybody being asked questions and then
we don't we're all
ships passing in the night they're
thinking of one thing he's thinking of
another are we talking criminal assault
are we i mean
this is not what a deposition is for
your honor he can ask the president what
did you do
he can ask him specifically in certain
instances what he did
and isn't that what this deposition is
for it's not to sort of lay a trap for
him
uh
and i'm going to object to the president
answering
and having to remember what's on this
whole sheet of paper and uh
i just don't think it's fair it's going
to lend a confusion all right
do you agree with mr bennett and i have
one other point
this is almost like in a typical
automobile accident where the appliance
council wants to ask the defendant were
you negligent
that's not factual mr fischer do you
have a response
yes your honor what i'm trying to do is
avoid having to ask the president a
number of very salacious questions
and to make this as discreet
as possible
this definition i think the court will
find is taken directly from rule 413
which i believe president clinton signed
into law
with the exception that i have narrowed
subpart 1
to a particular section which would be
covered by rule 413
and i have that section here to give the
president so that there is no question
what is intended this will eliminate
confusion not cause it your honor i have
no objection where the appropriate
predicates are made
for them to ask the president did you
know x
yes or no what happened what did you do
what didn't you do
we are we acknowledge that some
embarrassing questions will be asked but
then we all will know what we're talking
about but i do not want my client
answering questions
and not understanding exactly what these
folks are talking about your honor i
told you that the president has a
meeting at four o'clock and we've
already wasted 20 minutes and mr fisher
has yet to ask his first faction well
i'm prepared to rule
and
i will not permit this definition
uh to be
understood quite frankly there are
several reasons
one is that the court heretofore has not
proceeded using these definitions we
have used we've made numerous rulings or
the court has made numerous rulings in
this case without specific reference to
these definitions and so if you want to
know the truth i don't know very well
um i i would find it difficult to make
rulings and
mr bennett has made clear that he
acknowledges that
embarrassing questions will be asked and
if this is in fact an effort on on the
prior planets council to avoid using
uh sexual terms and avoid going into uh
great detail about what
life or might not have occurred uh then
there's no need to worry about that you
may go into the detail if the predicates
are we we have no objection to the
details
it's just going to make it very
difficult for me to rule
i'm not sure mr clinton knows all these
definitions anyway
did you hear that last statement from
the judge i'm not sure mr clinton knows
all these definitions anyway
now before the grand jury
the president discussed at some length
and in great detail his interpretation
of the definition that he was asked to
apply
uh during that deposition the definition
that he was asked to apply
and he gave lengthy and sustained
answers and when you read the grand jury
testimony as i urge you to do
you will see that they're consistent and
they're logical
and there is
reason behind his conclusion
that his activities with ms lewinsky
simply did not fall within that
definition
there's no mystery no deception
no lying no effort to conceal
his view his view is there for all to
see it's also reported
from these
limited excerpts from the grand jury
testimony
it's a plain statement of his
understanding
and to argue that the president
when he
conveyed his understanding
of that definition
doesn't really believe his argument
and to contend that he is
committing perjury when he told the
grand jury that he genuinely believed
his interpretation of the definition
that's just speculation
about what is in his
in his mind and it's not the stuff
or fuel
of a perjury prosecution
now i'd like to return very briefly to
the group of experienced prosecutors who
gave their opinion
about the president's testimony before
the grand jury on this issue
they said that the president's
interpretation
was a reasonable one under the
circumstances
but the managers claimed that the
president's explanation
of the jones definition his
interpretation his understanding and his
argument with the lawyers from the
office of independent counsel are the
heart of the pert of the perjury
let's hear what the prosecutors said
about this
and read the transcript of their
testimony
when they testified before the house
judiciary committee and first we'll
listen to tom sullivan
thank you very much mr hyde
it's clear to me that the president's
interpretation is a reasonable one
especially because the words would seem
to describes directly
oral sex
were the words which
seemed to describe directly oral sex
were stricken from the definition by the
judge
in a perjury prosecution the government
press proved beyond a reasonable doubt
that the defendant knew when he gave the
testimony he was telling a falsehood
the lie must be knowing and deliberate
it is not perjury for a witness to evade
obfuscate or answer non-responsibly
the evidence simply does not support the
conclusion that the president knowingly
committed perjury and the case is so
doubtful and weak that a responsible
prosecutor would not present presented
to the grand jury
and we have one more excerpt from his
testimony
in
perjury cases
you must prove
that the person who made the statement
made a knowingly false statement now
where i think the defect in this
prosecution is among others and i don't
think it would be brought because it's
ancillary to a civil deposition is to
establish that the president knew what
he said was false when he testified
in his grand jury testimony he explained
what his mental process was in the
jones deposition and he said the two
definitions
that would describe oral sex had been
deleted by the trial judge from the
definition of sexual relations and i
understood the definition to mean
sleeping with somebody i want to get too
particular here thank you but that is
where
this case in my opinion
wouldn't go forward even if you found an
errant prosecutor who would want to
prosecute somebody for being a
peripheral witness in a civil case that
had been
settled
that's my answer to that
the managers place great emphasis and
weight
on the conflict in the testimony between
president clinton and ms lewinsky
over some specific intimate details
relating to their activity there's a
variance
between the president's testimony and ms
lewinsky's testimony
about the details of what they did
what do they disagree about
not about whether the president and ms
lewinsky had a wrongful relationship
the president admitted that before the
grand jury
not about whether the president and ms
lewinsky were alone together
the president admitted that before the
grand jury
not about whether when they were alone
together
their relationship included
inappropriate
intimate contact
the president admitted that before the
grand jury
not about whether they engaged in
telephone conversations that included
sexual banter the president admitted
that before the grand jury
not about whether the president
and ms lewinsky
wanted to keep their wrongful
relationship a secret
the president admitted that before the
grand jury the difference
in their testimony about their
relationship
is limited to some very specific
very intimate details
and this is the heart
of the entire matter this disparity
in their testimony the true nub of the
manager's allegation
that the president committed perjury
is that he described some of the contact
one way
and she described it
another
not surprisingly the managers choose to
believe
ms lewinsky's description of these
events
and so even in the absence of any
evidence to the contrary
other than ms lewinsky's own
recollection of these events
the managers have concluded that the
president lied under oath about the
details of his sexual activity
that he somehow
shortchanged the grand jury
and should be removed from office
the possibility that the question
of whether the president of the united
states should be removed from his office
the fact that that might hinge on
whether you believe him or her on this
issue
is a staggering thought
ordinarily when dealing with disparity
in testimony such as this
prosecutors will have nothing to do with
it
only two people were there
and in truth the real importance of the
disparity in their testimony is
questionable
not all disparities or discrepancies in
testimony
are necessarily appropriate subjects
for perjury prosecutions
according to those experienced
prosecutors who testified before the
judiciary committee there are two more
points to be made about this
first this is a classic
oath on oath
he says she says swearing match
that under ordinary custom and practice
at the department of justice
never would be prosecuted without
substantial corroborative proof
such proof say these experienced
prosecutors
does not consist of the testimony of
friends and associates of miss lewinsky
who tell the fbi that ms lewinsky
contemporaneously told them about the
activity at the time it was going on
but the managers claimed that these
contemporaneous statements corroborate
ms lewinsky's testimony
that claim
is specious statements that ms lewinsky
makes to other people
are not viewed as independent
corroborative evidence
they come from the same source
they come from ms lewinsky
as the as the source that gave that
testimony to the grand jury
and no court and no prosecutor would
accept the notion
that such statements standing alone
satisf satisfy the requirement
of substantial corroborative proof when
there is a swearing badge
now let's see what the experienced
prosecutors have to say about this issue
and that claim
what is the false statement
well if you
it could be one of two it could be
when he denied having sexual relations
and i've already addressed that because
he said i was
defining the term as the judge told me
to define it and as i understood it
which i think is a reasonable
explanation the other is whether or not
he touched her touched her breast or
some other part of her body
uh not through her clothing but directly
and he says i didn't and she said i did
so it's who shot john it's it's it's
you know it's a one on one
the corroborative evidence that the
prosecutor would have to have there
which he as required in a perjury case
you can't do it one on one
and no good prosecutor would bring a
case with you know i say black you say
white would be the fact that they were
together alone and she performed oral
sex on him i think that is not
sufficient under the circumstances of
this case to demonstrate that there was
any other touching by the president and
therefore he committed this
you know he violated this
and committed perjury
and now the testimony from richard davis
on this same point
and then we'll move to subpart 2.
i will now turn to the issue of whether
from the perspective of a prosecutor
there exists a prosecutable case for
perjury in front of the grand jury the
answer to me is clearly no the president
acknowledged to the grand jury the
existence of an improper intimate
relationship with monica lewinsky but
argued with the prosecutors questioning
him that his acknowledged conduct was
not a sexual relationship as he
understood the definition of that term
being used in the jones deposition
engaging in such a debate whether wise
or unwise politically simply does not
form the basis for a perjury prosecution
indeed in the end the entire basis for a
grand jury perjury prosecution comes
down to monica lewinsky's assertion that
there was a reciprocal nature to their
relationship and that the president
touched her private parts with the
intent to arouse or gratify her in the
president's denial that he did so
putting aside her aside whether this is
the type of difference of testimony
which should justify an impeachment of a
president i do not believe that a case
involving this kind of conflict between
two witnesses would be brought by a
prosecutor since it would not be won at
trial a prosecutor would understand the
problem created by the fact that both
individuals had an incentive to lie the
president to avoid acknowledging a false
statement at his civil deposition and
miss lewinsky to avoid the demeaning
nature of providing wholly
unreciprocated sex indeed this incentive
existed when miss lewinsky described the
relationship to the confidence described
in the independent council's referral
equally as important however mr starr
has himself questioned the veracity of
his one witness miss lewinsky by
questioning her testimony that his
office suggested she tape record ms
curry mr jordan and potentially the
president and in any trial the
independent council would also be
arguing that other key points of miss
lewinsky's testimony are false including
where she explicitly rejects the notion
that she was asked to lie and that
assistance in her job in her job search
was an inducement for her to do so
the conclusion is clear to make this
case in any courtroom would be very
difficult for a prosecutor
they point out that it is difficult if
not impossible to put on a successful
prosecution
if the chief witness
is deemed by the prosecutors to be
unreliable on some issues
but presented as totally truthful on
others
now let's move to subpart 2
and it's exhibit number 18.
the allegations of perjury here
have to do with testimony that he gave
in the grand jury
about his deposition in the jones case
and i begin by repeating a point
that i made a little earlier that the
house of representatives did not to vote
did not vote to approve the article that
alleged
uh that president clinton committed
perjury during his deposition
in the jones deposition
um and as i said before there was good
reason for that what are the reasons
the president's there are many reasons
the president's testimony in the jones
deposition
involved his relationship with a witness
who was ancillary to the core issues of
the jones case
she was a witness in the case
she wasn't to defend the the plaintiff
in the case and she was ancillary to the
core issues in the case
someone whose testimony was
thereafter held to be unnecessary
and perhaps inadmissible
by judge susan weber wright
someone whose truthful testimony would
have been in any event of marginal
relevance
uh since her relationship with the
president
was entirely concession consensual
and as you know this was a case that
ultimately was found to have no legal
or factual merit
and it was dismissed by the judge
and it has now been settled by the
parties
moreover the president was caught by
surprise in that deposition and asked
questions about matters
that the jones lawyers
already knew the answers to
as you heard yesterday that jones
lawyers had been briefed the night
before by linda tripp
so they were asking questions of
president clinton in the course of this
deposition
about the relationship to which they
already had the answers that kind of
ambush
is profoundly unfair
and it is one reason
that congressman graham
said that he voted against this article
in committee
the surprise
he was the only republican to do so
he was the only republican to vote
against any article
and the decision of the house to follow
congressman graham's leadership and to
reject this article showed great wisdom
and judgment
but apparently that is not to be the
answer when it comes the end of the
matter when it comes to allegations of
perjury in the jones deposition
in subpart 2 of article one
the managers seek to reintroduce the
issue of the president's testimony in
the in the case
by alleging that when the president
testified before the grand jury
he testified falsely when he said that
he tried to testify truthfully
in the jones deposition
congressman rogan mr manager rogan has
claimed that the president's answers
ratified and reaffirmed
and put in issue
all of his answers in the jones
deposition when he testified that he
believed he did not violate the law in
the jones deposition
this is perjurious testimony
said manager rogan because the record is
clear and i'm quoting that he did not
testify truthfully in the deposition and
by that bootstrapping mechanism we are
now in a litigation
about whether
every single statement that the
president made in the jones deposition
was or was not truthful
to determine whether or not the
president's testimony that he was
truthful is or is not truthful
but in fact president clinton did not
ratify he did not reaffirm his jones
testimony when he testified before the
grand jury and you will see that when
you read the transcript of his testimony
quite the contrary is true
if you look at that transcript carefully
you will find
that without admitting wrongdoing
the president
elaborated he modified he amended and he
clarified
his testimony in
jones
and when mr shippers made his closing
argument to the house judiciary
committee
i think he used the truthfulness on one
occasion of the president's testimony
before the grand jury to support his
argument that the president lied in
jones
but actually the specific wording of
subpart 2
gives us no specific information
and is not illuminating and we turn to
the manager's trial brief
to ascertain precisely what their
argument is there
the managers allege that the president
falsely testified
that he answered questions truthfully at
his deposition
concerning among other things
whether he had been alone with ms
lewinsky
i begin by saying again that this
allegation was not included in the star
referral
why because it is based on a total
misconception of the president's grand
jury testimony
as i referred to earlier this is exhibit
number seven i believe
and it shows you some
evidence this is not the complete
evidence of his testimony about a being
alone but the question the prosecutors
asked the question the president many
questions about being alone with miss
lewinsky
but they never asked him about the jones
testimony they asked him about whether
he was alone
he never was asked about the jones
testimony
when i was alone with miss lewinsky on
certain occasions
it was right there when i was alone let
me ask you mr president you indicate in
your statement that you were alone with
ms lewinsky is that right
yes sir
how many times were you alone with ms
lewinsky
let me begin with the correct answer i
don't know for sure but if you'd like me
to give an educated guess i will do that
and then you will see over two or three
pages of testimony he tries to recall
times and incidents when he was alone
with miss lewinsky
and so the prosecutor says so if i could
summarize your testimony
approximately five times you saw her
before she left the white house
approximately nine times after she left
the employment
i know there were several times in 97
the president said
i would think that would sound about
right this is not a man
denying that he was alone with ms
lewinsky
but he was not asked about his testimony
on that topic
when he testified in the jones case
now the managers further allege that the
president's testimony before the grand
jury
that he testified truthfully at his
deposition was a lie
[Music]
in fact
his testimony there that they quote as
being
false was this one
my goal in this deposition was to be
truthful but not particularly helpful
my goal in this deposition to be
truthful they say is false
i was determined to walk through the
minefield of this deposition without
violating the law and i believe i did
his statement that i believe i did
they say means that everything that he
said
in the jones deposition was true
the president's statement that he set a
goal and believes
believes he's met it
is according to the managers for jurious
for which he should be removed from
office and it is through this device
that the managers seek to achieve by
indirection what they were specifically
forbidden to do
by the direct vote of the house of
representatives
by claiming that the president's
assertions in the grand jury were false
when he described his state of mind i
believed i tried i was determined my
goal was
that he believed the managers seek to
put out all of the
president's evasive and misleading
testimony in the jones deposition in
issue
that effort i submit should be rejected
let me cite one
rather painful example
in support of the president's testimony
that he in fact tried
to answer accurately
when he testified in the grand jury
he was asked whether he ever had sexual
relations with jennifer flowers
and he answered yes
that he had under the definition of
sexual relations being used in the jones
case
he later said that he would rather have
taken a whipping in public than to
acknowledge that relation
because he knew it would be leaked to
the public
which it was
now if he didn't care
about telling the truth
in that deposition
if he went in to that deposition with
the intention of denying anything and
everything that was embarrassing
if he really had decided
in his own mind
that whatever the jones lawyers asked
him
he wasn't going to be truthful about it
he never would have testified
the way he did about jennifer flowers
now ladies and gentlemen of the senate
the president does not claim and he
never was asked in front of the grand
jury
and he never asserts in front of the
grand jury that all his testimony in the
jones deposition was truthful
his statement was that he tried to be
accurate
that his goal was to be truthful
but that statement is not
a broad reaffirmation of the accuracy of
all his testimony
despite the house manager's desire to
characterize it as such
those were accurate descriptions
of the president's state of mind at the
time he testified
the real issue here is not the truth of
the underlying statements
made by the president in the jones
deposition
but the president's explanation of those
statements
whether his description of his efforts
to walk this fine line
that he gave to the grand jury
was accurate whether
you agree or disagree with the
president's view that he was or was not
successful
in his undertaking
not to break the law and to be lawful
that argument
is an argument
it's hard and it's not a secret argument
he has that out there open for everybody
to see
that argument is hardly a proper subject
for a perjury claim
and his simple restatement of his legal
position
to the members of the grand jury is
hardly the stuff of a perjury
prosecution
actually if you look at the president's
grand jury testimony you will see that
he provided much more complete much more
accurate
much more reliable testimony about many
of the topics covered in jones
and the notion that he reaffirmed
confirmed or ratified his jones
testimony
is just
unsupported by the evidence
it would be astonishing to think that
the senate would conclude that the
president should be removed from office
because in the
grand jury he gave voice to a legal
opinion and stated his own personal
belief
that his testimony in the jones
deposition did not break the law
i submit to you that if
that was the case the office of the
independent council would have included
that in the referral and they did not
in fact let me just say right now none
of the rest
of the allegations that we're going to
be discussing in the article
that we're talking about today
are included in the star referral the
rest are entirely the product
of the managers
sub part 3 which is exhibit number 19.
this has to do with the president's
testimony about statements he allowed
his attorney to make to a federal judge
in the jones case and you saw the
the tape of that
testimony
last week
according to the trial memorandum the
president remained silent during the
jones deposition at a time when his
counsel
mr bennett made false and misleading
representations to the court about ms
lewinsky's affidavit
pointing to the lewinsky affidavit
bennett stated that ms lewinsky had
filed an affidavit saying that there is
absolutely
quote no sex of any kind in any manner
shape or form with president clinton
and when asked
by the independent council about this
moment before the grand jury the
president testified that he hadn't paid
much attention
that he was thinking about his testimony
and he says this four or five times this
is not just once
he says this four or five times he's
emphatic
that he didn't pay attention and the
words went by him
now in support of their claim that the
president lied when he said he wasn't
paying attention the house managers
point to the videotape record
of the president's testimony which shows
they argue that the president was
looking directly at mr bennett and
paying close attention to his argument
to judge wright
this allegation
not included in the star referral is
even more curious than the previous one
because it's based on a novel legal
theory
which is
jeopardizes all lawyers in the building
which is that a client has an
enforceable obligation to correct his
attorney's alleged misstatements
and if he doesn't
make those corrections he the client
will be held liable to charges of
perjury and obstruction of justice
the charge is that the president misled
the grand jury
when he t when he said that he wasn't
paying attention
while the videotape shows that the
president was looking in bennett's
direction
there is nothing that can be read in his
face or in his
body language to show that he is
listening to understanding or affirming
mr bennett's statement no not of the
head
no movement at all
no comment
nothing
what happens is this mr bennett makes
his comment and is interrupted by the
judge she says no just a minute let me
let me make my ruling
before mr bennett has a chance to
complete his argument
and after interrupting mr bennett the
judge makes a lengthy observation
followed by intense exchange
between all council and the judge
the moment is fleeting it goes by very
very quickly
the moment occurs not at the beginning
of the deposition but well into it after
president clinton
has in fact been subjected to questions
about monica lewinsky
mr clinton as you know has been
surprised by the direction the case has
taken and the fact that the exclusive
focus
of these questions is on
lewinsky he did not know this was coming
he did not expect it
as he put it in his grand jury testimony
quote i had no way of knowing
that they would ask me all these
detailed questions i did the best i
could to answer them unquote
at that moment because the questions had
focused on ms lewinsky to the exclusion
of everything and everybody else
including the jones case
questions about the jones case didn't
occur until much much later and near the
end of the deposition
the president must have realized that
the jones attorneys
probably knew about his relationship
with monica lewinsky
he obviously had not taken any steps to
prepare
to answer questions about that
relationship
and he was clearly caught off guard
it is not far-fetched
to think that that moment
his mind was flooded with thoughts about
how to get through the deposition
it is not implausible
to think that that that moment the
president was preoccupied
watching his lawyer do his job
and not listening carefully and not
tracking word by word the substance of
the exchange
those of you who have practiced law and
who have represented individuals under
stress and depositions
know that this can happen
and is it reasonably is it really
reasonable to think that you can tell
beyond a reasonable doubt what is going
on in the president's mind by looking at
the videotape and if you can
and he you are convinced he has heard
does he have any obligation
to say something
and if he doesn't
then this case this allegation amounts
to nothing
it is hard to believe that the house
managers if it did i think the star
people would have brought it
it is hard to believe that the house
managers believe that the senate should
conclude
that the president committed perjury and
should be removed from his office on the
basis
of his silence
his failure to speak
now there's a second allegation
associated with this with this incident
one that congressman rogen asserted in
his presentation but is not discussed in
the trial memorandum
this has to do with the president's now
famous testimony about mr bennett's
statement about ms lewinsky's affidavit
depends upon what the meaning of is is
let's talk about that just a minute
while raising questions about the good
faith of the jones attorney and asking
questions about ms lewinsky this is in
the grand jury
i'm sorry i'm wrong this is in the jones
deposition
while raising questions about the good
faith of the jones attorneys and asking
questions about ms lewinsky and not
knowing that these same lawyers actually
know the answers to the questions mr
bennett said
referring to the jones lawyers quote
council is fully aware that ms lewinsky
has filed an affidavit
saying that there is absolutely no sex
there is absolutely no sex of any kind
in any manner shape or form with
president clinton
now
during his grand jury testimony
the independent counsel reads that
statement to the president
he gets president clinton to agree
that the statement was made by the
president's attorney in front of
judge wright
and here's what the independent counsel
says to president clinton the grand jury
after reading mr bennett's words
that statement
is a completely false statement
whether or not mr bennett knew of your
relationship with ms lewinsky the
statement that there is no sex of any
kind
manner shape or form with president
clinton was an utterly false statement
and he asks the president is that
correct
and at that point pausing just a moment
for reflection president clinton gives
his opinion
and explains that opinion
to understand the president's argument
you must know first that there has been
no inappropriate contact with ms
lewinsky at the time of that deposition
for according to his recollection almost
a year according to hers 10 months
and so
it's not in dispute that at that moment
in time
and for previous months there has been
and there is
no sexual relationship
currently
even though
there had been one in 95 96
and in the early part of 97 some months
back
now the president
makes
a political mistake here
and gives in to his instinct instinct
to play his own lawyer to be his own
advocate
you may find it frustrating you may find
it irritating
when you watched him do this
but he is not committing perjury
he is committing the offense of
nitpicking and arguing with the
prosecutors
he is arguing a point
and so he says
that whether mr bennett's statement is
false depends
upon what the meaning of is is
mr bennett's statement is true
if is means an ongoing relationship but
mr bennett's statement is false
if is means
at any time
ever in time
now the president's answer to mr
bennett's question and the statements
that follow it amount to an annoying
argument over the interpretation of what
mr bennett said focused on
the tense of the verb
and the president is being his own
lawyer here
the grounds of his argument are fully
stated fully explained
there's no mystery he's not concealing
anything
and making this argument is not perjury
but there's one final point to make
about this incident because again i
think there was a mischaracterization
of what the president actually said in
the grand jury
he didn't say
that at the time
mr bennett
made that statement in the jones
deposition
he caught
the word is and recognized aha i've got
an exit
that makes
it accurate
quite to the contrary he is clear in
front of the grand jury
when he says that he didn't even notice
this issue until he was reviewing the
transcript in preparation for his grand
jury testimony
he's clear in pointing out
the argument
that he is making is one that he just
discovered let me quote from that
portion of his testimony which appears
on pages 5 12
and 513
which makes it clear that he wasn't ever
claiming that he spotted that verb tense
at the time in the jones deposition and
his silence or his answer was based on
spotting the verb tense then this was
something he discovered noticed
and as a lawyer argued in the grand jury
quote
i never even focused on that
meaning that issue of the verb tense
until i read it in this transcript
in preparation for this testimony
i wasn't trying to give you a cute
answer
that i was obviously not involved in
anything improper during the deposition
i was trying to tell you that generally
speaking in the present tense
if someone said that that would be true
but i don't know what mr bennett had in
mind i don't know
now the president was open and honest
and obvious in what he was arguing
and that is precisely what he was doing
on this occasion he was arguing a point
that as a technical matter
bennett's statement could be read as
being accurate
i point out again that this particular
allegation was not included in mr
starr's referral
an argument that's identified as an
argument the grounds of which are
cleared at all are not the basis
for
a perjury prosecution
subpart four of this article has to do
with false and misleading testimony
about the president's efforts
allegedly
to influence witnesses and to impede
discovery
in jones
now as i've said before at the beginning
of my presentation the fourth category
of allegedly perjurious false and
misleading grand jury testimony overlaps
with article two's allegations of
obstruction of justice
and i'll say right now that cheryl mills
will be appearing here when i'm
completed
and david kendall tomorrow
to present the arguments
why article two
uh why the president should not be found
guilty and is not guilty
of the allegations of obstruction of
justice
in article two
but according to the manager's trial
brief
making this argument
that he also perjured himself about
these matters
they claim these lies are the most
troubling
as the president used them in an attempt
to conceal his criminal actions
one begins with the self-evident
proposition at least to us that the
president did not obstruct justice
and we hope you agree with us by the end
of the day tomorrow when we explain
the
evidence his explanations if that is so
of what he did or didn't do
to the grand jury were always truthful
put another way
if the president didn't obstruct justice
he also didn't commit perjury when he
denied it
according to the managers the general
language of this provision
of subpart 4
is supposed to include a wide range of
allegations so we've got some sub parts
of the subpart
but none of these allegations let me say
ladies and gentlemen of the senate none
of these were included or thought
sufficiently credible to be included in
the oic referral
nor were these allegations included in
mr shipper's initial presentation to the
judiciary committee
they're nothing more than an effort to
inflate the number of perjury
allegations
by converting every answer that the
president gave to the grand jury
about the subject matter of article 2
into a new count of perjury
it's the double
it's the double billing if you will
all of these allegations are more
properly part of our defense to the
obstruction of justice allegations
but i will try to respond briefly
to the allegations of perjury
his testimony about monica lewinsky's
false affidavit this grows out of the
president's conversation with ms
lewinsky allegedly on december 17th in
which he is said to have corruptly
encouraged ms lewinsky to execute a
sworn affidavit that he knew to be
perjurious false and misleading
in that famous late night telephone
conversation ms lewinsky asked the
president
what she could do if she were subpoenaed
in the jones case
according to ms lewinsky the president
responded well maybe you can sign an
affidavit that is what ms lewinsky's
recollection is
now in the grand jury the president was
repeatedly questioned about this about
this conversation
and he repeatedly answered emphatically
and this is another example where it's
not once it's not twice as three or four
times he truly thought he said that she
could have sworn out
an honest affidavit
the manager's claim that when he said
that that he thought that she could
swear out an honest affidavit that the
president perjured himself
now
the president's testimony in the grand
jury on this point is not in any way
cautious or qualified
he makes similar statements on four
different occasions during that
testimony
concluding with this statement
i've already told you that i felt
strongly
that she could issue that she could
execute an affidavit that would be
factually truthful
that might
get her out of having to testify
and did i hope she'd be able to get out
of testifying on an affidavit absolutely
did i want her to execute a false
affidavit no i did not
now the heart of the man the manager's
argument is that there was no way that
an honest affidavit could achieve what
the president miss lewinsky both wanted
to have achieved
which was to avoid her having to testify
and so the managers claimed the
president's statement that he thought
she could make out an honest affidavit
and avoid testifying in the jones case
about
her relationship with the president as
perjury
once again the president's claim the
president is guilty of perjury because
he is testifying falsely about a state
of mind it wasn't true they argue that
he really thought
that she could make out and sign and
execute an honest affidavit he couldn't
have thought that
he wanted and expected her to lie in
that affidavit and that's why he
suggested well you could always
file an affidavit
now miss lewinsky's inappropriate
contact with the president
was consensual
and an affidavit being saw in the case
involving sec allegations of sexual
harassment
that says
there was no harassment
no effort to impose unwanted sexual
overtures would have been some affidavit
an affidavit that ms lewinsky could
honestly execute
an affidavit stating that she had never
been
on the receiving end of any unwanted
sexual overtures from the president
and that she had never been harassed
second
both ms lewinsky and the president had a
definition of sexual relations that
would have allowed miss lewinsky in her
own mind honestly and accurately in
their view
to swear an affidavit
that she had never had
sexual relations meaning what she meant
in the exhibits we distributed with the
president
she would have thought that was
a factual and accurate affidavit and so
would the president
at that time third it is clear that ms
lewinsky understood
that it was not necessary to volunteer
information in an affidavit but on the
contrary she could try to give only that
small but true portion of the whole
story she talks about this at some
length in her telephone conversations
with
linda tripp in her words the goal of an
affidavit
is to be as benign as possible to avoid
being deposed
she's her own operator here she knows
what she's doing
please recognize what the managers are
trying to do here in article two
they accuse the president of obstructing
justice
by suggesting that ms lewinsky should
file an affidavit knowing full well
that the affidavit would have to be
false
and when the
when the president under oath in the
grand jury denies
that he believed that the affidavit
would have to be false they accuse him
of perjury
the two allegations are inextricably
intermingled
and if you conclude as you should that
there's no evidence to support the
underlying allegation
that the underlying offense is based on
nothing but pure conjecture you will
conclude that the perjury charge
is nothing more than an attempt to get
two bites at the same
apple
the second element is the president's
testimony about the gifts
the manager's trial brief says that the
president committed perjury
when he testified that he told ms
lewinsky
that if the jones lawyers requested the
gifts
that he had given to her she should
provide them
a typically the brief quotes the
president's precise language which is at
issue in this particular allegation
quote
and i told her that if they asked her
for gifts
she'd have to give them
whatever she had
that's what the law was
this testimony the manager's claim is
false they say
he never said that
and when he says he said it in the grand
jury he's guilty of perjury
now the only evidence offered to support
the allegation
that the president
testified falsely before the grand jury
on this topic is
a that ms lewinsky raised the question
with the president
as what she should do with the gifts
and you've heard a lot of testimony
about that which only establishes one
thing that the topic came up
and that is totally consistent with the
president's testimony and it has no
bearing whatsoever on whether the
president did or did not say
what he claims to have said
the second piece of evidence is that ms
curry ended up picking up the gifts and
taking them home with her
which no matter how you might try to
spin that simply cannot be construed
as evidence showing that the president
perjured himself when he told the grand
jury that he had given this advice to ms
lewinsky
it's tinker's to evers to chance
this allegation is all conjecture and
there's no evidence it is really
astonishing that the managers would
seriously include it
in their case kenneth starr did not
and it was not discussed or debated
by the house judiciary committee
the majority report makes another
entirely different allegation about this
matter
there the house republican site the
president's denial
this is a denial
not an affirmation the first had to do
with testimony in front of the grand
jury that he said something to monica
lewinsky the second has to do with the
denial that he ever instructed ms curry
to pick up the gifts
and from the transcript of the
president's grand jury testimony
i quote question
after you gave monica lewinsky the gifts
on december 28th
did you speak with your secretary ms
curry and ask her to pick up a box of
gifts
that were some compilation of gifts that
ms lewinsky would have answered no sir i
didn't do that
to give to miss lacurie a question to
give to ms curry answer i did not do
that
according to the majority report this
testimony was perjurious false and
misleading
the problem with this allegation is
similar to the problem with the previous
one only greater
in the first allegation there is no one
who testified
that the president did not say what he
testified under oath he said
and in this allegation there is no one
who testified
that the president said
what he testified under oath he did not
say
in other words the house managers offer
you this argument
nobody says the president made this
statement we just think he did
so we're charging charging him with
perjury for denying it
and you should remove him from office
despite the absence of evidence
again this was not included in the star
referral
and we wonder how this kind of an
allegation
could seriously be brought
against the president united states
the president's testimony about his
january 18th conversation with ms curry
the president's meeting and conversation
with betty curry on sunday january 18th
is a central element
in the allegation of obstruction set
forth in article 2 and you will hear
more about that from cheryl mills today
because the office of independent
council spent so much time
on this matter during president
clinton's grand jury testimony
they examined the president on this
topic at length on four separate
occasions
during that four hour session
it was inevitable that the managers
would find some way somehow to include
his testimony about this matter in
article one
parenthetically
this too is an allegation
that the office of independent counsel
did not make in its referral
so once again we begin with a question
what is it precisely that the president
said
that is at the heart of this allegation
of perjury
in his presentation last thursday
mr manager rogan quoted lengthy passages
from a number of president clinton's
answers on the subject
and finally he said this
i'm quoting mr manager rogan
when the president testified he was only
making statements to ms curry
to ascertain what the facts were
trying to ascertain what betty's
perception was this statement was false
and it was perjurious we know it was
perjury because the president called ms
curry into the white house the day after
his deposition to tell her not to ask
her to tell her that he was never alone
with monica lewinsky to tell her
that miss miss curry could always hear
or see them and to tell her that he
never touched monica lins lewinsky these
were false statements says mr rogan and
he knew that the statements were false
at the time he made them
to betty curry
but that's not true the president
clearly asked questions
as well as made declarative statements
and i confess
myself to some confusion
about what perjury congressman rogan is
really alleging here it seems to me that
he's moved from the world of perjury
which is my article one into the world
of obstruction which is cheryl's and
david's article two
the trial brief is more specific
they claim that the testimony was false
when the president went in and said that
he was trying to refresh his memory
about what the facts were
when he said that he wanted to know what
betty's memory was about what she heard
and when he said he was trying to get as
much information
as he could
the purpose of the meeting and the
conversation according to the trial
brief was to tamper with ms curry was to
influence her testimony not to gather
information
in truth
the president gave a number of different
reasons to the grand jury explaining a
number of different purposes for seeking
out betty curry and talking to her about
monica lewinsky
and it is totally plausible to conclude
that the last thing on the president
mind and the president's mind at that
particular moment given what was going
on in the previous 24 hours was betty
curry's potential role as a witness in
federal court
more simply
the fact that
in making this particular allegation
the managers have come up with two three
four different statements but by the
president that they claim are procurious
makes it a total distortion of the
president's answer
there were many questions many answers
and many reasons that he gave for
seeking out betty curry
kenneth kennestar made no such claim in
his referral
and finally
the president's testimony
about allegations that he influenced his
aides
to influence
he had misled his aides
let me let me get it right
the allegation is that when the
president testified in front of the
grand jury and denied that he misled his
aides or tested or told them false
things that it was perjurious faults and
misleading testimony because he was
really trying to use them
to
obstruct justice and influence the grand
jury
now the president testified in much
greater topic about his conversations in
much greater detail
about his conversations with his aides
than the managers suggest
and he never said that he only told them
true things
in fact if you look at that testimony
and i urge you to do so this is another
topic that will take up some time
the president acknowledged that he
misled his aides and he apologized for
it
and he testified that actually he
couldn't remember much of what he told
his aides he never challenged or not
denied
telling john podesta what mr podesta
said that he told him and told the grand
jury that he told him
and he never challenged sydney
blumenthal's version of what he said to
mr blumenthal
there is absolutely no evidence to
suggest that the president intended to
deceive the grand jury on this matter
because he never denied saying what they
said
he told them about
his relationship and that what he told
him was not just true things he told
them inaccurate things
he did not give the testimony that
congressman rogan claims that he gave
he did not say
that he didn't did not mislead his aides
he said that he had in he that he had in
fact mislead led his aides
he does say that he tried to tell
true things to them but he does not
conceal the nature of the true things
he's talking about
so you can make up your own mind whether
you agree with his characterization that
they're true things
he describes them for all to see and
understand
for example he told he says that he told
his aides quote i never had sex with her
as it was defined in his mind
now you may disagree with his
characterization of what he told them as
being a true thing but he certainly
doesn't conceal the basis of his belief
that it's true
he also says that he
is not
involved
with ms lewinsky in any sexual way and
he explains by use of the current of the
present tense
he thought that was a true thing
but the materiality of this alleged
perjury is really a mystery
that the president misled his aides is
not an issue that his aides became
witnesses
before the grand jury and that the
president knew they would probably be
called
is similarly not in dispute
nor does the president dispute the
testimony
of podesta and blumenthal
the only issue here is whether the
president when he discussed monica
lewinsky with these aides
was seeking to influence the grand
jury's proceedings by giving his aides
false information this is not a perjury
challenge this is a subject to be dealt
with in the context of article two and
an obstruction of justice
what does it all add up to
mr ruff had it right
beneath the surface of this article this
first article there really is a witch's
brew of allegation
pulled from all corners
of bill clinton's
grand jury testimony
he is alleged to have lied to the grand
jury when he used innocent words to tell
about his improper contacts with ms
lewinsky truly these are frivolous
allegations
he is alleged to have lied about the
date his improper activity with ms
lewinsky began
and whether it was preceded by any
period of friendship
these two are frivolous allegations
the president didn't say what they claim
he said
but even if he did the allegations are
of no import he is alleged to have lied
when he explained his understanding of
the jones definition
and testified that his genuine belief
was that the definition did not include
the activity that he and ms lewinsky had
engaged in experienced prosecutors say
that this interpretation was reasonable
he is alleged to have lied about the
intimate details of his activity with ms
lewinsky she says one thing he says
another this is precisely the kind of
oath against oath swearing match that is
never prosecuted in the real world
given the president's overall testimony
before the grand jury of what real
significance is this disagreement
he is accused of ratifying his every
sentence in the jones deposition
and by saying that his goal was to be
truthful he is said to have lied
but no one should be charged with
perjury for asserting his innocence or
for claiming that he was trying to be
truthful
particularly when all the evidence
supports his claim
and finally he is accused of lying about
a variety of actions aimed at concealing
his improper and embarrassing
relationship with ms lewinsky when each
one of those actions was motivated by
nothing more than a desire to protect
himself and his family from
embarrassment if not destruction
think just for a moment and ask yourself
if whether these allegations about this
testimony
is really an effort to vindicate the
rule of law
or is it something else
and ask yourself what coming generations
will think about these charges if you
convict and remove president clinton
on the basis of these allegations
no president of the united states will
ever be safe from impeachment again and
it will happen
and people will look back at us and they
will say
we should have stopped it then before it
was too late
don't let this happen to our country
before i conclude i'd like to respond to
one specific argument that we heard last
week one of the arguments most
frequently employed
to urge the president's removal is that
in the united states of america no one
is above the law
and if the senate does not take action
against the president convict him and
remove him from office we will not be
keeping faith with that principle
members of the senate i could not
disagree more with that formulation of
this issue
the principle that no one is above the
law is sacred
the idea that the wealthy or the
powerful or the famous
should receive preferential treatment
under the law
treatment that is different from that
accorded to the poor and the weak is
anathema to everything that is great and
good and special about the united states
it is anathema to our values and to our
national ideals i agree with mr hyde
our fathers and grandfathers
going back to the american revolution
fought and died to defend the principle
of equal justice under law
this principle is not only at the core
of anglo-saxon jurisprudence it is the
part is at the very foundation of our
civic society
but the framers
in their genius did not design or intend
the awesome power of impeachment and
removal
for the purpose of vindicating the rule
of law
they believe that the power of
impeachment and removal should be used
for a different purpose
to protect the body politic
to protect the government itself
from a president whose conduct was so
abusive
as to constitute an assault
a threat
to the entire system
we're all rereading the constitution
we're all looking at the federalist
papers again
and when we do that we realize that the
framers of the constitution considered
the question
of what to do
when the highest officials of government
the president or the vice president are
charged with misconduct
and back then they made an important
distinction that we should recognize and
respect today
between conduct and official capacity
and conduct in private capacity and they
created two different ways of dealing
with these two very different kinds of
conduct
impeachment was to protect the country
from abuse of official power
by an out-of-control president or by
someone
who is so abusive and assaultive on the
system of government that he had to be
removed to protect the government the
criminal justice system was to vindicate
the rule of law
and the clearest indication that one was
not meant to be a substitute for the
other
can be found in article 1 section 3
clause 7
of the constitution
judgment in cases of impeachment shall
not extend further than to removal from
office and disqualification to hold and
enjoy any office
of honor
trust or profit under the united states
but the party convicted shall
nevertheless be liable and subject to
indictment trial judgment and punishment
according to law
if the president's conduct in his
official capacity is so grave
as to be a serious assault upon the
system of government
so serious as to subvert
our constitutional order
so serious as to require the nation to
be protected
from the damage that he would do if he
were to continue in office
the remedy is impeachment and removal
by a political process if however the
president's conduct does not implicate
the office or the powers of the
presidency the remedy is in a legal
process involving prosecution conviction
and punishment in the courts
in this fashion the principle is
vindicated that no man
is above the law
for in the criminal justice system
the president will be treated like any
other citizen and accountable to the
rule of law
the great scholar
and justice james wilson said it best
when he wrote
far from being above the laws the
president is amenable to them
in his private character as a citizen
and in his public character by
impeachment
and more recently just last november
senator spector made the same point with
equal eloquence when he proposed quote
abandoning impeachment and after the
president leaves office
holding him accountable in the same way
any other person would be
through indictment and prosecution
for any federal crimes established by
the evidence
president clinton should not be above
the law
he is not above the law and he will not
be above the law
as senator specter rightly stated the
criminal justice system stands ready to
perform that function and to hold the
president accountable at some later date
and like any other citizen william
jefferson clinton can be prosecuted for
any crimes he is alleged to have
committed during his term of office
it would be a profound mistake with
lasting consequences for the members of
this body in the throes of a highly
charged impeachment trial
to conclude that only the senate rather
than the criminal justice system should
be the chosen instrument of the
constitution
to fulfill that principle
it is not up to the senate to remove the
president from office for private
conduct that does not involve abuse of
presidential power
and does not seriously disrupt the
president's capacity to function as
chief justice of the uh as chief
executive of the united states
and it would be falling to think that to
vindicate the rule of law in the united
states the senate is obliged to reverse
a national election and remove a
president from office before the
completion of his term
if there is sufficient evidence to warn
a criminal prosecution this president
when he returns to private life
can be indicted prosecuted tried and if
convicted punished like any other
citizen
i end by making a point that should
never be far from our thoughts as we
continue through this trial
there is no moment in our national life
more sacred than the ritual of casting
one's vote in a presidential election it
is amazing almost miraculous that so
powerful and transforming an event can
occur so quietly
in a great and populist nation
the act itself is invisible to outside
eyes on one designated day millions of
americans go to their local polling
places to schools fire houses police
stations and municipal buildings
throughout the nation to cast their vote
for president
it is a moment of high purpose
the only political act that we've
performed together as a nation
and so it is that we believe short of a
declaration of war there is nothing more
serious
for our elected representatives to
contemplate
than through the process of impeachment
to undo the result of a national
election
and to remove the man
chosen by the american people to be
their president
over the past week we've heard many
speeches about the constitution and the
rule of law
and the many sacrifices that the
american people have made
throughout their history
to defend their rights and their
freedoms
surely among the most important of those
rights and freedoms
is the right freely fairly and openly to
cast one's vote in a presidential
election and have the results of that
election
respected and obeyed
can anyone imagine
anything more damaging
to the constitution of the united states
than for a presidential election
to be reversed for conduct that the vast
majority of the american people does not
believe
warrants the president's removal from
office
in the entire history of the united
states
we have never been at this juncture
before
we have never come close
to the final act of removing an elected
president
than we are
at this moment in time
william jefferson clinton was elected
freely
fairly
and openly by the american people to be
president
we dare not reverse that decision
without good and just cause
and we dare not take that step
unless the people
who spoke
agree that such drastic action is
justified
the damage to our political discourse
for years
decades
would be terrible to contemplate
in the course of this impeachment
process we have also devoted a good deal
of time and attention to a discussion of
precedents that involve
the impeachment and removal of federal
judges
for the president we have argued that
when it comes to applying
constitutional standards for impeachment
judges are different
we think that the constitution
implicitly recognizes that distinction
i would like to change the focus for a
minute a moment
and look at the way that we think the
legislative branch of our government
also recognizes that distinction
history shows i think
that it has been easier for congress to
impeach and remove a federal judge from
office
than to discharge a member of the house
or the senate
and maybe that is as it should be
when confronted with misconduct by one
of its members congress has rarely been
willing
to negate the popular will
as expressed in congressional elections
in truth the congress has for the most
part
simply declined to take that step
perhaps rightly so
because of the greater deference paid to
elected as opposed to appointed official
officials or judges
perhaps because presidents and senators
and representatives are periodically
elected
to define terms as opposed to life terms
the congress has chosen to rely upon the
public
to work its will through the electoral
system
that deference is warranted i submit
and it should be a factor in your
deliberations
in 210 years of history and throughout
105 congresses
only four members of the house
have ever been expelled by that body as
for the senate 15 senators the first in
1797 the remaining 14 during the civil
war
my point is a simple one
because of the sanctity of elections and
the regularity of elections and because
of the heavy burden that must be carried
before reversing the will of the people
decisions to remove elected office
holders have been and should be
at least in some degree
based on factors that are different than
the ones used for judges appointed to
life for life and who serve for good
behavior
by its own conduct throughout its own
history
congress seems to agree with this point
i come from the state of vermont and if
you've been to vermont you know that
wherever you go across that state from
the smaller squares
in the smallest towns the larger parks
and what we like to think of as our
cities
you come across monuments
celebrating the american union
one of the things that vermont children
learn first
is that we were and are the 14th state
of the union
and that for our
our forebears fought to create this
nation and to preserve it
so we in our history have shown that
there are two things that we care about
we care about our american union and we
care about equal rights for all citizens
under the law
and one of the rights that is most
precious to every american is the right
to choose our leaders in free elections
that right
the equal right to vote with confidence
that the outcome will be respected is
fundamental to our values to our
national unity and identity
ladies and gentlemen of the senate you
must do your duty as you see it
as you see the law and the facts and the
evidence
but truly these articles do not justify
the nullification of the american
people's free choice in a national
election
i appeal to you do not turn your back on
those millions of americans
who cast their votes in the belief that
they
and they alone
decide who will lead this country
as president
do not throw our politics into the
darkness of endless recrimination
do not inject a poison of bitter
partisanship
into the body politic which like a
virus can move through our national
bloodstream for years to come
with results none can know or calculate
do not let this case and these charges
as flawed and as unfair as they are
destroy a fundamental underpinning of
american democracy the right of the
people and no one else
to select the president of the united
states william jefferson clinton is not
guilty of obstruction of justice he is
not guilty of perjury he must not be
removed thank you very much
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice uh i ask you to have
some consent that we recess the
proceedings now we will begin promptly
at five minutes after four without
objection it's so ordered
thinking about how are the children will
be in order chair recognize the majority
leader mr chief justice i believe we're
ready to resume uh to and go to the
presentation
mr council met at ms council cheryl
mills
chair recognizes miss council mills
mr chief justice managers from the house
of representatives
members of the senate
good afternoon
my name is cheryl mills and i am deputy
counsel to the president
i am honored to be here today
on behalf of the president to address
you
today incidentally marks my six-year
anniversary in the white house
i'm very proud to have had the
opportunity
to serve our country
and this president
it is a particular honor for me to stand
on the senate floor today
i'm an army brat
my father served in the army for 27
years
i grew up in a military world where
opportunity was not just where
opportunity was a reality and not just a
slogan
the very fact that the daughter of an
army officer from richmond virginia
the very fact that i can represent the
president of the united states
on the floor of the senate of the united
states
is powerful proof
that the american dream
lives
i'm going to take some time to address
two of the allegations of obstruction of
justice
against president clinton in article two
first the allegation related to the box
of gifts that ms lewinsky asked ms curry
to hold for her
second
the allegation related to the
president's conversation
with ms curry after his deposition in
the jones case
tomorrow my colleague mr kendall will
address the remaining
allegations of obstruction of justice
over the course of the house manager's
presentation last week
i confess i was struck
by how often
they referred to the significance of the
rule of law
house manager sensing brenner for
example quoted president theodore
roosevelt
stating no man is above the law
and no man is below it
as a lawyer
as an american and as an african
american
it is a principle in which i believe to
the very core
of my being
it is what many have struggled and died
for the right to be equal before the law
without regard to race or gender or
ethnicity
disability
privilege or station in life
the rule of law applies to the weak and
the strong the rich and the poor
the powerful
and the powerless
if you love the rule of law
you must love it in all of its
applications
you cannot only love it when it provides
the verdict you seek
you must love it when the verdict goes
against you as well
we cannot uphold the rule of law only
when it is consistent with our beliefs
we must uphold it even when it protects
behavior that we don't like
or is unattractive
or is not admirable
or that might even be
hurtful
and we cannot say we love the rule of
law
but dismiss arguments that appeal to the
rule of law
as legalisms
or legal hair splitting
i say all this because
not only the facts
but the law
of obstruction of justice protects
the president
it does not
condemn him
and the managers cannot deny the
president the protection that is
provided by the law and still insist
that they are acting to uphold the law
his conduct while clearly not attractive
or admirable
is
not criminal
that is the rule of law in this case
so as my colleagues and i discuss
obstruction of justice against the
president
we ask only that the rule of law be
applied equally
neutrally
fairly
not emotionally
or personally
or politically
if it is applied equally the rule of law
exonerates bill
clinton
that said i want to begin where manager
hutchinson left off this weekend during
a television program
the evidence does not support
conviction of the president on any of
the allegations of obstruction of
justice
on the record now before the senate
and that which was before the house
manager hutchinson said i don't think
you could obtain a conviction or that i
could fairly
ask for a conviction
we agree
we agree
there are good reasons for manager
hutchinson's judgment
the most important
the evidence in the record and the law
on the books
does not support the conclusion that the
president obstructed justice
now i know that manager mccullen begged
you in his presentation not to pay
attention to the details when the
president's case
was put forward
he went so far as to implore you not to
get hung up on some of the details when
the president and his attorneys try to
explain this stuff the big picture
is what you need to keep in mind
not the compartmentalization
manager mccollum was telling you
in effect
not to pay attention to the evidence
that exonerates the president
don't pay attention to the details that
take this case out of the realm of
activities that are prohibited by the
law
but the rule of law depends upon the
details
because it depends upon the facts
and it depends upon the fairness of the
persons called to judge the facts
i want to walk through the big picture
and i want to walk through the facts
i first want to discuss the real story
and then i want to focus on all those
inconvenient details or what manager
boyer called those stubborn facts
that don't fit the big picture
that the house managers
want you to see
manager bar suggested that the fit
between the facts and the law against
the president in this case is as precise
as the finely tuned mechanism
of a swiss watch
but when you put the facts together
they don't quite make out a swiss watch
in fact they might not even make good
sausage
so what is the big picture
the big picture is this
the president had a relationship with a
young woman
his conduct was inappropriate
but it was not obstruction of justice
during the course of their relationship
the president and the young woman
pledged not to talk about it with others
that is not obstruction of justice
the president ended their relationship
before anyone knew about it he ended it
not because he thought it would place
him in legal jeopardy
he ended it because he knew it was wrong
that is not obstruction of justice
the president hoped that no one would
find out about his indiscretion about
his lapse
in judgment
that is not obstruction of justice
either
one day however long after he had ended
the relationship he was asked about it
in an unrelated lawsuit a lawsuit whose
intent at least as proclaimed by those
who were pursuing it
was to politically damage him
that was their publicly announced goal
so he knew
the president knew
that a secret
would soon be exposed
and he was right
it was revealed for public consumption
writ large all over the world against
his best efforts to have ended the
relationship and to have put right
what he had done wrong
that is the real big picture
that is the truth
and that is not obstruction of justice
so let's talk about the allegation of
obstruction of justice about the box of
gifts that ms curry
received from ms lewinsky
i want to begin by telling you another
true story
the real story of the now famous
gifts
it takes place on december 28 1997.
on that day the president gave ms
lewenski holiday gifts
during her visit with the president ms
lewinsky has said that she raised the
subpoena that she had received from the
jones lawyers on the 19th and asked him
what should she do about the gifts
the president has said he told her
whenever it was that they discussed it
that she would have to give over
whatever she had
he was not concerned about the gifts
because he gives so many gifts to so
many people
unbeknownst to the president however ms
lewinsky had been worrying about what to
do with the gifts every since she got
the subpoena she was concerned that the
jones lawyers might even search her
apartment
so she wanted to get the gifts
out of her home
after ms lewinsky's visit with the
president ms curry walked her from the
building then or later either in person
or on the phone ms lewinsky told ms
curry that she had a box of gifts that
the president had given her that she
wanted miss curry to hold
because people were asking
questions
in the course of that conversation they
discussed other things as well and ms
curry agreed to hold the box of gifts
after their discussion ms lewinsky
packed up some but not all of the gifts
that the president
had given her over time
she kept out presence of particular
sentimental value as well as virtually
all of the gifts he had given her that
very day on the 28th
ms curry went home went by ms lewinsky's
home after leaving work picked up the
box which had a note on it that said do
not throw away and she took it home
miss curry did not raise ms lewinsky's
request with the president
because she saw herself as doing a favor
for her friend
ms curry had no idea
the gifts were under subpoena
and so ms lewency's request hardly
struck her as criminal
this story
that i just told you
is obviously very different from the
story presented by the house managers
how can i tell such a story that is so
at odds
with that which has been presented by
the house managers
the answer lies in the selective reading
of the record by the house managers
but theirs is not the only version of
the facts that can be told
so what details did they downplay
or discard
or disregard in their presentation to
create allegations of obstruction of
justice
to be fair
the house manager's house managers
acknowledge upfront
that their case is largely
circumstantial
they are right
let's walk through the house manager's
presentation of the key events
which they gave to you last week
let's look at exhibit one which is in
the packets that have been handed out to
you
first key fact on december 19th monica
lewinsky was served with a subpoena in
the paula jones case
the subpoena required her to testify at
a deposition
in january 1998 and also to produce each
and every gift
given to her by president clinton
second event on december 28th ms
lewinsky and the president met in the
oval office to exchange christmas gifts
at which time they discussed the fact
that the lawyers in the jones case had
subpoenaed all of the president's gifts
third key fact
during the during the conversation on
the 28th ms lewinsky asked the president
whether she should put away outside of
her home or give to someone maybe betty
the gifts at that time according to ms
lewinsky the president responded let me
think about it
fourth fact they presented to you
that answer led to action later that day
ms lewinsky got a call at 3 32 pm from
ms curry who said i understand you have
something to give me or that the
president has said you have something
for me it was the president who
initiated the retrieval of the gifts and
the concealment of the evidence
fifth event they presented without
asking any questions ms curry picked up
the box of gifts from ms lewinsky drove
to her home and placed the box under her
bed
that is what the house managers told you
last week
now let's go through their story piece
by piece
on december 19th monica lewinsky was
served with a subpoena in the jones case
the subpoena required her to testify at
a deposition in january 1998 and also to
produce each and every gift given to her
by the president
this statement is factually accurate
it does not however convey the entire
state of affairs
ms lewinsky told the fbi that when she
got the subpoena
she wanted the gifts out of her
apartment
why
because she suspected that lawyers for
jones would break into her apartment
looking for gifts
she was also concerned the jones people
might tap her phone
therefore she wanted to put the gifts
out of reach of the jones lawyers out of
harm's way
the managers entirely disregarded ms
lewinsky's own independent motivations
for wanting to move the gifts
let's continue
on nov on december 28 1997 ms lewinsky
and the president met in the oval office
to exchange christmas gifts at which
time they discussed the fact that the
lawyers in the jones case had subpoenaed
all the gifts from the president to ms
lewinsky
during the course during the
conversation on december 28th ms
lewinsky asked the president whether she
should put away the gifts outside of her
house someplace or give them to someone
maybe betty
at that time according to ms lewinsky
the president said
let me think about
it the house managers have consistently
described the december 28th meeting
exactly this way
as did the majority council for the
house judiciary as did the office of
independent council
it's been said so often that it's become
conventional wisdom
but it is not
it is not the whole truth
it is not the full record
lewinsky actually gave
10
renditions of her conversation with the
president
all of them have been outlined in our
trial brief
invariably the one most cited is the one
least favorable to the president
but even in that version the one that is
least favorable to the president no one
claims he ordered
suggested or even hinted
that anyone obstruct justice
at most the president says
let me think about it
that is not obstruction of justice
but what about the nine other versions
some of the other versions which i have
never heard offered by the house
managers
versions that maybe you too have never
heard
are the ones that put the lie
to the obstruction of justice allegation
let's look at exhibit two which is in
your materials
you may have never heard for example
this version of their conversation and
this is ms lewinsky speaking
it was december 28th
and i was there to get my christmas
gifts from him
and we spent maybe about five minutes or
so not very long talking about the case
and i said to him well do you think i
should i don't think i said get rid of
i said but do you think i should put
away
or maybe give to betty or give to
someone the gifts
and he
i don't remember his response
it was something like
i don't know
or hmm
or there was really no response
you also may not have heard this version
and this is a juror speaking a grand
juror speaking to ms lewinsky the juror
now did you bring up betty's name
or did the president bring up betty's
name and this is at the meeting on the
28th
ms lewinsky
i think i brought it up
the president wouldn't have brought up
betty's name because he didn't
he really didn't discuss it
and you probably have not heard this
version
lewinsky advised that clinton was
sitting in a rocking chair in the study
lewinsky asked clinton what they should
do with the gifts clinton had given her
and he either did not respond or
responded i don't know
lewinsky is not sure exactly what was
said but she is certain that whatever
clinton said she had no clear image in
her mind
of what to do next
why haven't we heard
these versions
because they weaken
an already fragile
circumstantial case
if ms lewinsky says that the president
didn't respond at all
then there's absolutely no evidence for
the house manager's objection
obstruction of justice theory even under
their version
of events
so these versions get discarded to
ensure that the house manager's big
picture
doesn't get cluttered
by all those details
it's those facts
those stubborn facts that just don't fit
but the most significant detail the
managers discard because it doesn't fit
is the president's testimony
the president testified that he told ms
lewinsky that she had to give the jones
lawyers whatever gifts she had
why as the house managers predicted we
would ask because it is a question that
begs to be asked
why would the president give ms lewinsky
gifts
if he wanted her to give them right back
the only real explanation
is he truly was as he testified
unconcerned about the gifts
the house managers want you to believe
that this gift-giving was a show of
confidence that he knew ms lewinsky
would conceal them
but then why
under their theory asked miss curry to
go pick them up
why not
know that miss lewinsky is just going to
conceal them
better still better still why not just
show her the gifts
and tell her to come by after the
subpoena date has passed
it simply doesn't make sense
the president's actions entirely
undermine
the house manager's theory of
obstruction of justice
but let's continue with their version of
events
that answer the let me think about it
answer that answer led to action later
that day ms lewinsky got a call at 3 30
p.m 3 32 p.m for ms curry who said i
understand you have something to give me
or the president said you have something
to give me it was the president who
initiated the retrieval of the gifts and
the concealment of the evidence
here is where the house managers have
dramatically
shortchanged the truth
because the whole truth demands that ms
curry's testimony be presented fairly
and telling their story the house
managers do concede that there is a
conflict in the testimony between ms
lewinsky and miss curry but they strive
mightily
they strive mightily to get you to
disregard
miss curry's testimony by telling you
that her memory on the issue
of how she came to pick up the gifts
was fuzzy
fuzzy
in particular manager hutchinson told
you i will concede there is a conflict
in the testimony on this point with miss
curry miss curry and her grand jury
testimony had a fuzzy memory a little
different recollection she testified
that the best she can remember ms
lewinsky called her but when she was
asked further she said that maybe ms
lewinsky's memory is better than hers on
that issue
that's what the house managers want you
to believe
about miss curry
that's not playing fair by miss curry
it's not playing fair by the facts
why
because miss curry was asked about who
initiated the gift pickup
five times
her answer each time was unequivocal
five times
from the first
fbi interview just days after the story
broke in the media
to her last grand jury appearance ms
curry repeatedly and unwaveringly
testify that it was ms lewinsky who
contacted her
about the gifts
her memory on this issue
is clear
what does she say
let's look at exhibit three
the first time she's asked
but once he called curry in advice she
had to return all gifts clinton had
given to lewinsky as there was talk
going around about the gifts
second time monica said she was getting
concerned and she wanted to give me the
stuff the president had given her or
give me a box of stuff it was a box of
stuff
third time and this is a gran this was a
prosecutor asking miss curry the
questions just tell us for a moment how
this issue first arose and what you did
about it and what ms lewinsky told you
ms curry the best i remember at first
were rose with conversation i don't know
if it was over the phone or in person
i'm not i don't know she asked me if i
would pick up a box she said izakov had
been inquiring about the gifts
fourth time
the best i remember she said she wanted
me to hold these gifts hold this she may
have said gifts i'm sure she said gifts
box of gifts i don't remember because
people were asking questions and i said
fine
fifth time
the best i remember is monica calls me
and asked me if she can give me some
gifts
if i'd pick up some gifts for her
indeed the last time the fifth time when
a grand juror completely misstated miss
curry's testimony regarding how the gift
exchange was initiated by suggesting
that the president had directed her to
pick up the gifts
ms curry was quick to correct
the juror
this is a grand juror speaking ms curry
i want to come back for a second to the
box of gifts and how they came to be in
your possession as i recall your earlier
testimony the other days you testified
that the president asked you to
telephone ms lewinsky is that correct
pardon
the president asked me to telephone ms
lewinsky
the juror is that correct
miss curry about
the juror about the box of gifts i'm
trying to recall and understand exactly
how the box of gifts came to be in your
possession possession miss curry i don't
recall the president asking me to call
about a box of gifts
the juror
how did you come to be in possession of
the box of gifts miss curry the best i
remember ms lewinsky calls me and asked
me if she can give me some gifts if i'd
pick up some gifts for her the record
reflects
that ms curry's testimony on this issue
was clear
five times
every time she was asked
what then are the managers talking about
when they say that ms curry concedes
that ms lewinsky might have a better
memory than herself on this issue
they're talking about something a little
different
that was whether she miss curry had told
the president that she had picked up the
box of gifts from liz ms lewinsky
let's put it in context
after being asked the same question for
the fourth time and reiterating for the
fourth time that ms lewinsky contacted
her about the gifts the prosecutor asked
miss curry well what if miss lewinsky
said that miss curry spoke to the
president about receiving the gifts from
ms lewinsky
ms
curry responds then she may remember
better than i i don't remember
not once did ms curry equivocate on the
central fact
ms lewinsky asked her to retrieve the
gifts
the president testified consistent with
ms curry's testimony that he never asked
ms curry to retrieve the gifts from ms
lewinsky
so why is ms curry's testimony distorted
and discounted by the house managers
they are asking you to make one of the
most awesome decisions the constitution
contemplates
they owe you
they owe the president
they owe the constitution
they owe betty curry
an accurate presentation of the facts
but what about that supposedly
corroborating cell phone call from betty
curry to monica lewinsky on december
28th
the managers highlighted this call which
they claim is the call in which ms curry
told ms lewinsky that she understood she
had something for her the gifts
this they say is the lynchpin that
closes the deal on their version of the
facts
what the manager's downplay as mr ruff
discussed yesterday is the fact that
this call to arrange the pickup of the
gift comes after the time ms lewinsky
repeatedly testified that the gifts were
picked up by ms curry
inciting the cell phone record as
cooperation they also disregard ms
curry's testimony that she picked up the
gifts leaving from work on her way home
that would have been from washington to
arlington that is inconsistent with a
call from arlington
most significantly the managers
purposely avoided telling you about the
length of the call
as mr ruff pointed out yesterday the
call is for one minute
or less
according to ms lewinsky's own testimony
when she spoke to ms curry to arrange
the gift pickup
they talked about other matters as well
as the box
they had a conversation
that's a lot of talk i have a box
when can you come pick it up
where do you want me to meet you
other chit chat
that's a lot of talk for a call that
lasts one minute or less
it's all but inconceivable
that all this took place on the call
since miss lewinsky since ms curry
placed a call to ms lewinsky though the
house managers want you to believe that
what next
the house managers told you without
asking any question ms curry picked up
the box of gifts from ms lewinsky
drove to her home which incidentally is
inconsistent with their theory because
she's going the wrong direction she's
supposed to be going to the hospital if
she picked up the gift in their theory
and place the box under her bed
then they posit this question
why would miss curry pick up the gifts
from ms lewinsky why on earth
would she do such a thing
their answer
she must have been ordered to pick up
the gifts by the president they conclude
without any testimonial support
that there would be no reason for betty
curry out of the blue to retrieve the
gifts unless instructed to do so by the
presidents
why else would she do it
well the record
before you offers the answer
as miss curry told the fbi during her
very first interview in january 1998
ms lewinsky
was a friend
she had been helpful and supportive when
she was dealing with some very painful
personal tragedies
ms curry enjoyed what she saw as a
motherly relationship with ms lewinsky
they would often talk about each other's
families
about their own activities
and other chit chat
why does she agree to hold the box of
gifts for ms lewinsky
because she's a friend
and that
is not obstruction of justice
now think about the story as i told it
to you
and about the different story the
managers presented
ms lewinsky was concerned about the
gifts after receiving a subpoena from
the jones lawyers
she was worried they might search her
apartment
and she wanted to get the gifts out of
her home
she met with the president and what does
he do
he gives her more gifts
more gifts
when she asks what to do about the gifts
at most he says
let me think about it though miss
lewinsky has acknowledged on several
occasions that he may have said
nothing
ms lewinsky is still concerned about the
gifts
she decides to put them away
keeping the gifts that have sentimental
value giving over to the lawyer to her
lawyer the gift she thinks that the
jones lawyers are looking for and giving
to ms curry those items that she'd
really like back
but that she can live without
she tells ms curry that she has some
gifts from the president that she wants
her to hold because there's talk going
around about the gifts
miss curry picks them up after leaving
work on her way home
this story is consistent with the
president's lack of concern about the
gifts
the managers have tried to deflect the
inexplicable contradiction created by
their own theory
they want you to believe the president
would really give ms lewinsky gifts
only to take them back the very same day
but of course he wouldn't
no one would
the only explanation they can conjure is
tortured
the president gave her gifts he intended
to take back that same afternoon to show
his confidence that she would conceal
the relationship
the facts
clearly do not support
their version of events
to believe the manager's version of
event of events you must not only
disbelieve the president you must also
disbelieve miss curry
miss curry has said that the president
did not ask her to pick up the gifts
miss curry has said that ms lewinsky
asked her to pick up the gifts
so the managers have downplayed miss
curry's credibility
in this instance
they have urged you to think of her as
acting as quote a loyal secretary to the
president
of course she's loyal
but it is may i say an insult to betty
curry
and to millions of other loyal americans
to suggest that loyalty
breeds dishonesty
if miss curry was
dishonest why would she have told the
independent council
about the conversation between the
president and her that the managers have
recounted as being so damaging
why would she have said anything at all
about that conversation
why
because she is honest
and loyalty and honesty are not mutually
exclusive
betty curry is a loyal person
and betty curry is an honest person
these are the facts
that is not obstruction of justice
i believe
i can best sum up by using the words of
manager boyer
who quoted president john adams
facts are stubborn things
whatever may be our wishes our
inclinations or the dictates of our
passions they cannot alter the state of
the facts and the evidence
those stubborn facts
manager boyer went on to say
i believe john adams was right
facts and evidence facts are stubborn
things you can color the facts
like calling miss curry's memory fuzzy
you can shade the facts
by not telling you the length of that
supposed corroborating phone call
you can misrepresent the facts
by giving only one of ten versions of ms
lewinsky's testimony about the
president's response
to her question about the gifts
you can hide the facts like not telling
you of ms lewinsky's personal
motivations for wanting to move the
gifts
but the truthful facts are stubborn
they won't go away like the tell-tale
heart
they keep pounding
and they keep coming
they won't go away
those stubborn stubborn facts
they show
that this
was not
obstruction of justice
i now want to talk about the president's
conversation with miss curry on january
18th
it is not difficult to understand these
events if you have lived a life in which
you are the subject of extraordinary
media attention
extraordinary media scrutiny
most american lives are not like that
our jobs and our personal lives are not
usually
a subject for daily media consumption
as senators you obviously know well what
that life is like on january 18th the
president talked to miss curry about the
jones deposition and in particular about
his surprise at some of the questions
the jones lawyers had asked about ms
lewinsky
in the course of their conversation the
president asked ms curry a series of
questions and made some statements about
his relationship with ms lewinsky all of
which seemed to seek her concurrence
or reaction or her input
the manager's theory is that the
president
by his comments corruptly tried to
influence miss curry's potential
testimony in the jones case in violation
of the obstruction of justice laws
they acknowledge that the president knew
nothing about the independent council's
investigation so they have focused on
the jones case
as the place to lodge their obstruction
of justice allegation
but miss curry was not scheduled to be a
witness in that case
and as you will see the president had
other things on his mind that sunday
before i go through the facts
surrounding these conversations i wanted
to focus focus briefly on the law
as the manager stated in their
presentation there are two relevant
obstruction of justice statutes 18 usc
1503 which is the general obstruction of
justice statute and 18 usc 1512. the
more specific statute which prohibits
witnesses witness tampering
there are differences between the two
statutes but for our purposes their
essential elements are similar
both require the government to prove
that the person being accused
one acted knowingly
two
with specific intent
three
to corruptly
effect and its influence in 1503 and
corruptly persuade in 1512
either the due administration of justice
under 1503
or the testimony of a person in an
official proceeding under 1512 to try
and persuade the testimony of any person
in an official proceeding
for conviction each and every element
must be
proven beyond a reasonable doubt
if the prosecution fails to prove even
one element
a jury is obliged to acquit
in this case
none of the elements are present
first a little more about the law
you have to do more than make false
statements to someone who might or might
not testify in a judicial proceeding to
obstruct justice
in united states viagra an opinion
written by mr chief justice rehnquist
and quoted by the house managers the
supreme court addressed the government's
require that it showed that the
defendant knew his actions were likely
to affect a judicial proceeding
there a united states district court
judge was accused and convicted of lying
to fbi agents about his conversations
with another judge and about what he
said about his knowledge of some
wiretaps
the supreme court reversed his
conviction under 1503 the general
obstruction of justice statute holding
that the facts were insufficient to make
the case
they said and this is in your materials
we do not believe that uttering false
statements to an investigative agent and
that seems to be all that is proved here
who might or might not testify before a
grand jury is sufficient to make out a
violation of the catch-all provision of
1503
what use will be made of false testimony
given to an investigative agent who has
not been subpoenaed or otherwise
directed to appear before the grand jury
is
speculative we think it cannot be said
to have the natural and probable effect
of interfering with the due
administration of justice
in responding to the dissent criticism
of the court's holding mr chief justice
rehnquist wrote
under the defense under this dissents
theory
a man could be found guilty of violating
1503 if he knew of a pending
investigation
and lied to his wife about his
whereabouts at the time of the crime
thinking that an fbi agent might decide
to interview her and that she might in
turn be influenced in her statements to
that agent by her husband's false
accounts of where he was
the intent to obstruct justice is indeed
present but the man's culpability is a
good deal less clear from the statute
than we would usually
require in order to impose criminal
liability
so i want to begin by focusing on
the corruptly persuaded element of
witness tampering what does it mean to
corruptly persuade
the term is vague and the legislative
history on this specific point
is not very clear
we do know it means more than harassing
which is described as badgering or
pestering conduct since 1512 makes
intentional harassment a misdemeanor
a lesser offense of corruptly persuade
which is a felony
the us attorney's manual gives some
guidance
a prosecution under 1512 would require
the government to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt one an effort to
threaten force or intimidate another
person and to
an intent to influence the person's
testimony
thus corruptly persuade for career
prosecutors requires some element of
threat
or intimidation
or pressure
keeping that overview in mind let's look
at the facts
on january 17 1998 the president called
miss curry after his deposition and
asked her to meet with him the following
day
on january 18th the president and ms
curry met and the president told her
about some of those surprising questions
he had been asked in his deposition
about ms lewinsky
in the course of their conversation
according to ms curry the president
posed a series of questions and made
statements including you are always
there when she was there right we were
never really alone you could see and
hear everything
monica came on to me and i never touched
her right
and she wanted to have sex with me and i
can't do that
our analysis of this issue
could stop
here
there is no case for obstruction of
justice
why
there is no evidence whatsoever
of any kind of threat
or intimidation
and as we discussed the u.s attorney's
manual indicates that without a threat
or intimidation
there is no corrupt influence
without corrupt influence there is no
obstruction of justice
but the evidence reveals
much more
not only does the record lack any
evidence of threat or intimidation the
record specifically contains ms curry's
undisputed testimony which exonerates
the president of this charge
this is ms curry's testimony and is the
fourth exhibit in your materials
question to miss curry now back again to
the four statements that you testified
the president made to you that were
presented as statements did you feel you
were pressured
when he told you those statements
none
whatsoever question well what did you
think or what was going through your
mind about what he was doing
miss curry at the time i felt he was i
want to use the word shocked or
surprised that this was an issue and he
was just talking
question
that was your impression that he wanted
you to say because he would end each of
the statements with right with a
question
ms curry i do not remember that he
wanted me to say right
he would say right and i could have said
wrong
question
but he would put each of these questions
to you with a right and you could either
say it was true or not true
correct
did you feel any pressure to agree with
your boss
none
the evidence on this issue is clear
there was no effort to intimidate or
pressure miss curry
and she testified that she did not feel
pressured
betty curry's testimony unequivocally
establishes that the manager's case
lacks any element of threat
or intimidation
there is no evidence direct or
circumstantial that refutes this
testimony this is not
obstruction of justice
but let's not stop there let's look at
the intent element of the obstruction of
justice laws in other words whether the
president had the intent to influence ms
curry's supposed testimony or potential
testimony
in an attempt to satisfy this element of
the law the managers overreached in
their presentation to create the
appearance that the president had the
necessary specific intent
they argued that based upon the way he
answered the questions in the jones
deposition
he purposely referred to ms curry in the
hopes that the jones lawyers would call
her
as a corroborating witness
therefore according to their theory he
had the specific intent
the facts belie they're over reaching
the house manager suggested to you that
the president increased the likelihood
that ms curry would be called as a
witness by challenging the plaintiff's
attorney to question ms curry
a review of the transcript however shows
that the president's few references to
ms curry were neither forced or
needlessly interposed
they were natural appropriate
they were responsive
indeed the only occasion when he
suggested that the jones lawyer speak to
miss curry
is when they asked if it was typical for
miss curry to be in the white house
after midnight
he understandably said you have to ask
her
hardly a challenge
it's a reasonable response to an inquiry
about someone else's activities
the manager's conjecture about the
president's state of mind however fails
on an even more basic level
if you believe the manager theory if you
believe that the president went to great
lengths to hide his relationship with ms
lewinsky then why on earth would he want
miss curry to be a witness
in the jones case
if there was one person who knew the
extent of his contacts with ms lewinsky
it was miss curry
while she did not know the nature of his
relationship with ms lewinsky ms curry
did know
and would have testified to
ms lewinsky's visits in 1997 the notes
and messages that ms lewinsky sent the
president the gifts that ms lewinsky
sent the president and the president's
support of her efforts to get miss
lewinsky a job
with just that information it would have
only been a matter of time before the
jones lawyers discovered the
relationship
not that they needed miss curry's
testimony
they didn't need it for any of this
this trip was already on the december 5
1997 witness list and she was already
scheduled for a deposition
so why would the president want her to
testify
the answer is simple
he didn't
the president was not thinking about ms
curry becoming a witness in the jones
case
indeed she's the last person the
president would have wanted the jones
lawyers to question
and even if the jones lawyers had wanted
to question ms curry it's highly
unlikely they would have been allowed to
do so given the posture of the case at
that time
judge wright ordered the parties in
august of 1997
to exchange names and addresses of all
witnesses no later than december 5 1997.
miss curry was not on their final
witness list
moreover the cut-off date for all the
discovery was january 30th
by the time the president's deposition
was over
it was really too late to call miss
curry as a witness
finally you need to remember that in the
context of the jones case ms curry was
at best a peripheral witness on a
collateral matter that the court
ultimately determined was not essential
to the core
issues in the case
she had only knowledge of a small aspect
of a much larger case
all the more reason not to view her
as a potential witness
the president was not thinking about
miss curry becoming a witness in the
jones case
so what was the president thinking
the president explained to the grand
jury why he spoke to miss curry after
the deposition
it had nothing to do with miss curry
being a potential witness
that was not his concern
the president was concerned
that his secret was going to be exposed
and the media would relentlessly inquire
until the entire story
and every shameful detail
was public
the president's concern was heightened
by an internet report that morning that
he spoke to betty which alluded to ms
lewinsky and to miss curry and to issues
that the jones lawyers had raised
the president was understandably
concerned about media inquiries
a concern everyone who lives and serves
in public eye
likely can understand
trying to prepare for what he saw as the
inevitable media attention he talked to
ms curry to see what her perceptions
were and what she recalled
he talked to her to see what she knew
remember some of the questions that the
jones lawyers asked the president were
so off base for example they asked him
about visits from ms lewinsky between
midnight and 6 a.m where ms curry
supposedly cleared her in
the president wanted to know whether or
not ms curry agreed with his perception
or whether she had a different view
whether she agreed that ms lewinsky was
cleared in when he was present or
whether there may have been other
occasions that he didn't know about
he also wanted to assess ms curry's
perception of the relationship
he knew
the first person who would be questioned
about media accounts particularly given
that she was in the internet report
was going to be miss curry
the house managers did the president a
disservice in suggesting in his in the
end that his five pages of testimony
about why he spoke to miss curry
ultimately amounts to a forward sound
bite of to refresh his recollection
he obviously said a lot more
why did they say that
because they needed to establish intent
intent
and the testimony and the facts do not
show intent
that is the truth
that is all of the facts
the president's intent was never to
obstruct justice in the jones case
it was to manage a looming media
firestorm which he correctly foresaw
as the president told the grand jury
i was trying to get the facts
and trying to think of the best defense
we could construct
and the face of what i thought was going
to be
a media
onslaught
he was thinking about the media
that is the big picture
that is not
obstruction of justice
in the end of course you must make your
own judgments about whether the managers
have made a case for convicting the
president of obstructing justice on
either of these allegations
we believe they have not because the
facts
those stubborn facts
don't support the allegations
neither does the rule of law
we are not alone in that conclusion
we want to share with you some of the
remarks from a bipartisan panel of
prosecutors who spoke through the house
judiciary panel
some of which you saw earlier with mr
craig
i've taken a very brief clip of their
testimony that dealt with allegations of
obstruction of justice against the
president though as you will see then
representative and now senator schumer
focused in on one of the two allegations
that i addressed today
mrs curry
testified
that
uh
she
uh did not feel that the president came
and asked her some questions in a
leading fashion was this right is this
raise this right after his deposition
was taken in the jones case
and
she testified that she did not feel
pressured to agree with him and that she
believed his statements were correct and
agreed with him he
the quote is he would say right and i
could have said wrong now that is not a
case for obstruction of justice it is
very common for lawyers
before the witness gets understand
saying now you're going to say this
you're going to say this you're going to
say this now it doesn't make a
difference if you got two participants
to an event and you tried to to nail it
down well if you agree with that with
the curry uh
the curry
and and on the other two
the lewinsky parts of this
i think is there i mean i don't even
understand
how
they could how star could think that he
would have a case
not with a president of the united
states but with anybody here when it
seems so natural and so obvious that
there would be an overriding
desire not to have this public and to
have everybody have the two of them
coordinate their stories that is the
president miss lewinsky if they were not
the faintest scintilla of any legal
proceeding coming about it just strikes
me as an overwhelming stretch
am i wrong to characterize it that way
you gentlemen all have greater
experience than i do i think you're
right and also the problem a prosecutor
would face would be that
in these cases there is a relationship
between these people unrelated to the
existence of the paula jones case
correct the relationship
do you agree with that did i just ask mr
well for a yes or no for a yes or no
answer on that can you answer that yes
or no governor i think it's a little
thin mr congressman thank you
again it's a specific intent crime and
the question is what was the president
thinking when he said this we can look
at his words and try and analyze his
words but miss curry says that she
didn't believe he was trying to
influence her and that if she'd said
something different from him if she
believed something different from him
she would have felt free to say it so
for that reason i believe you just don't
have the specific intent necessary to
prove obstruction of justice with regard
to the comment that you just asked me
manager hutchinson is keeping very good
company
he like the other prosecutors does not
believe the record before you
establishes obstruction of justice
we agree
before i close i do want to take a
moment to address the theme that the
house managers sounded
throughout their presentation last week
civil rights
they suggested that by not removing
the president from office
the entire house of civil rights
might well fall
while acknowledging that the president
is a good advocate for civil rights they
suggested that they had grave concerns
because of the president's conduct
in the paula jones case
and some managers suggested that we all
should be concerned
should the senate fail to convict the
president
because it will send a message
that our civil rights laws
and our sexual harassment laws are
unimportant
i can't let their
comments go unchallenged
i speak as but one woman but i know i
speak for others as well
i know i speak for the president
bill clinton's grandfather owned a store
his store catered primarily to african
americans apparently his grandfather was
one of only four white people in town
who would do business
with african-americans
and he taught his grandson
that the african-americans who came into
his store
were good people
and they worked hard
and they deserved a better deal in life
the president has taken his
grandfather's teachings to heart and he
has worked
every day
to give all of us a better deal
an equal deal
i'm not worried about the future of
civil rights
i'm not worried because miss jones had
her day in court
and judge wright determined that all of
the matters we are discussing here today
were not material to her case
and ultimately decided that ms jones
based on the facts in the law in that
case
did not have a case
against the president
i'm not worried
because we've had imperfect leaders in
the past
and we'll have imperfect leaders in the
future
but their imperfections did not roll
back nor did they stop
the march for civil rights and equal
opportunity for all of our citizens
thomas jefferson
frederick douglass
abraham lincoln
john f kennedy
martin luther king jr
we revere
these men
we should
but they were not perfect men
they made human errors
but they struggled to do humanity good
i'm not worried about civil rights
because this president's record on civil
rights
on women's rights
on all of our rights is unimpeachable
ladies and gentlemen of the senate you
have an enormous decision to make
and in truth there is little more i can
do
to lighten that burden
but i can do this
i can assure you
that your decision
to follow the facts
and the law
and the constitution
and acquit this president
will not shake the foundation of the
house of civil rights
the house of civil rights is strong
because its foundation is strong
and with all due respect
the foundation of the house of civil
rights was never at the core
of the jones case
it was never at the heart of the jones
case
the foundation of the house of civil
rights is in the voices
is in the voices of all the great civil
rights leaders and the soul of every
person who heard them
it's in the hands of every person who
folded a leaflet for change and it's in
the courage of every person who changed
it's here
in the senate
where men and women of courage and
conviction
stood for progress
were senators some of them still in this
chamber some of them who lost their
careers
looked to the constitution
listened to their conscience
and then did the right thing
the foundation of the house of civil
rights is in all of us who gathered up
our will
to raise it up
and keep on building
i stand here before you today because
others before me decided to take a stand
was one of my law professors so
eloquently says because someone claimed
my opportunities for me
by fighting for my right to have the
education i have
by fighting for my right to seek the
employment i choose
by fighting for my right to be a lawyer
by sitting in
and carrying signs
and walking long marches
riding freedom rides and putting their
bodies on the line for civil rights
i stand here before you today because
america decided
that the way things were
was not how they were going to be
we the people decided that we all
deserved a better deal
i stand here before you today because
president bill clinton believed
i could stand here
for him
your decision whether to remove
president clinton from office based on
the articles of impeachment i know will
be based on the law
and the facts
and the constitution
it would be wrong
to convict him on this record
you should acquit him
on this record
and you must not let imagined harms to
the house of civil rights
persuade you otherwise
the president did not obstruct justice
the president did not commit perjury
the president must not
be removed from office
the chair recognizes the majority leader
now i ask unanimous consent that on
thursday and friday have been ordered
for senators to introduce legislation
and to submit statements at the desk
during the senate's consideration of the
articles of impeachment
in the absence of objection that sword
and uh as chief justice i ask unanimous
consent that the appointments now at the
desk appear separately in the record as
if made by the chair
without objection it's so ordered and
once again i invite all senators to
attend the leader lecture series this
evening at six in the old senate chamber
uh as i've already announced former
president george bush will be the guest
speaker i ask unanimous senate now stand
in the german under the previous order
without objection it's so ordered
senate has now adjourned the fifth day
of